So,
shoot faster. Just a little bit of
energy. I want to try something better
right now. I guess the people falling
down.
Let's move this to Russ and see what
Papa thinks. It's such pathetic
neatness, but not for long cuz you'll
get
jinxed.
Hey,
hey, hey.
When I ask you, will you follow me
tonight to break their spine and reclaim
what once was mine.
Those cravers that stab me, deceive me,
never shall tolerate their crimes again.
Now let the hunt begin.
Yeah.
7,000 souls scared and daunted. Such a
terrible.
Not too long ago, this village was a
golden sea of hope
to bring back hope
to live forever.
Yeah. Bring down the dark regime. I know
how to unleash eternal power.
lead us to order. I am the lightbrer.
Yeah.
I am the lightbringer.
Now listen, fellow warriors, I ask you,
should my campaign come to an end,
there's way more to avenge.
Wow.
15 million souls living in this realm
without much hope. Not too long ago,
this kingdom was a golden state of home
to bring back hope and peace. store
to live forever.
Yeah.
Bring down the dark regime. I know how
to unleash eternal power.
Lead us to order. I am the lighter.
Heat. Heat.
Cold down the reckoning. Bring back hope
and peace. Restore our glor
to live forever.
Call down the reckoning to bring back
hope and peace. Restore our glory
to live forever.
Bring down the regime. I know how to
unleash eternal power.
Lead us to order. I am the light
bringer.
[__]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Hey,
heat. Hey.
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Come on. Come on.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Yeah.
Don't me.
Heat.
Bonjour high from Lan Pal. We are ready
for RQ Le. It's Riftbound time as 2,000
players have readied their decks and
joined us here in the venue for two days
of action to determine the second
European RQ champion. We're playing
Spirit Forge, but there's been a wave of
bands and that means we're in an all new
meta. Welcome everybody. I am James
Hill. I am joined today by Lothar to
bring you the beginning of the show and
Loi, it's going to be a great weekend.
How you feeling about Riftbound?
>> Super excited to be here. This is my
second regional, but first time on the
cast and I cannot be in a better
position to cast because of what you
mentioned. We have a brand new metag
game. We have bands. We have a lot of
people testing old but new kind of
decks. It's going to be a very
refreshing experience.
>> You know, the best thing about going
from the players seat to the caster
seat,
>> you already know you make day two.
>> Confession rate is through. You're good.
You'll be you'll be through the Swiss
rounds as well. Um, there's a lot to
play for, but in general, if you're a
Riftbound player this year, there are a
lot of events to play at, and that's
where I think we're going to start
because we're into the second wave now
of European regional qualifiers. Um,
here we are in Le, but that's only the
beginning of this road here as we go
through Atlanta next weekend. Uh, and
then we get ready to get unleashed.
>> That it's lovely expansion. I'm looking
forward to the pre-rip events, but it's
going to be a huge shakeup of the entire
meta game coming into Sydney and
Vancouver.
>> Yeah, and we've already had one shake up
with the bands, as you said, unleashed
there to shake things up as well through
the summer. We turn our attention later
in the year as well to another step
coming out that we're expecting a big
change to the meta with, and that is
Vendetta. I know you're looking forward
to those opposite color pairings, their
domains crushing together.
>> Those will be really awesome to look
forward to. Like for example, we're
going to have yellow and purple
together. Those decks have some really
nasty combinations and I'm really
looking forward to which we actually
have the which legends will be playable
in vendetta for that.
>> Unlike actual League of Legends Twisted
Fate players will be able to pull their
gold card at that point as if as if
that's not enough radiance to round out
later in the year before Los Angeles
later on. Um there is so much going on
throughout the rest of the year but we
need to focus on today. We're here for
for our RQ Le for Spirit Forged. So,
what does that mean for the players in
the venue? As I said, over 2,000 players
are locked in. Let's take a look at the
road that they have to cross in order to
make it to the finals to potentially
name themselves as the second European
champion. Well, today is a grueling
eight rounds of Swiss Lothar. You played
it last time. How was eight rounds for
you?
>> Uh, well, we had a little bit different
meta game that was a little bit slower
and people are still learning their
decks, I would say. You know, in this
meta game, I feel like people will
actually speed it up. they have a lot of
practice on their own decks and I feel
like because of that we're going to have
a little bit less of an endurance test
but it's still going to be an endurance
test and but that is like when you play
a TCG and you attend like a huge
tournament like this you actually have
to be mentally prepped to be ready to be
on top of a game for such a long period
of time.
>> Yeah, I hope our players had a good
breakfast here in AI. Uh it's eight
rounds of Swiss today and then tomorrow
another five rounds of Swiss followed by
the top eight. So, two days of backto
backto back riftbound action. And what
are they playing for, you might ask?
Well, let's take a look at our prize
pool for the weekend. Of course, this is
looking towards the champion for that
Blade of the Rune King uh promo, plus
the champion playmat. The top eight will
get themselves a a different Blade of
the Ruin King, but still cool promo. Uh
and everybody in the top 32 will have
prizing as well. You can see it broken
down on your screen. So, a lot to play
for Lothar, but this isn't all the
players are playing for. We also have
best of prizing as well. For the best of
every single legend, um, if you were
picking a champion to play, a legend to
play this weekend, what would you have
picked in a best of hunt?
>> Um, I would still play the thing that I
wanted to play in the main event, which
was Rexai. She's not super popular, but
at the same time, she's a very strong
deck at so you will have not that much
of a competition. it like when it comes
to the plated foil legends, I feel like
most of the legends are going to be
around 2% of the population, right? And
Rexai probably will be around like four
to six% in the main event.
>> Well, we'll keep our eyes on the race
for those plated legends throughout the
weekend. It's going to be a lot of
action for Riftbounder. We'll keep all
of the stories as much in hand as we
possibly can. But in order to help us do
that, in order to help us keep the
temperature of the room, the attendees,
the players gunning for those metal
cards, we've brought in some additional
help. We've got somebody ganking in,
supporting us in the bot lane here on
the broadcast, and that is Barcode, who
I want to say hello to right now.
>> Thank you guys. Now, if you're going to
make it here today, no worries. We've
got you covered. I'm Barcode and all
weekend long I'm going to be right here
in the venue to bring you as close to
the action as possible. Players
interviews, behind the scenes, main
events, side events, even in the middle
of the crowd. I'm going to be everywhere
to make sure you experience the
tournament as you're here with us.
Because trust me, this event is shaping
up to be something incredible. the level
of competition, the players, the
atmosphere, everything is here for an
incredible weekend of Reebound. So stick
with us. We're just getting started.
That being said, I'm going to hand it
over to our wonderful dwarf
commentators, James Gems. Lothther, take
it away.
>> Thank you very much, Barcode. Um, I
can't wait to hear more about the
stories and the players out on the
floor. Lothar,
we've been around together in esports
for so long. getting the stories of the
players is one of the most important
parts but fascinating parts of esports
and having 2,000 players in the room is
crazy. Like I I don't know about you,
but but my eyes on players to watch just
my list is like 25 30 40 players. Yeah,
there's a it's funny when you say that
because so many people have history in
esports as well. They can, you know,
transfer to different games, but the the
experience that they have actually holds
weight behind them, right? So, we're
going to have a lot of like for example,
Ellen Zik, the winner of the previous
regional. He is an avid Legend of Runa
player, right? We have accolades there
as well. And because of that, it's so
interesting to follow their footsteps,
but we're going to have more and more
and more players with each tournament.
So, after this one, we're probably going
to have few new players that we're going
to be now also looking forward to in the
next regional qualifier.
>> Yeah, exactly. Uh, you know, turns out
being a world champion in Legends of
Rune Terror,
>> it's a transferable skill into being
able to be pretty good at Riftbound, um,
that's Allen's road to being a champion,
but your road to being a champion can
start in your local game store, and that
is with the pathway to a regional
qualifier. So, you want to start out,
test out your decks at the Nexus Knight.
Scan the QR code on screen in order to
find out where your local Nexus Knight
is. And when you're ready, join your
Summoner Skirmish. And when you summon a
skirmish, not only do you get some cool
promos, a playmat, but you also get to
skip round one. You get more time for
breakfast at a regional qualifier. So,
you already come into the event one and
zero, and you can be on your path to
potentially dethroning Allen's CQ at an
RQ champion. You know, stranger things
have happened.
>> Yeah, look, I will tell you one thing.
Skipping round one of original qualifier
is really a huge thing. Not only you're
trying to like avoid some random happen
stance and playing around some random
decks, right? you're going to be saving
an hour probably of your mental when it
comes to the entire duration of the day.
That is huge. That is huge in when it
comes to your performance. So, winning a
summoner skirmish, playing in your local
game store is actually really pivotal
into performing in the original
qualifier.
>> Absolutely. I mean, you mentioned um
this now being the second event, people
being more used to their decks. That's
something that as somebody who follows
competitive games in general is such a
big part of it. It's like bologonia.
People were making decisions around, you
know, what cards do I want to take from
a stack deck? Quite slow. Now I'm
expecting you to know. You see three
cards, you know what card you want from
your deck. Like we're going to be able
to go faster, be you, you know, used to
what you're playing. Um, there is a bit
of a change for this meta though, and I
think we have to get into the meat of
what has changed between Bolognia and
Le. Uh, so Lothar, we've had seven cards
banned, and it has shaken up the meta.
I'll run you through them for those of
you maybe that missed the announcement.
So, four cards banned, three
battlefields. The cards banned, Scrap
Heap, Fight or Flight, Corn Shot, and
Draven Vanquisher. The battlefields
being banned, Reaver's Row, Obelisk of
Power, and the Dreaming Tree. So, that's
pretty much the seven cards that were in
some of the top decks. Um, I'm going to
give you a very open question. Locar,
what would you say is the biggest change
from those seven bands? I would say
probably obisk of power even though cold
shot is like an very obvious answer
where I was like oh man cold shot is
played in so many decks and is actually
making the deck so consistent but the
thing is obvious of power was such a
popular uh battlefield I think it was
52% of the entire field in the previous
region right so when you think about it
and half of the field is playing one
battlefield that also makes the deck
skip one turn essentially and speed up
the game play by to some degree Right.
It makes the game a little bit more
predictable. And I feel like the entire
bands here are tailored toward making
the game a little bit less predictable
and a little bit more like a card game
and not just a solitaer that you try to
solve, you know.
>> Yeah, that that's a very fair way of of
looking at it. We saw, as you said, a
lot of uh Obeliska power in the previous
regional. I think one deck that does
mean will have an effect on. Uh it
didn't win the last event, but it came
second. I know Aurora players, I'm one
of you. Uh, I know we're not feeling so
great right now where Aurora is placed
in the meta. So, that's a deck we'll
come back to if we end up seeing it.
But, I think we have to turn our
attention potentially to Draven, the
elephant in the room from many events.
Uh, Draven Vanquisher, the champion, the
chosen champion of that deck, has been
banned, but it isn't enough to take it
away.
>> No, Draven is going to be very popular
today, and that's going to be very
interesting as well to see how people
adapt to how their decks is being
changed, right? How the their decks are
being affected by the bands. For Draven
Miracle, we not expect any Draven
Miracle at all. But what you do expect
is the mid-range version of Draven. But
now the adaptation is going to be a
little bit more interesting because many
people are pivoting to more two drops
because they need to hit the uh curve of
their deck more often. So instead of
like having eight drops uh eight drops,
sorry, going to have like nine two
drops. But then we're also going to
maybe have some decks fill out the curve
on turn two because now we don't have
the drape and vanquisher. So maybe we're
going to see some Rex size being played
in that spot to also have a pairing with
like a one energy card stack deck on
turn two with Rex size. Pretty good
opener. We have possibilities with like
Gust for example as well. I've seen some
Madrid Dravens actually pack the Gust
because when you think about it, Gust is
also drawing you a card when you're
winning combat against the two drop for
example. Right? So there's synergy
there. The biggest question is like how
do you not miss the gap in your energy
curve on that spot where Draven Vancouer
was and now it's gone.
>> That's a good question and a question
we'll endeavor to answer throughout the
weekend. Those of you expecting to see
Allen's exact Ezreal deck, we'll talk
about this more later. Don't expect to
see that lineup exactly. The Vex out.
Ezreal has a different deck, but we have
plenty of time to talk about the meta as
we go through the day. But for now, I'm
going to send it back over to Barcode
for an interview.
>> Yeah, actually I'm with one of the best
players in the room, right? Dining
Kamong, one of the most outstanding
players on lot of TCG and now on
Reebound. How do you feel today?
>> Yeah. Um I feel uh super tired because I
tried to learn more about the game
because I started two days ago. So, uh,
yeah, I hope it will go well and that
I'm, uh, going out positive, you know,
like not not a bad score, but like a
five two or 53 or whatever.
>> I'm sure that you can do that. I mean,
you have a lot of background in the TCG
history. So, you started two days ago.
Are you still confident that you can win
it all?
>> No.
>> Not confident? Like, how? Uh, the game
is really complex. Um, you need a lot of
games, a lot of reps to get all the
dynamics in because like one situation
can change by like one card or something
a lot of times and then you have to
actually play it out to know what you
need to do. But I had no time so yeah, I
don't know.
>> Yeah, it actually makes sense. And just
for the entire crowd, which legend did
you decide to play today?
>> Uh, Draven, that makes a lot of sense
actually. Thanks a lot. We are going to
let you go to your table because the
round is going to start real soon. Guys,
take it away.
>> Thank you very much, Barcode. I That is
one of the fascinating things. I mean,
we're sitting here. Your background in
TCGs and and digital card games goes,
you know, a way back.
>> I am old.
>> So am I. It's okay. Uh my background is
in League of Legends and Wild Drift. Um
we have players in the room from
different card games, uh different uh
esports personalities. I mean, I know
Yamato Cannon for League of Legends fans
is floating around playing in the main
event today. So, we have just people
from all different backgrounds and okay,
maybe maybe two days notice is is maybe
not enough for your road to an argument.
But, I mean, Stranger Things have
happened. Being good at a game is a
transferable skill there.
>> It is like it's especially important in
the early stages of the game and I would
consider Riftbound still very early
stage of the game. We are learning the
rules of the game. The rift bound is so
fundamentally different from any cod any
other card game that I've ever played in
my entire life that a your experience
still is transferable but the game when
you're adapting to it it's really it
shines through when you can plan out the
game very early and you go ahead of the
other players because they do not
understand the fundamentals of the game
yet.
>> That's such an important point. Uh, and
I think that's happened significantly at
least twice so far. I think the move
from set one to set two of understanding
how to avoid Draven in combat was huge
and and changed people's understanding.
And then Allan blew all of our minds in
Bolognia and saying, "Hey, if I just
move Vex into a showdown, I can just
play all of these spells basically for
free and do everything I want and you
can't do anything."
>> You want a funny story?
>> I do. I always want a funny story. when
sets 2 was releasing uh actually before
the release but we had the spoiler
season. I was speaking with Alan and I
was telling him yo this Vex card is
really nasty and he was like no it's
garbage man.
>> I've heard the same story Kasanova said
the same where he was like I'm trying to
convince him that Vex is good. My my
funny story on that and it has nothing
to do with being right and everything to
do with loving that archetype of card uh
for Bolognia. They were like hey what
cards do you want to say that you like
from Spirit forge? And I was like I love
Vex. No one's going to play it, but I
think it's a really cool card. And there
it is on the graphic on day one. And
everyone's like, "Wow, how did you
predict that?" And I'm like, I'm just a
degenerate when it comes to like not
wanting my opponent to play cards. I
just want you to have to pay more and I
want to play it for free.
>> Vex is nasty when you think about it in
different terms. Like the Vex cheerless
on the battlefield acts like like a
proactive counter spell
>> and also speeds up your own energy like
essentially like resources, right? How
do you even explain that? It just makes
you your spells cheaper, right? So, you
can sling the spells at the same time,
but your opponent is not enticed to
actually play anything. It's incredibly
powerful, but you have to find a way of
putting her into the battlefield as soon
as possible. And sometimes those combos
are, for example, like Vex into right
the wind. So, immediately move Vex into
the showdown or and you do it I also
action speed. So, you can do it during a
different showdown as well. It's
incredibly powerful combination. That
was the crazy thing for me at least
watching that is like not thinking about
the 4D chess of doing it to other things
on the battlefield uh while you were in
a showdown. Um as I mentioned before we
went to the interview. Allan's specific
Ezreal deck list from last time did get
hit heavily with the bands things like
uh I believe Allan was playing like
scrap heap to discard with
>> No, he actually was not playing scrap.
>> So it's the shot.
>> The cold shot was very important in his
deck list. So even your there was also
an interaction with Vex and Culture when
you could and Bellow's breath as well
when you can play essentially them for
free and that was incredibly powerful.
So now that's not possible as well. But
Allan is on a quest to win all of the
plated foil legends of Ezreal. So he
definitely has a different type of
Ezreal that will work.
>> Yes. And I I don't know whether it's
Allen's because we haven't seen deck
list yet. So this is not spoiling
Allen's specific deck. just to talk
about Ezreal as an archetype. Right now,
what we have seen in recent days is what
people are calling a tempo Ezreal. So,
you mentioned Gusts within the Draven
deck. We know it's come into the Ezreal
as well as some some units that have
like a gust built in. So, the whole deck
revolves around like lowering the might
of your opponent's units in order to be
able to gust them out of of a
battlefield.
>> Not only that, you can also use it use
it on your own units. And that's where
the skill of these of this deck will
shine through because again Allan chose
if he's playing the temp as a ro tempo
it's one of those decks when your
efficiency with it your experience with
the deck will carry you through knowing
when do you have to use the gust or
rinsing on your own unit or your
opponent's unit. How do you get more
value out of the small creatures that
your deck is running? because the
biggest one is going to be watcher, but
other than that, all of the units are
essentially two to three might and then
you have a student that just grows
during your turn. But the thing is that
you have to do is you have to plan ahead
to make sure you get the most value out
of your units, get the most value out of
your fizz as well, so you're replaying
the spells. And there's so many
sequencing um sequencing like order that
matters in this deck. It's incredibly
different when you see a novice playing
this deck. and incredibly different when
you play a seasoned veteran of this
deck.
>> That's my favorite thing. I'm not going
to be too shady to the people at my
locals, but a bunch of them after
Bolognia were like, I'm gonna play
Ezreal. It's such a good deck. I saw
everybody's locals did this as well. And
then they play the deck and I'm like,
how do you get through more than two
games? You can't even finish the second
game cuz you're like, okay, I've got to
look at three cards. Which one do I
want? Okay, I got to look at two cards.
Now I got to look at two cards. Like the
number of game actions in those Ezreal
decks is insane. Um, but Ezreal is not
perhaps the deck we're looking at to be
in control of the meta this event. Some
players will play Ezreal, but I think
most represented deck in the room seems
to be Aurelia. Looking at the early
stats, which is not surprising, but it
is a different deck to play against than
an Ezreal than a Draven. So, so Loa,
talk to me about Aelia. How do you like
it positioned for this event?
>> I think which is funny because she got
hit hard with the bands. uh the
battlefields affected her ability to
draw cards, but at the same time, the
deck that was praying on her the most
was mid-range Draven. and mid-range
Draven, even though it's still going to
be popular in the metag game with fully
expecting like around 15 to maybe 20% of
of the field is going to be mid-range
Draven. Um, Elia now has a this spot of
the tempo where she will have a
possibility of coming back early in the
game where the Draven might miss a drop,
might not be as efficient as he was
before. Because before if you have a two
drop with Draven, turn two is 99% of the
games it's going to be Draven Vanquisher
and your curve is looking incredible.
Now, Urelia has that doesn't have that
weakness anymore. It's still not a great
um matchup, but because we have a green
purple deck that has access to Stella
Herders, you can still have an
incredibly full hand. And when the
Aurelia is able to play with full amount
of energy and like seven cards in hand,
you basically cannot go through an Aelia
that goes to like 17 might.
>> Well, we'll see how Aelia fares
throughout the day. We'll keep our eyes
on the meta. It's time to get into round
one. We'll stop talking. We'll go over
to our casters, Blevens and Amy.
>> Hello everyone and welcome to round
number one regional qualifier le. I am
Blevens joined with Amy and we have got
some great matches coming up here for
our regional qualifier here. Brand new,
I call it set 2.5 meta. I'm really
excited, Amy.
>> It really does feel like that, doesn't
it, with the bands and how they're going
to shape and change things and allow
people to bring this new life and
ingenuity to their decks. I'm really
excited because we're going to have,
like you say, that kind of 2.5 meta that
allows us to see something completely
new.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean, we've seen the
meta already shift. We've got a little
bit of uh insight from the super uh
regional qualifier, pre- regional
qualifier yesterday, which was awesome.
And this is a really interesting round
because this is round one. This means
you didn't win a skirmish. You don't
have a buy. So, this is where the real
dedication comes and shines through. We
are seeing the players who are going to
be playing the full eight rounds today.
This is the start of that journey. It's
a long old day and they've got a long
way ahead of them. But this is where the
grind sets in for those who either
weren't able to get to a skirmish or
they have a particularly tough local
scene. They are going to have that first
round to really battle through with
everybody else in the room. And
honestly, I've seen some fantastic decks
floating around looking around this
morning. There have been so much cooking
going on at home. And we saw that even
from the pre- rift yesterday um with
what Darius having a fantastic
conversion which was unexpected. Um oh
let me think Rumble had a fantastic
conversion.
>> Yeah we did hear an interesting fact
about Rumble.
>> I love interesting facts
>> which was that Rumble believe it or not
this is true. Stats can't lie had a
better conversion rate at that event
than Kaisa did.
>> You're joking. You're joking. Really?
That's wonderful. That's wonderful.
That's what we want to hear. That's the
stories that we want. Now, admittedly,
the disparity between people playing
those decks in numbers, maybe they're a
little bit off, but regardless, it still
shows that they have good conversion
rates if you are dedicated enough to
making that archetype work.
>> Absolutely. That's the beauty of
Riftbound. But Amy, we have got our
players here. We've got a deck list for
our very first player here. Let's take a
look. What are we going to be watching?
Ah, ask and you shall receive. This is
of course my specialty deck. It is
Lucian. Amy, we get to see Lucian in
round one. I'm so happy.
>> I You were saying, "Oh, I don't know if
I want to see Lucian in round one
because I have so much to say about
Lucian." But you know what? I think it's
a great way to start the day with some
action pack. one of the legends that
kind of really benefited from those
bands because the cards that really
targeted it down uh are gone and so it's
got that momentum now. And honestly,
this these gearled decks are proving
their stuff now. They've got the
strengths to stick on in it and we're
seeing more gear removal because of that
in our opponents.
>> Absolutely. I think Lucian I mean again
I'm biased. I was on Lucian for
Bolognia. played the full day one as
Lucian. I'm a Lucian believer. I thought
he was good before. I think he's even
better now. Like you said,
>> I really think that he benefited from
the bands or I guess not really getting
hit too much from the bands. Other decks
getting hit from the bands and there's a
deceptive amount of play in Lucian. I
think a lot of players see Lucian
thought it was an aggressive deck, kind
of a mindless aggressive deck. It is not
that. There is a lot of play. There is a
lot to do there. And we are ready to
jump on it. And it is Illusian versus
Aurelia. Here we go. We're not we're not
quite ready. Players are getting ready,
but we see it is against Aurelia. So,
this is a true test right from round
one. Amy, Lucian versus Aurelia.
>> You love to see it. You know, Lucian
does have a lot of tricks up their
sleeve and the combos that they can pull
out just take Aurelia by surprise. And I
think that's what it's all about is
you're playing her at her own game.
Let's take a look at her deck list
today.
>> Yeah, I'm taken by surprise right here.
jumps right out to me. Seal of focus in
Aurelia, this is a new iteration that
I've actually not even seen yet. I mean,
one of the things about Aurelia, it is a
very, very powerhungry deck. So, you are
able to have that seal out, get that
seal early. I mean, we've seen the seal
of discord played a lot in Ezreal decks
and other the the miracle decks before.
Those decks are super power hungry.
Aelia no different here. playing the
seal of focus to be able to pay for
those defies to be able to pay for the
blade dancer ability the guardian angels
all of that if you can get one seal out
all of a sudden you're getting a huge
discount on your power for the whole
game
>> and if you look at those if you look at
those power costs if we're looking at
power cost versus our energy actually
the payoff for that seal of focus is
gigantic when we're looking at how many
resources we're going to save overall
and how much that's going to be able to
swing the game back in our favor when
we're really trying to play that protect
the princess and you don't want to run
out of resources. You need to be a
little bit more careful
>> that could really come into play.
>> Absolutely. I mean, we saw there's a lot
of different variations of Aurelia. I've
not seen the one with the seals. I like
this. It's running three charms in the
main. Not necessarily a a standard pick
from before, but here, three charms in
the main is huge, especially against
Lucian. I mean, as the Lucian player,
you play out your Lucian, you think it's
fine. No, they're going to move in a
unit. They're going to charm it over and
you are not great. And but Amy, we are
ready for round number one. We're going
to be jumping into the game here. Lucian
versus Aurelia RQ Leil round number one.
>> I wonder which battlefields are going to
get chosen out of those three. Let's
have a look what we've got. We've got
Forge of the Fluffed and Tarans Peak.
>> Yes, this is a very very good
battlefield for Lucian especially. They
are running the they are running the
expensive equipment a lot of those
expensive equipment and expensive to
equip costs there.
>> So that forge of the fluff if you can
control that forge of the fluff you can
all of a sudden start to
actually equip those equipment for free
which is really great.
>> Yeah. I mean, just giving yourself all
of the power when it comes to equipment,
cuz that's where the big combos come in
with this deck is being able to equip
multiple equipments and really kind of
take that jump into the driver's seat.
>> Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, the this
matchup in general, the way that I've
seen it play out is both of these decks
are really good at doing the same thing.
They both want to conquer two
battlefields and then get off of those
battlefields. You do not want to engage
in combat really against either of those
decks. They both have a lot of combat
tricks. I mean, that's Aurelia's bread
and butter right there. So, they're both
doing that. So, what is hard to do as
those decks sometimes is get back into
the game if you fall behind. Well,
Lucian has the ability to score two
points with a single conquer with that
combo. That is Lucian's signature, not
literally signature, but the signature
gameplay. And with that signature spell,
Realms Pursuit, you can even conquer
four points in a single turn, which is
quite crazy.
>> It's bonkers. And that's exactly what
they're going to be ramping up towards.
But jumping right into our round one
here in Le um Adib heading on with just
one singular lonely porro to start us
off. And of course, our trusted stack
deck. One of the most powerful cards for
being able to not only see more of your
deck, but get information and cherrypick
that perfect hand.
>> Yeah. And we see a very standard play on
the side of Lucian. Play out that
Doran's blade. And guess what? You've
always got that Lucian in your chosen
champion if you want. He's got weapon
master. He's going to come down. He's
going to immediately become equipped
with that Doran's blade and then pass
turn it. And this is great. And a lot of
times the Lucian will come out without
an equipment out and against a deck like
Aurelia, you can really get punished by
charms here. Now it's going to be a lot
harder to punish this Lucian now that
he's five based and then when he's
attacking, he's actually six because of
the assault from the Legend there.
Lonely Portal going to come in, conquer
that Targon's Peak, which is really,
really scary as Aelia because now they
can use their resources here and they're
going to have two up no matter what at
the end of this turn.
>> Yeah. And you don't really want to be
giving that to Aurelia. It's a great
battlefield to be able to utilize cuz
you can spend all your power now. You
don't have to worry about that energy.
You can just get that sorted for later.
Now Aurelia is going for a little bit of
ramp with find your center which will
allow us to channel runes exhausted and
draw cards. A fantastic early game card,
but unfortunately doesn't leave a lot
more for us to go with this turn.
>> Yeah, I I I do like the the call out
here from Aurelia. They're saying, "Hey,
a lot of times you're you have five
energy. Let's play that chosen champion,
Aurelia." Well, it can be very scary
against Lucian because they've got cards
like challenge that can hit the Aurelia
in the backline. And if your Aurelia
gets challenged, if you you exhaust all
of your runes for an Aelia and it gets
challenged, you are.
>> Here comes the first sabotage. We're
going to get to look at our opponent's
hand and pluck a card out. Ooh, going
for the hard bargain.
>> Yeah, well, we got a card out. It just
was not uh maybe the one that Lucian
wanted to choose, but that's okay. Still
got a card there. We're going to go in
and attack this lonely Porro. And the
sad sad Porro does in fact die there.
But
>> he get to draw a card for their for
their sorrow.
>> And that's the first point scored for
Janick as we continue. Of course,
bringing Lucian back into base. You very
well assess that that's where Lucian is
safest. And both of these decks are
actually decks that do that incredibly
well. Bringing back to base, protecting
their units, making sure that they're
staying strong. and then jumping in and
out of battlefields in order to score
points, which is where I think this
charm version of Aurelia is going to
possibly take Janick by surprise by
being the aggressor.
>> Mhm. Absolutely. And we saw the Kai'Sa
could have actually been accelerated
there and gotten that second point, but
that Aurelia in the champ does not
matter. It can come from nowhere. And
with Aurelia Blade Dancer, you're able
to effectively accelerate any one of
your units. And that's just going to
leave the Kai'Sa sitting as a sitting
duck, which is not where you want to be.
>> Here comes the gear on Adam's side.
We've got, of course, our boots of
swiftness and our guardian angel, but
nothing to equip them to yet.
>> Yeah, we're playing we're playing very
cautious here. As we can see, I I I got
a peak of the hand a little bit. I
didn't see a lot of units there. So,
ahead of here is is setting up building
up to, like you said, protect that
princess. So when the time is right,
we're going to see that Aurelia come out
and it's going to be a matter of how far
behind are there and how much damage can
they do on the back swing to this
Lucian.
>> So true. Over again to Janick's turn and
now it's whether we want to take both
battlefields or not. Going in with a
Kaiser, seeing for a response and does
have three active energy that could be
utilized.
>> Just taking a few notes. I love that the
players are taking every moment to
themselves to be able to check what the
optimum moves are. Ooh, now that is such
a special card in this deck.
>> Yep, that's the Skyfall of Arian, which
is half of the combo. It turns your hold
effects into conquer effects and vice
versa. And when paired with the Trinity
Force switch, oh by the way, there it
is. Wombo combo. There it is. We're
going to be equipping that to Lucian.
And that is going to score not one but
two points here for the Lucian. And
guess what? That's going to trigger
Targon's Peak. And
>> as well,
>> Lucian's going to be able to get out of
there.
>> Oh my gosh. Lucian jumping in, scoring
two points, and then readying to be able
to jump back into the base. And that's
exactly what this deck's trying to do.
Jump in and out, shake it all about,
score two points, and be as safe as
possible. Can Adib do anything to combat
this flurry of points happening on the
other side of the board?
>> It's going to have to happen now because
like I said, we're we're already
threatening to score three points next
turn, which would put us to seven if we
have something like a uh Reliance
Pursuit. We may even be able to win on
Adam's next turn. So,
>> Adam does not have the luxury of time
anymore. The time is now and we're going
to need to really start to accelerate
this game for Adab or else it's going to
end and we're going to go to game number
two.
>> It's got to happen now. A really had to
come out to play. Will Adab have enough
resources, enough combat tricks to be
able to stop Janick from just well doing
just that, jumping in and out, getting
all of those points. Going to draw some
more cards. Of course, we are able to
attach these equipment and just boost
Aurelia up, which is exactly what we
want to do. But I think here really
poses a difficult question of do you
target down the Kaiser or do you just
try and take targets peak to be able to
not only further your own advantage, but
kind of prevent your opponent from being
able to respond?
>> Yeah, this is a this is a moment here
where I I really like this play. This
maybe is a bit soft to a card like punch
first, but Adam is not in a position to
play around a lot of cards. That's true.
Adam is in the position to say, "If
you've got punch first and I don't have
an answer for it, all right, let's go to
game two." I'm not going to change that.
Me saying that you don't have punch
first, it doesn't exist. It can't hurt
me. Is not going to help him if it
appears to say, "Hey, you know what? It
can't hurt me. If you have it, let's go.
Let's go game two. If not, I'm going to
at least put myself in a position to try
to win here."
>> That's so true. But it was a difficult
decision. I feel like going for that
Kaiser knowing that there are two energy
on the other side ready to go. that
punch burst of looming and so being able
to actually now take that battlefield
taking that forge of the fluff huge turn
for Adib. The potential for a comeback
is in sight.
>> Yeah. Now Adab is is deciding are they
going to equip the boots of swiftness
here?
>> Yeah, they are.
>> They absolutely are.
And the question is, are we going to
ready the It looks like we are even
going to ready the Aelia. We're going to
be spending our power here. We're going
to ready the Aurelia and then be able to
gank over to that Targon's Peak. We're
getting back into the game in terms of
points here. We're going to get that
Targon's Peak
>> proc.
>> Yep, there we go.
>> Yep. And then we're going to go into the
next turn and hopefully have some
resources to defend here.
>> And that's what it's all about now. Now
that Aurelia is out and about, we need
to keep her super safe. And that's kind
of what Lucian wants to do as well.
hard
on top and I think that this
>> relatively unit light decks. Uh as we
can see the Aurelia has nothing else
here. If that Aelia goes down, that is
it for Adip right now. I believe there
may be another unit or two in the
Lucian's hand, but as it stands right
now, only the Lucian on the board. It is
of course threatening to score two
points per conquer. And I see a gem
jammer which is and there's a sabotage.
>> Oh, that's going to hit hard and
>> use the coast clear.
>> Defy.
>> Not going to know yet. Not quite going
to know yet.
Hand knowledge is such a ginormous
advantage when you're coming up with a
situation exactly like this where you
don't know whether it's safe for you to
move in on uh the target's pig, whether
it's worth challenging that Aurelia
because that would kind of sum up the
game for Janick. That would be
colossally saying I am in the leading
position here. However, there are some
fantastic cards in hand. do have the
ability to score multiple points here
and so it's all about those risks versus
rewards at this stage.
>> Yeah, and Adam has the can have the read
that there's not likely a punch first in
hand. It would have almost certainly
came out last turn. So, they know that
that is a bit of a safe uh safe line
there. Again, they don't really have the
ability to play around too much, but
Yanick can actually go for the win here.
And I think that's what they're trying
to decide. How big does this Lucian need
to be to actually try to win? Are they
going to try to engage this Aurelia in
combat, which is as someone who's tried
to do it many times, it is not always a
winning proposition.
>> No, it's not an easy feat. And look at
those cards in hand. We've got
discipline. We've got to ride the wind
as well. So, you know, Adam does have
three cards in hand, four standing
runes. That's scary when you're looking
down at an Aelia deck. You know that
they've got so much flexibility within
that.
>> Do you have enough resources if you're
Janick right now to pull a win forward?
And that's exactly what Lucian's always
trying to do is use these tricks to get
extra points, push themselves forward,
and not allow their opponent the
opportunity to respond with gaining
points of their own.
>> Yeah. And we see here, we see Janick
going in and attacking. Lucian is a 11
might right now,
>> which is quite big.
>> Yeah, as you can imagine,
>> that's more than one, you know.
That's two ones stood up next to each
other which gets much much bigger. And
now Adam has to decide, are they going
to try to ride the wind? Looks like not.
So that's going to be two more points
for Lucian here. It's going to ready the
Lucian. And now they have to decide, are
they going to try to go for the win
here? The gem jammer would be able to
give the Lucian ganking allow them to
attack over
>> Trinity Force.
>> And we're just going to attach that.
We'll get to ready Lucian and we're
going to go back to base. We're playing
it safe and I like this especially for a
game one of potentially three. Playing
it safe knowing that you're so far ahead
at this stage. Six
>> is
>> a lot more than three. I can tell you
that for me and it's really going to be
putting Janick
>> in the driver's seat and Adam is really
going to struggle to kind of challenge
that Lucian at all.
>> Yes. One thing about Aurelia, it does
not do a great job of defending,
especially defending two battlefields.
And normally, you know, you can set up a
game state where you have a gigantic
Aurelia. Even if your opponent is trying
to hold onto the battlefield, you can
usually move the Aurelia and get it big
enough to contest. Well, Lucian gets to
circumvent that. They can conquer one
battlefield at this point. And uh it's
going to be three points. And yes, in
fact, that can be the winning point. It
will be if they don't find a way to deal
with this Lucian or to at least put a
couple of units into a battlefield, but
it's not looking likely at this point.
We've got a at least one unit in hand
there from that stack deck, but I don't
know if it's going to be enough. Not
only would we need to ready that unit,
move it into targets peak, but then I
don't know if we're going to have enough
energy remaining to be able to use
combat tricks to deal with this Lucian.
>> I don't know. I may have miss seen a
card. I can't. Is that No, it's Ride the
Wait. I thought it might be Rebuke,
which could have actually been a charm
into Rebuke. The Lucian could actually
get added back in this game, but that is
not the case. It is going to have to be
a ride the wind to try to catch the
Lucian on the Lucian's attack with all
of those equipment. It's not a It's not
an easy thing to do, but it is something
that may need to have to happen in order
to prevent this win from happening. two
equipment to five. When we're looking at
heavy equipment decks that rely on it to
buff your units to have those extra
power notions to overwhelm the opponent,
it really does go to show how much of a
back foot Adib is on right now.
>> We're cashing in the discipline now.
Certainly must be looking for something
here or trying to get the Aurelia big
enough to try to contest the Lionus and
maybe be able to charm it in. Feel like
that was a charm, but it's not quite
enough on its own.
>> Oh, I think it's two charms. Oh, that is
the first charm may be necessary. The
second charm is not one that you are
looking to to have. Here
>> we are going to ride the wind, the
Aurelia here.
>> We'll get the
>> send it back over
>> and ready.
>> We can't leave. We can't leave a
battlefield. That's the thing. We just
got to keep making Aurelia as big as
possible.
>> Yes. Okay. Okay, I see I see the vision
here.
>> I see the vision. We are making Aurelia
as big as possible and we are taking the
fight now. Might as well try to take the
fight on Lucian when they don't have a
lot of resources up here. But is it
enough?
>> They calculate the assault on Lucian.
That is a very familiar sign I've seen
as a Lucian player, which is turning my
legend around for them to see. It gives
the Salta every piece of equipment,
which means that's an additional plus
one. And that looks like in fact Lucian
is 18.
>> 18.
Oh my goodness gracious. An extra
assault per
equipment.
>> That is just phenomenal. And Aurelia I
don't think is going to be able to get
big enough. And there it is. We take it
away with Janx Lucian taking game one of
our round one here in Le. Like I've been
saying it this whole time, Lucian's a
great deck, fantastic deck. Uh I mean,
we saw it play out exactly how you draw
it up. When you are playing Lucian, you
want to get some early board presence.
You're getting either ahead naturally or
get that combo to get ahead on the
points there. So, uh really well played
by, uh by the Lucian player and I mean
really valiant effort on the side of
Aurelia as well. I mean had the vision
in in mind there. just didn't, you know,
wasn't it was not in the cards. There we
are seeing the sideboard here for Jana
coming in. We get some Ferst forunners,
unyielding spirits. Uh we got Piercing
Lights and Aan Ashan particularly
devastating against Urelia when you can
steal that guardian angel.
>> Yeah, that's really not what you want to
be happening when you're Aurelia. So, I
think that's quite impactful right now.
I think they might just be wiggling
their way into the deck and having a few
extra units that have kind of okay power
levels are also really helpful against
Aurelia. What in this lineup for addive
feels like is going to be a troublesome
card for Lucian?
>> Yeah, I I can see the factory recall
which is a great card if you are going
all in on the combo or expecting to have
one of your equipments win this combat
for you as Lucian. Well, factory recall
is an action speed card that can
actually target those equipment for that
combat, which is a lot of times good
enough. If you can kill a Lucian with a
factory recall, that is fantastic as the
Aurelia. I mean, the Gust is okay. We
saw more Rebukes. There's not really too
much that Lucian can do against Rebuke.
It's uh it is almost a hard counter to
what they are doing in a lot of the a
lot of the cases here. So, I think that
sideboard wise, Aurelia gets a lot more
in against Lucian than vice versa. I
tell you what, I'm actually really
surprised at how that game one went
down. I think we're going to see a very
different game two. Adam's deck is
actually very well teched for Lucian
that's got so many tips and tricks that
you don't expect when going into Aelia
>> that actually we and we didn't see a lot
of those either. And that's the great
thing about how short that game was. It
actually does give Adib a little bit of
an advantage when you're thinking about
Janick doesn't know what cards are in
Adib's deck. And that is still the case
because they didn't show too much.
>> They didn't unnecessarily play cards
which then reveals to your opponent your
possible strategy into their deck. So
actually not only having cards in the
sideboard that your opponent's going to
not be expecting, but also not revealing
too much during game one could be huge
for a comeback and making that extra
push to pull ahead.
>> Yeah, I mean seeing one charm in the
main not uncommon. I mean it may not be
in the you could see a deck with one
charm in Aelia. You wouldn't you
wouldn't bat an eye at it. Three charms
though, you're not necessarily expecting
that and that's what we see here. And it
is, like I said, quite good against
Lucian. We're going to have a lot more
tricks there against the Lucian. Lucian
does get to bring in a little bit there.
They have the, as we saw, sabotages in
the main, which are quite good. That
hand knowledge just so so strong against
Aurelia specifically. If you can I mean,
it's not easy to do the math, but if you
could if you could see the math laid
out, you at least have the opportunity
to do the math there. And uh it makes
these attacks a lot more smooth as the
Lucian player
>> and knowing what the risks are. And
you've got that risk versus reward when
you're playing Lucian. When do I push
forward? Do they have any gear removal?
What how do I make sure that I am
keeping this Lucian with all this lovely
gear attached
>> in play? And if you know what's in their
hand,
>> you know exactly what could come your
way. And so if you go ahead and just
have a cheeky peek, then it's all going
to be okay. But as we saw in that game,
>> the opponent was not laying letting that
happen. Not even once was a single card
looked at. Instead, it was, "No, I
really don't want you to see that."
>> And it really shows why
>> it's such a powerful resource in this
game is hand knowledge. If your opponent
is going, "No, I'm going to spend this
resource instead to stop you from doing
that."
>> You know, it's strong.
>> Oh, absolutely. I mean, having the I
mean, that's the the really the power of
Aellia. Not just having the all of those
pump spells, but your opponent not
knowing what you do and don't have and
even cards like discipline. It's like
you can have one card in hand. I'll play
discipline. Draw a card. Oh, I drew
another discipline. There's another
buff. You're definitely not playing
around that. You say, "Oh, it's maybe a
plus three or maybe, you know, plus five
if it is the signature spell from
Aurelia. Well, you're not necessarily
playing around play a card, draw a card,
get another pump spell, and and lather,
rinse, repeat." You're not necessarily
doing that. So very very uh powerful
game plan from Aurelia. We saw the forge
of the fluff game on Lucian is very very
strong for the Lucian. I mean we saw all
what was it five equipment.
>> Five and almost all of them were
>> played for free. They were equipped for
free.
>> Yeah.
>> If you imagine that game with five fewer
>> runes in play or five fewer runes in
play because that's what Forge of the
Fluff is reducing that game looks a lot
different. very much so. And you have
less advantage when it comes to making
those swings in combat as well. You
don't have the energy left over to use
something like punch first if you're
constantly having to put runes to the
bottom of the deck.
>> Yep. And we see sunken temple on the
side of Lucian, which is great card for
Lucian. The problem is it's also a great
card for Aurelia. And we see it actually
line up here.
>> The double sunken game.
The table is sunken as we bring
ourselves into game two.
>> Here we go. I'm imagining we are likely
going to see Ulia on the play here.
Going first.
Let's start it up.
>> Going to be drawing lots of cards this
game for both sides and hopefully that
will help them piece together these
really strong combos. Will Adam be able
to finally stop Janick in his tracks?
Starting off with a stack deck much like
game one and being able to gain that
knowledge. It looks like we've got a
Stellicorn Herder. I think I couldn't
see what the other cards were.
>> Saw just a sliver, but I think it may
have been Rebuke and Guardian Angel.
>> It looks like they are taking the
Rebuke. As we said before,
>> it is really a hard card for Lucian to
deal with if they are behind or even
just at parody.
This is a breadandbut play for Lucian. I
see three runes. I play my Lucian.
>> Yep. Three runes. Lucian's here ready to
play. And also staring down at nothing
from your opponent means that you have
potential free rain next turn to just
kind of do exactly that and jump around
between the battlefields, gaining
points. You know, nothing in particular
is coming your way.
>> Yeah. But we see a very scary unit that
is Stellicorn Herder. And you know,
Lucian, Lucian's a powerful card,
powerful deck. He fears no man. But that
thing is terrifying. Let me tell you,
Aurelia scary on her own. When Aelia has
more cards in her hand than deck, that
is not a winning proposition for almost
any deck.
>> No, that is that is a spell for
disaster, quite frankly. So, Celicorn
Herder being out this early is
fantastic. Being able to wiggle around
the battlefields, gaining cards as we
fly between them. And that is just
exactly what Aurelia wants to be seeing
is more cards, more tricks, and you
know, planting that fear into your
opponent as well of, oh my gosh, they've
got a giant hand. They surely have
everything they need. Of course, here we
go with that first Lusion play. One
equipment so far, an extra two might.
>> Yeah. And really heads up play here from
Janick. You know, normally you're not
you're not getting into combat with
anything. Why are you equipping here?
Well, that sunken temple is very
important. Lucian a lot of times has
trouble drawing cards. And when you can
turn one rune into a card, at least at
this point in the game, you're
definitely going to want to do that.
>> Yeah, the unit must be mighty to be able
to draw those cards. And on his own
without any equipment, Lucian is not
mighty, but one piece of equipment just
booting that might up did the trick.
>> Absolutely. We saw a few other pieces of
equipment in Janick's hand, but getting
that first point is going to be great.
But it's not necessarily who gets the
first point, it's who gets to that even
break point. It's 2 4 6 8 for the
winning point in Riftbound. That first
point is almost exactly the same as the
second point in this case.
>> Here we go. Stellicorn Herder back on
it. Jumping into our first sunken
temple. And not only that, we're going
to draw a card, but our boots of
swiftness also allow us to have ganking
for later. and again make it a lot
stronger.
>> Yep, we're going to draw a card for
moving. We are mighty, so we can pay an
energy to draw another card if we'd
like.
>> More cards, more good as far as Aelia is
concerned.
>> That hand is already looking marvelous.
And I can see a little bit of gear
removal in there as well. Probably
wanting to save that, hold on to it
until the pivotal moment.
>> Yeah, I do see the factory recall.
You're certainly going to want to play
that in a position where it is going to
impact combat quite a bit. I do see a
couple of charms as well. Find your
center discipline. So, a lot of
resources on the side of Aurelia here to
interact. It's just a matter of what are
we going to do, when are we going to do
it, and how is it going to line up? And
it looks like we are leaving the
Stellorn Herter stranded here. So, looks
like Adam is going to be playing defense
onto this turn, but you not you don't
necessarily need to cash in those
defensive spells because it is scary to
try to attack an Aurelia.
>> It really is and you've got to make sure
that you're kind of got you've got your
wits about you. Now, looking at Janxham,
we do have a lot of pump spells. We do
have plenty going on, but at the moment
it's better just to play it safe and
just have that Lucian. Go into Sunen
Temple, score a point, jump back out,
and just play all of your cards when
they are needed to be played. I think
there's a lot to be said for uh pretty
much any trading card game when it can
be tempting to play all of your cards
and be like, "Oh, these are amazing."
But actually holding those resources
back for when they're most needed can be
so advantageous. And here comes our
action.
>> Oh yes, we're going to steal a boots of
swiftness.
>> Oh, stealing the booties off right off
the Stellorn.
>> Yeah, you wanted Stellorn to move from
battlefield to battlefield. No, thank
you.
>> No,
not so swift looking. Now
>> we do see the not so fast which can
actually counter the ability that
targets a gear here. So Axan, you don't
counter the Axan. There's still there's
still a four bite body.
>> He's still there.
>> But uh at least the boots get to stay on
the Stellicorn here, which is very
important in order for Adab to continue.
>> Not only that, but an adorable image of
little booties on this Stellicorn
Herder.
>> True. Yes. Just just floating around
from battlefield to battlefield, minding
their own business, being a menace to
society. Classic.
>> Exactly that. Drawing cards as it
should. And there's our first glide over
to the uh hm wait a minute sunken
temple.
>> Yes,
>> I feel like I've been here before.
>> This feels so familiar. And there we go
for drawing two cards. We did go ahead
and use that extra energy to
grab an extra. Looking very flush in
cards and options here now. But when is
it going to be time to go aggressive?
And that's what I really like about this
build. Here we go. Is that you can get
aggressive. can force your opponent into
unfavorable positions.
>> Yeah. And really good call out from Adam
here. They see, oh, there's one energy
up. Oh, I'm afraid of punch first. Well,
if you take a look underneath Jedx,
there's only one body run. So, punch
first is a no no right now.
>> No gode indeed. We're not able to punch
first and that is why it was an
opportune moment to be able to just drag
Archan forward towards our Stellorn.
Going for an on guard.
>> Yep. And this is is scary as well
because is there a
is there another
>> I think there's another charm.
>> I was going to say there's another
charm. And the beauty you saw that there
wasn't the punch burst before. Now you
know the coast is clear. Let's take out
that Lucian.
>> Oh, that is huge. Such a pivotal turning
point for this game. Of course, the
Doran's blade stays in play, but now
Janick has no units in play. Can't play
that chosen champion. Of course, Adam
still has the opportunity later in the
game to play our Aurelia, bringing that
Stellicorn Herder back to base. It's
safe and sound as it been. It's It's put
in so much work this turn. Deserves a
rest.
>> Yeah, there there's a reason I fear that
card and we are seeing it in action
right now. Adab is a full grip of cards
in hand. They are
um they are currently ahead. They've got
board presence. We did not see much left
in the hand of Lucian here. In terms of
units, I think there may be a first
mate. Uh, which in this case is just
going to be a three might unit, which is
it's okay. I mean, it's great in in some
cases, but not really here. We also do
see the Brin here, but if you're just
playing the Brin here for the body, that
is not where you want to be.
>> No, not at all. That's not using the
card as optimally as we want. We want to
be getting full value
and that's just not bringing it home.
>> And we're seeing a bone shiver played
here. There's the first mate as the
three might body just needs something to
carry these equipment. But that passes
the turn over back to Aurelia back to
Celicorn. We're going to be seeing a ton
of cards drawn here. We're going ahead
on point tempo. Once we get to that
fourth point here, first player to four
goes ahead on the point tempo. And like
we mentioned at the start of this match,
when you're ahead, the both of these
decks are really good at getting ahead
and staying ahead. But once you fall
behind, that is really tough to get
back.
>> So difficult. And that's exactly what
it's all about. You just want to
>> stay at pace almost when you see a [__]
in the armor from your opponent,
>> go aggressive, stay ahead, and then they
just don't have the opportunity to pull
back. And that's exactly what we're
trying to do here. Uh but by kind of
seeing the [__] in the armor, we saw
that there wasn't the potential for a
punch burst from Janick. Knowing that
that wasn't a possibility, Adam was able
to go aggressive with this really
intuitive version of Aurelia with the
charms
>> just bringing all of the charm to the
table with three total in the deck. And
now it's time to get rid of that bone
ship and go back to the hand. You're
going to have to use all of those runes
to play it again. Factory Recall coming
into its own here. Fantastic card. I
think it's underutilized in this meta.
I'm going to say it.
>> I mean, as the Lucian player, I say,
"No, no, no. People are playing it too
much. Play it less." In fact,
specifically against me. But no, you are
100% right. It is a very effective card.
And here we're seeing it just as a tempo
play. We're saying, "I'm going to spend
one energy. I'm going to make you spend
three more energy on top of the three
that you already spent." And that's just
to get you back where you already were.
>> And that's exactly what we want to be
doing. We're playing Aurelia. We're
playing Chaos. That's part of what Chaos
does is making it really awkward for
your opponent to do what they want to
do. Make that energy cost really
uncomfortable and push them into the
back seat where they don't belong.
>> Yep. And we're seeing a great usage of
Ride the Wind here. Ride the Wind
effectively reads try draw until you're
you're you're fine. If you don't want
any more cards, it's fine. Just take as
many as you want with Ride the Wind on
Stellicorn Herder and Sun in Double
Sunken Temple. Double sucker temple.
Just icing on the cake.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm We have the We have the
might trackers on uh on the bottom of
the screen here, which is really great
innovation for this event. But can we
get a can we get a hand tracker just
over on top of their head here? I think
we're going to run out of space very
quickly if we keep watching Aurelia that
are playing Stalicorn Herders.
>> They're just going to have these
Constantina hands that keep getting
bigger and smaller and bigger and
smaller. They're going to be playing a
tune on that ever so soon. Uh,
>> okay. We're yet having to manually
equip.
>> Oh, no. Oh, no. We're not.
>> Relentless Pursuit.
>> Ooh,
>> Relentless Pursuit is a way to
effectively give accelerate here. We're
going to equip the bone shiver for no
additional cost here. That is part of
the Relentless Pursuit. That's going to
allow the first mate to conquer. It will
also allow them when they conquer to
move back to a battlefield this turn.
So, really great in this case. The first
mate can move to the sunken temple
conquer. That's going to proc the bone
shiver. It will then because of
relentless pursuits ability move back
automatically without exhausting be able
to then exhaust to move in and conquer
the other one. But uh
that that's too much text. Too long
didn't read.
>> One of the best feelings as a TCG player
is when your opponent has to pick up
your card and read it cuz you know they
haven't seen it before. They haven't
played against it and it was too
fearful. We were like, "No, no, I'm
going to have to defy that."
>> Yep. And here we go. We're seeing
exactly what we talked about here, the
double conquer. We're seeing the bone
shiver proc here. That is going to help
there. And yeah, we saw Janick maybe not
make the mistake, but was punished last
game from not having their unit in base
be enough. They've already seen two
charms. We're not getting hit by a third
one here.
>> Surely not. But it could happen.
>> It could. And it does not matter how big
that first maid is. It's not big enough
is the answer.
>> Yeah, going to draw a load of cards all
over again with the extra choices from
those sunken temple as well helping them
out. Choosing your battlefield for each
game. One, two, and potentially three is
such an important skill. And add really
had the advantage here going in knowing
they had their own sunken temple. And
then Janick just kind of accidentally
fed into that thinking, well, I need
more cards. But actually, Adam's now in
a much more prevalent position. You've
accidentally given your opponent a
slightly larger advantage.
>> Yeah, this is very much a the rich get
richer type of game. If whichever player
gets off to a strong start is likely
going to continue onto an even stronger
one. But we see here
>> which means Adam is now going to have to
play their pump spells now and try to
guess how big is this first mate going
to be because if they don't play spells
now that's it for the rest of the turn.
No more spells can be played. That's
what Brin here says. So Adam said not
going to play anything. We're just going
to attack in and is the corner being
turned here?
>> It could be preventing your opponent
from playing cards from their hand.
You can't ask for much better for a
trading card game. Let's be real. Taking
down the Stellorn Herder. And now all we
can really do is kind of sit and watch.
We can't play any cards. So
unfortunately that first mate does just
pull ahead. And this can be the pivotal
turning point. This can be the comeback.
Just putting your opponent enough on the
back foot. And we're not too far away
points-wise to keep going now. keep pace
and just take the win that way.
>> Yeah, the question here for Adam is are
they going to be able to present the
conquer on two battlefields cuz they're
at six here. They are potentially
threatening to win, but I don't know if
they have enough energy to play the
Aurelia ready her and then also be able
to take both battlefields. I'm not sure.
They certainly have the cards in hand. I
just don't know if they have the energy.
>> I think that's exactly it. you kind of
have the ability to make Aurelia big
enough. But do we have enough resources
to make that happen realistically?
My gut says no, but I'm not out here
playing. We've got Adam to thank for
that. So hopefully he'll be able to
piece a miraculous turn together.
Otherwise, Janick really is in the
driver's seat.
>> Yeah, good news, bad news for Adab here.
The good news is that Janick is at five,
which is notably not six, which means
>> theoretically in a normal game of
Riftbound with non-Lucian decks, they're
not threatening to win next turn.
>> But
>> but it is Lucian. So if we see the combo
come out, then all of a sudden it could
be over and that could actually be the
end of the game
>> in Lucian. Looking like we're going to
try and put the advantage back in our
court by channeling an extra rune and
then also drawing a card with find your
center. But I think it might be a turn
too late to be channeling that extra
rune cuz really we need to be putting
the pressure on Janick now in case of
that rather scary combo that we saw last
game.
>> Yeah, I believe that the three equipment
are Bone Shiver and two Doran's Blades.
I'm not 100% sure, but uh it is uh it is
not necessarily going for two points on
the hold here, but if they are able to
assemble that combo, they can get a
surprise win out of nowhere.
>> And that's exactly it. That's why
Lucian's so strong. I really believe
that this deck has been almost slept on
for too long. I can see why you've been
a believer from the beginning. I see now
the mistake of my ways. But first, Mate
is out of there. Rebuke comes down and
says, "No, I need to take this game. I'm
taking this back by force. Put that back
where it came from."
>> Yeah, get the first mate out now. We're
going to prevent the hold point. We're
going to slow the game down for Janick
as well. But the problem is what is Adam
actually going to be able to put put
down in terms of pressure as well?
because they they also need to be
threatening to win the game next turn
likely because yeah, they Lucian might
not win the game right now, but they're
certainly going to be winning the game
if they get another turn.
>> Oh yeah, you can't let them have that
realistically. This is now or never.
You've got to put as much pressure as
humanly possible on. We've got our
little Porro standing strong, but is it
going to be enough? We're running really
low on active runes by the looks of
things.
It might just not be enough. Brinh
already there going to be readying at
the Oh no, here we go. Yeah, we're
passing over.
>> Yes, the the good news for Adam is that
we don't see either piece of the combo
in play right now. And at this point, it
would need to be the combo plus a third
Relentless Pursuit, which I don't even
know if there's enough energy to do so.
I think we're not likely winning on this
turn. So then it's going to be the
question of can Adib present the win the
turn after. And it's going to be harder
with one fewer card in hand.
>> Do we have anything to Oh, we don't.
This time we get the full effect of
sabotage being able to choose a nonunit
card and recycle it. That means to pop
it to the bottom of Adam's deck. We're
not going to be seeing that anytime
soon.
>> No. But uh this is also a matter of uh
which one of these five, no, sorry, six
pump spells do you want to take? Or do
you want to take Ride the Wind? Or are
you taking a gear that I already have in
play? Yeah, I I like this choice.
Getting rid of the Defiant Dance to make
sure that we're keeping on par. We know
that we're going to be putting some big
units into play and that is a really big
turning point for Aurelia having that
signature spell.
>> Yeah, it is the biggest might swing that
you can really present. And there's half
of the combo. That is scary. All of a
sudden,
>> we are
>> It's going on.
>> Yeah, we're seeing the Bone Shiver
equipped first here. Well, I think we
might be we might be suiting up here.
>> Oo, suiting and booting ready to go.
We've got the Trinity Force.
Oh, it's getting scary. Still plenty to
go, but we don't have the other part of
our winning combo yet, but we might be
able now that we're mighty, we might be
able to go ahead and draw some more
cards with the Sunken Temple.
>> Yep. We don't have the Skyfall, so we're
not going to score two points on
Conquer, but we would
>> score two points on hold. That's just
what Trinity Force does as a base cost.
>> Trinity Force is one of the most
fantastic effects on a gear in my
opinion. When I first read that card,
being able to duplicate other effects, I
was like, "Oh, the potential."
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, the future potential of that card is
infinite.
>> Yeah. Skyfall is just one of those cards
that uh every time a a new hold or
conquer effect comes out, you got to you
got to look what happens if I make that
hold effect or vice versa. Like how does
the game change? I mean, even having
even having it on a Kai'Sa and having
the Kais drawing an extra card is just
good enough a lot of time.
>> Yeah, that's crazy. Isn't that uh isn't
that what Draven was good for? You know,
>> drawing we we saw through Draven draw
more cards is good. Yeah, cards in hand
go up, win rate go up. It's very simple.
But rift bound riftbound easy game
confirmed, but obviously not as we see
here. Looks like the judges are making a
slight correction to the game state. But
I think all is well in regards to where
we are. And that is going to be the Brin
here coming in going for the sunken
temple.
>> We're going to choose to draw
>> Oh, we're channeling a rune
>> from the bone shiver.
>> Yeah, we're going to choose to draw a
card. or are we just going to again take
it slow? This isn't a race that needs to
be won right now.
>> Yep, we are seeing a one and one and
that is a challenge saying you know
what,
>> let's get that porro out of here. Yeah,
you're going to draw a card, but that is
one fewer unit in play. That's going to
be more resources you're going to need
to spend to try to contest me next turn.
At this point, Janick being able to get
a hold point here even again just puts
him in a winning position for next turn.
Going up to seven would be easy peasy.
>> Here's the thing. If Janick gets a hold
point this turn, that's going to be game
because Trinity Force will give you the
second hold point.
>> That is so true. Yeah. Wait.
>> So, if if Janick holds here, it is over.
And we are seeing the we are seeing the
Brin here get suited up all the way to
11 right now. And let's pass it. There
wasn't a porro in sight for Adib. We
don't have any units in play. Not only
would we need to ready something, we'd
also need to send it into quite the
scary combat unless we can push the Brin
here back out of the base somehow. This
could be a disaster.
>> Yeah, I mean, in the in the previous
meta, you may have had some more outs
with a card like Fight or Flight. Well,
that has flighted away. not legal in the
format right now, which means Janick is
going to have to go for glory here.
Going to start off by playing the
Aurelia, equipping, readying it with the
Aurelia Blade Dancer, and then going
from there. How much might can we get
from this Aurelia?
>> We got to go all in. We got to go all
in. We got to get as much as we can onto
this Aurelia. We don't have that many
runes right now that are available to
use for that energy. We've got some on
guard that's going to be able to pump us
up a little bit more. So, we'll be able
to kind of
>> slowly creep towards that total, but
that brin here is massive.
>> Yes, the Brin here is 11. The Aurelia
currently going up here up to nine.
>> Be able to get to 11, I think,
relatively easily. But the question is,
>> can we get above a punch first? I
believe we've seen a punch first in
Ganex hand from the beginning. Is there
enough to push over?
>> Cuz we can on guard. And that's another
one spent,
>> but then we do need it.
>> We have the defy in hand, I think.
>> Yeah, that's the beauty of punch first
is it costs two power. So, you can't
actually defy it. It's one of those it's
one of those why oh why you you know you
you don't want to pay the two power but
sometimes you can. And we see here again
can't be defied. It costs two power.
Janick was thinking the same thing. It's
too much. And it's such a simple kind of
uh not mistake to make as such, but it's
it's a simple kind of uh notion where
you think, "Oh, I've got the defy. It's
fine." And then you go, "Oh, wait, no.
Punch first is too big." But
>> yes, dis uh discipline able to come
over. Still had all these pump spells
for Adib there. And guess what, Amy? We
are going to a game number three. Both
of these decks work in such similar
ways, but Adam was able to just make
that Aurelia big enough to take down
Brin here. A fantastic play regardless.
And both players have been, you know,
playing exceptionally well considering
these decks similar in nature, very
different archetypes, but actually when
you boil it down, they both want to
achieve the same thing.
>> It is crazy how different, but also
similar.
Yeah, it really is. As we see here
again, take a look at taking a look at
the sidebar. We saw the Oxons come in. I
don't imagine that much else is coming
in. You could make an argument for
piercing light, but a lot of times
you're not going to really be able to
take anything out that is relevant with
Piercing Light. There's so many combat
tricks for Aurelia at reaction speed
that you can react with and that's
costing you a lot of power to play that
piercing light repeated. And again on
the side of Adam, we saw the not so fast
come in and be relevant. We saw the defy
there. Wasn't relevant in that case, but
we've seen it in other games as well.
Factory recall also again slowing down
the tempo of what the Lucian is doing.
And of course, Rebuke is a very, very
strong card.
>> And will it make a difference now that
Janick knows what tricks are up sleeve?
We saw pretty much all of them in that
game. So now we know what the potential
is. Will it change the way that Janick
plays? Yeah, it is possible. I mean,
having the having the confirmation that
certain cards exist just allows you to
keep them in mind and maybe mix up your
play ever so slightly so that you can
make it a little bit more awkward for
your opponent. And and really these
little things, especially in these game
threes, it's a long day. You need to be
playing tight from the very beginning.
And we'll see which of these players can
take it away. Just goes to show that if
you do get that early lead with a deck
like this, that can really spell out the
rest of the game. You kind of really, we
saw the struggle and the tussle back and
forth there, but that Stellicorn Herder
at the beginning just being able to draw
cards again and again really did bolster
Aurelia's position.
>> Yep. Yeah. I mean, that was the that was
the lucky part there. Well, not lucky,
but it was the very strong part about
Stellicorn Herder. Just fill up that
hand. And yes, there was a pivotal turn
for Lucian. They were able to take out
that Stellicorn Herder with the Brin
here, saying, "Nope, can't play spells
this turn. Got it taken out, but I'm
still good. I'm still okay. I've got
enough resources here. Oh, I'll be all
right. You'll
>> be all right." And that's that's what
it's all about. Don't panic. It's okay.
You'll have enough. And both decks being
able to ready units as well also gives
them that really fearsome notion of,
>> oh gosh, they can just come at me at any
time. They do have that flexibility. And
we're seeing the battlefields for our
game three. Zorn Warren and Rockfall
Path.
>> Yeah, ZH Warren is a great one for
honestly both players, but Lucian
especially if you're looking for those
specific cards, if you're looking for a
specific piece of the combo. It is
great. Rockfall Path is going to slow
the game down for Aurelia and is going
to allow them to have that breathing
room to hope that Lucian is not going to
get too far ahead. And if Aurelia is
able to get their resources out, play
their Aurelia or Stellicorn, protect the
princess,
it is a really tough game for Lucian to
come back from.
>> And that's exactly it. Whichever one of
these competitors manages to get into
that really strong position and hold
that unit as much as they can. That's
going to be the turning point. Now,
Zanic does Janick does have the slight
advantage of being able to kind of
reestablish units a little bit faster
typically than Aurelia can, but we've
got a fantastic Stella. Oh, no. It's a
porro. It's a borrow. I got it wrong.
It's a lonely porro, but we saw that
game one and lonely porros can be quite
fantastic. They've got a great death
nail effect and they're, you know,
they're not too light on the power
either.
>> Yeah, they're perfectly perfectly fine
units and at the very least they're
going to be replacing the
>> There's the Stellacicorn her. I was just
uh anticipating.
>> Yep, there she is. The Stellicorn
Herder, the terror of any opponent.
Stellicorn Herder going to be able to
draw a ton of cards. But Lucian, you
know, made it a turn, did not get
charmed, did not get taken out, and is
going to be able to start contesting the
other side here.
>> Ooh, going to go for a gust. Just push
Lucian back. Keep this porro. try and
get a whole point, I imagine. Oh,
>> there we go. We've got our good friend
Ruin Runner, which says, "Hey, you know,
all those interactive spells, the gusts,
the rebukes, all that." Yeah. Uh, I
can't can't touch this.
>> Nah, not at all. Not having that. You
know what? You've used one gust. I don't
fancy that happening again. Let's bring
our Ruin Runner into play and just stop
that happening. Yeah, even a card like
Defiant Dance can't even be it can't
even give the minus to the Ruiner
Runner. So, you're able to force your
opponent to actually put the minus on
one of their own units uh and and not
even be able to do much against that
Ruin Runner. Very, very strong card to
equip up and say, "Yeah, I'm not really
afraid of anything." You got
>> going into the Zorn Warren using its
effect to draw more cards. And that's
exactly what Aurelia wants. We want to
make this beautiful big hand and try to
just further our stance. Moving over
with gust of uh wind ride the wind.
Goodness, I was thinking gust and all
sorts to bring ourselves into rockfall
path where our opponent will really
struggle to contest it.
>> Yeah. And just able to move the Stellorn
Herder around, draw more cards. Again,
ride the wind with Stellorn Herder
basically says, "Ah, draw as many cards
as you need and go ahead. Take them. can
he can have him. But we see a moment
potentially of opening here. The Aurelia
comes down. No energy on the side of
Adam here. If we have cards like
challenge, they can come through here
unchallenged from the Aurelia, but we
can also play our equipment. We can
conquer. We can attack here and say,
"Yeah, you've got all these cards in
hand. You've got no energy, so I'm not
afraid."
>> Straight on in. No need to worry. Five
power to just a sweet porro. Do get the
death nail effect which is quite
advantageous.
>> Yeah, there we have our Trinity Force
coming through. And I'm wondering if
we're going to see potentially the
Relentless Pursuit to move
>> the Ruin Runner over, get another point,
>> be able to equip the Trinity Force for
free, and then get the Ruin Runner out
of dodge here. Can't be charmed from the
backline unlike other units, and just
keeping up on the point tempo as much as
they can.
And then potentially looking to assemble
that combo and get some additional
points out of nowhere. jumping over to
Zorn Warren and then back to base just
to get that extra card draw in. Can't
knock it. That's exactly what we want to
be doing. And loading up
this Ruin Runner with those gear is
going to make it so much harder for Adib
to to deal with it where it can't be
targeted by these effects. So, Adib is
going to have a lot of cards that are
practically useless against it.
>> Yeah. And I can see another Relentless
Pursuit. I can see a first mate. I mean,
both of these cards really good at
protecting that Ruin Runner. I I not
sure if we have the Skyfall. I maybe saw
it for a second and that would allow
this Ruin Runner to all of a sudden
start to get two points per conquer
which is going to get them back on track
to be ahead in this game. Stellicorn
Herder doing its thing. Jumping straight
into Zorn Warren there scoring us a
point. Now it's a hard consideration of
what's next. How are we going to
overcome
our opponent here? Going for the charm
just to Oh, that was a discard on the
charm for the draw.
>> Yep. Can't can't charm the runer anyway.
So, and of course
>> I think we drew into another charm.
>> Classic. Yeah, this part of part I don't
need this anymore. Draw one. Yeah. Okay,
fair enough.
>> But Aurelia moves on in. Rockfall path
is once again taken by Adib trying to
make it difficult for Janick to come
back in the points lead not necessarily
on board state seeing a threat thinking
oh gosh but he can only go into one
battlefield at a time
>> right and this is a really interesting
hand on the side of Adam I see some
rebukes I see
I see a lot of cards that would
potentially be good against a lot of
units that aren't a ruin runner on
>> that's exactly it ruin runner so we
We see a lot of other stuff. And now
Adam has to decide what are they going
to leave stranded on the battlefield.
What are they going to try to defend on
opponent's turn? Are they going to try
to move anything back? What are what are
we doing here?
>> Honestly, Ruin Runner is one of those
really tricky cars for Aurelia to cope
with and I've seen a lot of people
complaining about it and that's how I
know it's good.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The more the the more
winging you hear, the uh the better the
card usually is.
Oh, looks like we're going for a big.
Here we go. Over to Janick's turn. Adiv
just has all that energy ready to go.
Sabotage time. But I believe we can say
a no to that. Or can we not? No, we
can't.
>> Now the information is there. Not only
are we getting rid of a card, the
information is there. And we see the
factory recall. You know what? Rununner
can't be targeted, but the equipment
equipped to run definitely can.
Absolutely. And that's exactly what
Janick is saying. Yeah. All these other
cards, uh, they are almost blank against
me. I don't care. We're going to take
Oh, okay. No, we're going to take that's
fine, too. Yeah, it's a it's effectively
another card. And it's also a plus three
to Aurelia at the very least. As long as
we I mean, we now know that the factory
recall is there.
>> Oh, there's another sabotage. It's okay.
>> We know the factory recall was there. It
was there, but not for long.
>> No.
>> No. Brilliant. Double sabotage. Can't
make it up. Couldn't write it. It's
perfect. Really, you know your opponent
has two things you'd rather them not to
have in their hand. And not only that,
you get the additional information of
knowing what's potentially coming, what
units are available, and what might be a
threat to other units Janick could play
down.
>> Yep. And now the rune runner is a five
plus two is going to be seven. Plus
another two is going to be nine. Plus
another two from the assault is going to
put Ruin Runner at 11 on the attack.
>> Here comes that Skyfall.
>> The Skyfall is also going to threaten
now to get two points per conquer. We're
going to start with a challenge here
>> on the side of Janick to get rid of that
Stellicorn Herder before any other
shenanigans can happen.
>> Do we have a response if we're ad
contemplating?
Okay.
>> See defiant dance happen.
So, we're we're significantly bigger.
You mentioned a minute ago. It's one of
the largest pump spells we can get in
one go. And of course, is that signature
spell. They have phenomenal power for a
very good reason.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, I believe we're saying
the Stellorn Herder is dead anyway.
>> Yeah.
>> We're going to use this opportunity to
play Defined Dance and actually pump up
the Aurelia because if the Cellorn
Herter is gone, you need the other
target for the minus two. You can't say
I'm not going to give anything minus
two. you have to choose something. So,
I'm going to choose the Stellicorn
Herder because there's no other options
at if that Stellorn Herder is gone. So,
let's cash that in now. Really heads up
play on the side of Adib, but we know
there's no Defy. We're going in and
relentlessly pursuing that Aurelia. Here
it is. 11 versus 8. Janick knows there's
no more pump spells.
>> There's nothing coming. We can we can
you can ride the wind over. That's fine.
But guess what? Relentless Pursuit says,
"No, no, no, no. I I'm coming after
you."
>> No, I'm I'm I'm coming in. You you can't
stop me. Now, the only thing we could do
is to continue to ride the wind, but
that's all we can really do.
>> Just keep running away. And that might
just give Janick the momentum we need
now to finish up and start to close out
this game. Because if we're looking at
points, Janick is on the back seat, but
Adib is going to need the momento to
keep on going.
>> I think we're just discussing
>> Yeah, this
>> where the
effect can happen, but it absolutely can
in this instance.
>> Yeah, it's one of those weird scenarios
where there's pending combats and making
sure that all the triggers happen and
which which one of these resolves first.
They did resolve it correctly here. The
Lucian initial attack is happening
first. We're then going to use the R rel
R relentless Pursuit ability to move the
Ruin Runner back. And guess what?
Relentless Pursuit does not exhaust in
any of those moves. So now Janx is going
to be able to reattack if they want
into that Aurelia.
>> Discarding Charm again. Charming is
certainly not on the menu
>> right now. So that can go. We'll draw
more cards. And again, drawing more
cards at this point as well kind of
gives you an advantage in that Janick
doesn't know your entire hand now.
>> It is massive. What was that top deck?
It could be anything. I mean, this this
top deck could very easily change this
entire combat. But as we see, it
doesn't. And Lucian is able to conquer
here for another two points. That puts
them to six. And if they hold, they win
the game.
>> That's dramatic jump from two to six
jumping ahead. And we're going to see it
all unfold here. Can Adib come back from
this. It's not impossible, but it's
going to be a tough ride ahead. We're
going with another Stellicorn Herder,
>> but I'm not sure we've got a lot more
that we can play this turn without kind
of running ourselves really thin on
resources to be able to answer what
Janick might have next turn.
>> Guardian Angel's a good start, and we
can equip it. We can equip it. But the
question is, are we able to? I mean, if
we can score both here, we just win the
game. But there's only one energy left.
>> I don't know if we have enough resources
to do so, but we might be able to cuz
what was in hand?
>> That's two rebukes. Those are both
blank.
>> Okay, we can draw.
>> We're drawing from Zon Warren here
>> and it wasn't enough. We've passed the
turnover. We got that extra score point.
Now it's up to Janick to try and take
the win.
>> Through a not so fast. I don't think
that's going to end up being enough.
We're gonna see. Are they
>> Are they going to try something else
here?
>> I'm not sure that we have much more
>> anything they can do.
>> They're passing the turn. Make your
opponent do it. See, is there something?
Is there some misstep that Janick can
make? They just need to conquer the
battlefield because of the combo that
will put them from seven up to eight
with that bonus point. It will be
enough.
Seeing just confirming everything with
the judge here going for it.
>> Going into rockfall path which is just
open for the taking.
>> Yep. And it looks like there it is.
>> There it is. Janick Ruin runs right into
the winners position for this round one
here at our regional qualifier. Leo,
>> there it is. I Hey, I've been talking
about it for a long time. Lucian good
deck confirmed taking game number one or
round number one here and that is a huge
one to take. That sets the momentum for
the day especially when you have to play
such a long day. Eight rounds today of
Swiss getting that first win under your
belt and really earning it in the way
that Janick did there is got to be a
huge confidence boost going into the
day.
>> Huge. We had so so many uh combat tricks
and attempts from Aurelia to
specifically target Lucian and so many
ways of getting around Lucian's typical
combat tricks and typical ways of
scoring those extra points and they just
weren't enough. No, and that that's the
beauty is you can bring all of these
tools to fight Lucian. I mean, we saw
the Gust hit the Lucian earlier. That's
a that's a huge tempo play. We saw the
factory recalls come into play have
these really great tempo plays and Runer
says, "I don't care what you have. Uh I
am here and I'm going to do what I'm
doing and I'll let you do what you're
doing, but I'm going to score two points
a turn when I have that combo in play."
>> And unfortunately, there just wasn't a
unit big enough on the other side to
contest that Ruin Runner at all. And
even then, we're keeping it in base. In
base, it's completely safe. Nothing can
drag that forward kicking and screaming
to a base to perish. It sticks around
and that's the worst part. It's just
like a lingering smell that won't go
away.
>> Yeah, I just got this horrible image of
a giant camel with two pieces of
legendary equipment kicking and
screaming, being dragged, and that's
terrifying. So, they say, "No, that that
can't happen in this game. That's too
much of a nightmare. This is a
familyfriendly game. We're not having
this horrible abomination." But it was
very scary of course if you're in that
case because yes you're conquering
getting two points a turn. This is not
fair. The only or two points per conquer
up to four points a turn. That's not
fair. That's not riftbound. Well Lucian
says I don't care. I'm going to get
these points. I'm going to jump ahead.
If I'm behind I'm going to jump ahead.
If I'm ahead, I'm going to go really far
ahead and win the game in spots that
most decks aren't even able to.
>> Lucian says rules. I don't need them. I
don't need them. I'm going to I'm going
to gear up and go ahead in and take my
points and you're not going to do
anything about it.
>> But I I will say to the credit of
Aurelia, we saw a lot of trickiness
there. We saw like you mentioned that
hand that hand reveal being so powerful
that they're saying, you know, I'm going
to spend a whole card. I know you're
going to take a card. I'm going to say
nope. I'm going to I'm going to defy
that. I'm going to hard bargain that.
Because if you see my tricks, all of a
sudden they get a lot worse when you go,
I'm actually just holding a bunch of
garbage. When it's a mystery, all of
these cards get way way better by by
proxy.
>> Yeah. And that's that's the power in
leaving the energy available as well to
play with is that even if you don't have
a card that you can play with it, just
especially when we're playing chaos,
>> you're just signaling to your opponent
the what if? And that's the scary part
is leaving enough for the what if to put
your opponent off their game.
>> Yeah. And it gets to that point of I'm
going to represent that I have something
if my does my opponent respect my
representation. Like I could be leaving
up punch first. Are you going to now
play around punch first and then I don't
actually have it and if they you know if
they call the bluff all of a sudden you
can see things go wrong. But if they
don't that's the beauty of I mean of
card games of Riftbound specifically.
Yeah.
>> Like you said you don't need to
necessarily have every single combat
trick in your hand. No. But you can play
like you do. And if your opponent reads
that, all of a sudden, you can take
advantage of them being a good player.
You can take advantage of a good player
by saying, "Oh, nope. I've got nothing."
Yeah, I'm telling you, I've got nothing.
With all my energy up, I'll pass the
turn. You know, oh, they definitely have
something. We see their hand, they've
got nothing. It doesn't matter. That's
the beauty. This is these are the types
of things that I love in card games,
specifically in Riftbound and and even
more specifically in Lucian. We
mentioned as well with this particular
matchup that holding resources, not
playing them too early, not giving away
not necessarily what's in your deck, but
also not giving away the strategy you
could employ is not only good, but also
having that ginormous hand also changes
your opponent's perception of how your
turn could go and how you could interact
with their turn. Because the chances of
you having cards that they know exist,
that they know are a threat, but they
don't necessarily know if they're your
in your hand. Well, if you've got 10
cards in hand,
>> that's
>> they probably have it.
>> They probably have it. And so then it
becomes scarier to call that bluff.
>> You can still do it. We saw in game two.
But
>> yeah,
>> it becomes that wall that then you have
to get over.
>> Yeah. It it becomes a a a knowledge
check of it's not that I don't think
that you have it. It's that if you have
it, I lose anyway. So, I'm going to
pretend that you don't have it. And
sometimes that works and sometimes it
doesn't. And we see really great players
be able to make those adjustments and uh
call the bluffs when necessary and say,
"Hey, move move in when you need to uh
and play to win instead of playing to
not lose." And we saw that really
executed well by by both players
honestly across the
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. No, honestly, both
players played spectacularly. Really
pleased with our round one there cuz we
got to see two decks do their thing in
very unique ways and we got to see the
combo. We got to see the Lucian combo
unfold, which obviously everyone knows
what Lucian's trying to achieve. But
then,
>> are they able to string it together? Can
I stop them? It's like a mini game, like
you were saying yesterday to us in a lot
of our interviews. You've got to throw
your opponent through those loops.
>> Yeah, you got to throw your opponent
through those loops. And we are going to
throw over to an interview with our
winner. Let's hear it from the giant
unargetable camel's mouth himself. Let's
throw it on over and listen to what they
had to say.
>> Thank you, Blevens, for the throw. I'm
here with the winner of round one,
Yanik. You won on the Lucian. Congrats.
Now, tell me, why do you play Lucian?
>> Well, I play Lucian because he was just
my favorite champ in League of Legends.
Was my first main when I started started
the game. I played him like years, one
or two years.
>> And when I saw that he will be released
in Spirit Forge, I was like, "Hell yeah,
I got something to play." Doesn't matter
what kind of tier he is in, man. This is
going to be my main. I knew it on the
spot. And I'm happy that the deck really
fits my player. It's a lot of fun.
>> And uh like this.
>> It's kind of dumb play sometimes, but I
like the combo the the Skyfall Trinity
stuff with scoring two points or four
points in one turn.
>> Feels kind of good to have that comeback
potential against some decks that start
out really fast. Uh where you have like
chances to come back. It's really fun. I
just love the champion, man. It's uh
>> That's awesome to hear that you actually
played like League of Legends so much
and you have so much association with a
legend that it transfers to Riftbound.
That's really really cool story. But I
wanted to ask you since Lucian now is
actually way stronger in the metag game
than it was before the bands. What do
you feel like is your best matchup and
worst matchup coming into this
tournament?
>> That's a pretty good question actually.
Um I'm not sure what my best matchup is.
I feel like everything is winnable
actually.
>> I think most matchups are wable if you
hit the right stuff. Uh can sabotage
like out the your counter stuff. It
really depends on the sideboards to be
honest because a lot of people are
sideboarding against Aurelia and stuff
>> and that hits me as well a lot to be
honest.
>> Correct.
>> Ireelia is uh probably one of my worst
matchups. Um,
it really depends if they hit like the
adaptive turn thing that destroys my
gear. If they have this uh that on
curve,
>> I don't do much. Right.
>> So, what was in your head when you were
playing against here in the first round?
What what what is in your head? How was
your mindset when coming into this
match?
>> I was like, great, I'm on stream and I
can play against my worst matchup.
Was like, man, this is going to be fun.
But, uh, no, that's that's not really my
mindset. I was like, hey, it's going to
be fun, man. just uh just playing
playing my game. Um and it worked. It
was a close game. Was really fun. The
opponent was a nice guy.
>> That's awesome to hear.
>> So, it was awesome. Yeah.
>> Yeah. All right. Awesome. Thank you very
much um for for the interview and
congrats again to your round one win.
Big ups. This is your first regional
from what you told me. So, very happy to
have you here. And we're going to throw
to Barcode for another interview live in
the arena.
All right, guys. Yeah, I'm here with a
familiar face of the TCG competition,
Samir Bashar, who is with me. Thanks a
lot for being here. How are you doing?
>> Fine. Fine. Honestly, because it's my
country this event.
>> Absolutely. Yeah, we are on the French
territory on home soil. So, tell me, are
you playing the main event or the side
event? I go to the side event this time
because I didn't inscription directly.
>> Oh, so yeah. So you're a bit late for
the for the registration. Okay, it makes
sense. But still, I saw you walking down
the alley and you were so always
smiling, you know. What do you think
about the atmosphere of the venue?
>> Honestly, this event of the atmosphere
of this event, it's really nice. Full
nice guys. It's really really better
atmosphere. I mean, and when we see you
smiling all the time, I can get it. I
totally relate to that. So, speaking
about the side events that you decided
to play, which one will you be excited
the most about?
>> Uh, can you repeat?
>> So, which side events are you going to
play?
>> Ah, okay. I go full the time go to the
um the egg player egg player best three
and elimination jacks.
>> Okay. So you are here for competition.
By the way, speaking about the other
side events, are you excited about the
freefor-all for example or the 2v2?
Honestly, me didn't test for B on this
because two V two it's little strange
because if you are not for isn't the
same rule simple for 2v2 it's it's other
game and I really liking the rift bond
game and didn't want to playing other R
bond actually. So you you prefer the 1 v
one to the 2v2. But be aware of
something. If one day you want to play
some 2v2, I will be right there by your
side playing the game alongside you.
Speaking about the game itself, which
legend did you choose to play?
>> I choose to play Draven.
>> Draven.
>> So Draven, yeah, it was a bit impacted
by the ban list, but still you decided
to play the deck. Do you think it is
still one of the best decks?
>> Me thinking isn't the best deck
actually. me thinking the ban list
didn't change more of this deck because
I lose I lose the miracle version on the
mid version just change the matchup
rotation the bad matchup is now good
matchup because the card main deck on
the card fighting is on main and now D
didn't the best deck of the
>> of the pool
>> just uh I can use the skill ability draw
Yeah. I mean, yeah, this legend is
absolutely insane. Being able to throw
one every single time that you win a
combat, that's huge.
>> Yes. And before the ban, it's impossible
for use effect because all of your man
want didn't draw by a don effect.
>> Exactly. Absolutely. Every single player
was playing around this ability. So, it
makes sense. Finally. Did you already
have something from the side events?
>> Oh, yes. Yes. Yes.
>> What did you have? This is my metal
card.
>> So, he's got already a metal card, a
Teimo metal card. So, you know what to
do if you want to get some metal cards
as well. That being said, we're going
back to the stage.
>> I take one more
Welcome back to RQ Leal here for
Riftband. How were you just in an un
>> I don't know. I I just was there and I
changed and I'm here.
>> Now you're here. James and Loar taking
you through round two of day one. It's
still early on in the day. So we we're
learning lots of things about Spirit
Forge already. We've had one interesting
match up, Evolution and and Aurelia, and
we're getting closer to round two as
well. Uh interesting to hear that even
in the side events, you're going to meet
like good players who are already
getting their their metal cards already.
>> Yeah, people are really loving to play
Riftband, you know, over here. There's
like over 2,000 people playing not only
in the main event, but also in the side
event. There's going to be a side main
event today as well. So, there's there's
so many people playing Rift here, you
would not imagine. Hull is beautiful. Is
huge.
>> Yes, it is. There's so many people
invested bringing whether it's their
favorite deck or whether they think it
is the best deck in the room. We heard
some discussion there in the interview
with Barcode a little bit about Draven
and how the changes have come through
with the miracle version dropping off.
We talked about it a little at the
beginning of the day.
>> If someone brought a miracle deck over
here, I would like to shake his hand.
Like I'm not sure what he's thinking but
or what they are thinking, but it it
will be something else. It's the kind of
decision where you think, well, that's
really strange and then Allan would win
with it. Uh, you know, where I'm like,
"Oh, okay. Allan's just going to like a
good player of that caliber will come
and do something strange." We're not
really expecting that. Uh, today we will
expect to see some Draven later on in
the day is what I will say. There is
still a uh mid-range version going
through. We have a look at the uh the
breakdown of decks that are here for day
one of Swiss. Um, Draven no longer king.
So, I think unequivocally officially we
can say the bands work. Draven's gone.
Yay. We don't have to worry about that.
He's only second place now in the most
played.
>> But if you want to have a little bit of
context, yesterday we had pre-regional
that had also been constructed, but with
no metal foils prizes. So, the shift is
not as big as you expect. Like Draven
yesterday was 16%. Today, he's 13%.
Ireelia was 14.8% yesterday. Today,
she's 15%. So there's a little bit of
shift towards players who are trying to
win the metal foil legends, but it's not
as big as you think. People still are
aiming to play with a really powerful
deck to aim for the top 64 to get the
qualification as well for the
championship.
>> And there's a lot of things as we
continue to look down the the list.
We've talked about the top. Now we can
look at the mid part of the table where
like no one would really have have
predicted master specifically being so
high but we've heard quite a bit about
the okay I say no one loa you predicted
it in some of your content but I think
generally the conversation was not so
much around master up until the last
week or so maybe where people have
started realizing how strong it can be.
>> The thing is in my local game store uh I
have Voytech playing who won the metal
foil for Master Y in Bolognia.
>> Okay. And so I have personally a lot of
experience playing against master
mid-range. I know how powerful can it be
with a good pilot's hand, you know, and
in case of um after the bands, I
immediately asked Voytech what does he
think? Because in my eyes, mid-range
raven, sorry, mid-range Master Yi really
wins a lot in this potential landscape
shift. And he said, "Yeah, I think so as
well." So mid-range Master Y might be a
good consideration when coming to a big
event like this. It's consistent. That's
what it's very important about. It may
be the card draw is not that big, but
your biggest problem was mid-range
Draven and the consistency like drawing
cards
>> and consistency is key at a competitive
level in everything. We're from, you
know, we've had a history with League of
Legends. You and I have shared the stage
with many times your history in G2, my
history on broadcast and with Spice and
Mad Lions. I want to hear from somebody
else who has a League of Legends history
that has brought him here to Rift. It's
a good friend of mine, a friend of
everybody with League of Legends in
Europe. Let's hear from Yamato Cannon in
an interview.
I'm here with Yamato who is a very
famous face in the League of Legends
ecosystem. No, no, no. Don't be shy. I
mean, you know it. You know it for real.
Yamato, thank you so much for joining
us. How are you doing?
>> I'm doing good. I'm super excited. I
drove in 6 hours, which is very easy.
And I was I was walking through the
venue. I got nostalgic because my first
LCS game that I played as a player was
in the Zenet Arena. So, this was like 13
years ago. So, it's good to be back.
Like it feels like I'm reborn again, you
know? I'm a beginner. I'm starting a
new. It feels good.
>> Exactly. And yeah, you're a new Rebound
player. So before that, you were a lot
in League of Legends. How is it to
transition from League of Legends to
Reebound?
>> I think it feels very natural. Like I've
always collected cards, but every game
was always so intimidating in terms of
starting, but the League of Legends IP,
I love it. You know, it's like I see all
the characters I recognize, and in terms
of starting to play, it just was
natural. you know, it's like this is the
first time where I'm not competing
actively in the LEC or anything like
that. So, I allowed myself to get
addicted to something. So, I've been
going around to Nexus Knights and some
of the skirmishes and uh I've been
getting smoked but uh it doesn't feel
too bad, you know. It doesn't feel too
bad.
>> I mean, yeah. Do you think that the game
is just easy to learn but hard to
master?
>> I would say so. Yeah. I I think
everything is quite uh intuitive. Um I
think everything makes sense. Uh there's
certain like interactions that when you
learn them the one time, you will always
remember them. And I think it's also
super nice that everybody's super
helpful. Uh because I've gone to the
Nexus nights and some of skirmishes and
um everyone like if I make a mistake, I
learn something new, everyone helps each
other. There's no uh you know fierceness
in that. Uh I wonder if now with the
regional qualifier, the competition is
more fierce and more intense and that's
not going to happen. But luckily uh I
have made enough mistakes that hopefully
I don't need to make them here.
>> I mean we hope so for you. But yeah,
speaking about the the people, I would
really like to highlight the fact that
yeah, people are very helpful. They try
to help you as much as they can. So if
you do not play yet Reebound, do not
hesitate because the game is very
welcoming. Speaking about Rebound, by
the way, which one is your favorite
champion?
>> Oh, this is going to be bad because in
the first set I played Kaiser, so people
didn't like me. Then I played Miracle
Draven, so people like me even less.
Luckily, it's banned, but now I'm back
to Kaiser because that's what I'm
experienced with. Uh I'm I'm a big fan
of Kaiser. My favorite champions aren't
out yet. Uh but uh I I love the Kaiser.
It just the art is perfect and u it fits
my play style, which is to really really
annoy people uh by removing all of their
creatures and uh let them play nothing
at all
>> unless they have the flect.
>> This is Yeah, exactly. I'm an Aurelia
player, so I've got a very good matchup
to be honest. We might do some games
later on, but yeah, I think that GISA is
very, very cool to play. Arena enjoyed
it during the set one as well. Do you
think that it is well positioned right
now in the meta game?
>> I would say yes. I feel like the meta is
very rock paper scissors cuz like I I
have a bad match up into a bad match up
into like the Victor. I have a good
match up into the Victor. And then um I
think in terms of the Kaiser deck,
there's not a lot of flexibility because
there's a lot of cards that you have to
have. I have a unique take on the Kaiser
deck and hopefully uh I can I can show
that off uh and and use it uh to my
advantage and if not I'll just look
stupid but that's a part of making
decks.
>> Between us there are only the two of us.
Uh which one uh is this special deck?
Yeah,
>> it's not super special like I play a
very very heavy uh deck in terms of the
hikos cards. So I play three time warps.
I play three first four runners, three
watches of course. And then to make sure
that I don't break my hand, I play get
excited.
>> Oh, so that's a card that people are not
ready for. I can do 10 damage swings
with progress day, six damage, and
Draven players their spinning axes can't
save them, you know. So
>> absolutely. I mean, get excited is such
a good card to be honest. Being able to
just blow up some very big units is so
strong because this is kind of some of
the problems for Kai'Sa to be honest.
Sometimes you just can't get those units
out of the of the battlefield. So this
is a very good take. By the way, you
mentioned time warp. This is a very
scary card to be honest. You always have
to play around those cards. Yes, sir.
>> During the set three, because set three
unleashed has been announced. Is there a
specific champion that you would like to
play? So, since I played so boring
decks, meaning like the best ones in set
one and two, uh I am going to uh a
sealed event uh in my in my local uh TG
store. And uh hopefully what I draw,
what I pull is going to be what is
showing my path forward. But if I if I
got to choose, I would hope to play
maybe Pike, Jin, Ivvern. On paper, they
seem like the weaker decks right now,
but um I'm hoping that Riot bans Aurora
so we don't have to run into the Elder
Dragon Aurora.
>> Oh yeah, Elder Dragon is absolutely
scary. You mentioned Ivvern, and I've
got the feeling that Ivvern, I mean, a
lot of people like the champion, but I
don't really like the legend to be
honest. What is it that you really like
about the champion?
>> Honestly, it's just how goofy he is in
the in in the game, you know? He's just
walking around like he has this swag
walk about him, you know, and just says
the goofiest things. He doesn't harm the
creatures. He has tokens, cats and dogs,
and I love animals. So, it's as simple
as that. But, uh, I do think that the
deck will probably be weak, especially
against Aurora. I don't think you have
any removal, so might be cooked.
>> Yeah, that's going to be hard. But maybe
the birds will help you on this one. I
don't know. Maybe the birds on the cat
as well. to talk about the champions a
little bit more. Of course, there are a
lot of champions in League of Legends
and some of them are not in the game
yet. Most of them are not in the game
yet. Which one would you really like to
see in the game in the next sets?
>> Honestly, I'm just kind of, you know, I
love Arcane, so I just want to see the
Arcane heroes. I'm a big fan of Jace,
how he plays in the game. Uh, I liked
his arc in Arcane, too. So, I kind of
just want a Jace or I want a Himerdinger
uh legend. Uh I want something that um
maybe with the XP system that eventually
like you build towards something where
uh eventually you like make insane big
units because you have progress to that
point. Uh something like techwise in of
course Piltover. That's something that I
would want to see. Uh otherwise uh I'm
quite happy. I love I love Kaiser. I
love Ari. I hope it becomes stronger. Uh
and um other than that I'm I'm quite
happy. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I mean that looks pretty nice to be
honest. That look pretty nice to me.
Finally, some last words for you. Do you
think that you're going to win it all?
Do you feel confident during this event?
Because yeah, you told me that you were
getting smoked during the last event,
but you learned and you learned by
making some mistakes. You made a lot of
mistakes as you just said. So maybe you
learned a lot as well.
>> I I hope that my advantage is that I
have a steady hand cuz I think people
are going to come here and be nervous
and I don't think I will be because I'm
ready to lose. But in terms of how I
will do, I'll be so happy if I make top
128. If I make top 64, you'll see me do
a little dance next to my table. Uh
we'll see how it goes today in the
pre-regional qualifier. I'm hoping to
score some uh tickets to get a metal
card early, you know, one of the waifu
cards. Kaisa Ari would be nice. Bring it
home, you know.
>> Oh, yeah. I think that you can get it.
You can get those cards. I have a 100%
confidence in you and yourself and your
ability to do it. We're going to follow
your journey throughout the tournament
anyway and see how you do. Thanks a lot
for your presence. Thanks a lot for
joining us. We'll be back in a few
minutes.
Welcome back to round two of RQ Leil. We
just heard from Yamato Cannon who League
of Legends viewers will be very
familiar. And I think that was one thing
he brought up is he's cool, calm, and
collected. That's one thing he was known
for. His motivational speeches from the
coaching position in League. And as
somebody who has competed at a high
level, Loar, how important is that on a
day like today where our players have to
play eight rounds of Swiss,
>> I I feel like, you know what's funny is
that the players in TCG are actually way
more calm than when it comes to other
games in general, like FPS games, um,
RTS games. I feel like they're way more
emotional when it comes to card games.
People are like a little bit more
collected because they just kind of
flocking to to this kind of gameplay.
Anyway, but let's talk about Lolo 96
over here playing looks lady of lum
luminosity. Now remember this is round
two. This player might have had a buy in
round one. I'm actually not certain that
that's the case, but uh the deck list
that we have here is a full control list
with some amount of units and the
potential combo of Jayce and Vanguard
Armory as one of the wind conditions
over here.
>> Yeah, which I love as a combination in
my free-for-all games. That's what I
I've built a deck around doing. So,
we'll we'll touch on Lux in a little
bit. Uh those of you familiar with the
Riftbound creator scene and also getting
your information from uh Riftbound
report will recognize Marshall who uh is
running Rexi in this event. A Rexi a
deck that we think is is quite well
placed given the change to the meta from
the band. So it it's very much a a go
wide strategy. Is that fair to say?
>> It is. This is like a a little bit of a
hip hybrid because you have three
archetypes in Rexside potentially mono
yellow, a red version with under titans
and still plays seals and overall it's
just a red strategy and then we also
have Phoenix's which is like a
spell-based Rex side. This one is a
hybrid of a mono yellow with a little
bit of sprinkling of a red color here
because we do have Ferris forunners
which are incredibly powerful in in the
metag game overall. That's why it's
included. But that means that also
Marshall will be playing a little bit of
red runes.
>> Yes. And I think it's really important
to explain in Riftbound when we talk
about mono color decks. Typically that's
what we're talking about with regards to
recycling. You may very well run cards
that are from the fury archetype in
this, but typically you don't run the
runes because you you don't need to
recycle for fury. However, this one you
mentioned Ferris 4runner being a very
strong card. Marshall saying well I
don't want to run I don't want to run
the archetype without the best card out
of Fury. So let's put that in there. So,
let's see how Marshall can fare up
against Lol 96 on the Lux. I'm always
happy to see a deck like a Lux. Uh
because you you don't necessarily have
to play style down. You don't grind
games against something like a Lux,
which is going to come out with big
spells and look to to put massive damage
on later.
>> Well, just by the matchup, like the
basics of this matchup, I would say that
Rexai has a huge advantage over looks.
The problem with looks is that she will
try to get the removal spells to remove
a unit and then replace the card in hand
and try to out grind the opponent, seal
the deal with potentially a watcher or
maybe the vanguard armory. And that's
the idea of controlling the game. Now
for Marshall, he's going to have a very
unpleasant wave of creatures all the
time because because the void burer
legend will allow you to essentially
play a card from the top of your deck
almost every single turn. So this draw
engine will allow you to not run out of
steam, which is something that looks
literally wants you to do, right? She
wants to grind you out. And when the
deck doesn't get grinded out because of
the card draw engine that is being built
in inside of the legend, that inherently
puts Marshall ahead at the beginning of
this uh matchup.
>> And then it it's also very difficult to
deal with the possibility of accelerated
units that come from this Rexai
borrower, the chosen champion for
Marshall in this Rex side deck. So here
you go. Here comes the reveal from the
top from that void borrower. We'll find
a seal. Yeah.
>> So, everything has been yellow so far.
Everything uh has been order. So, I I'm
waiting to see whether Marshall has
perhaps ways of generating gold tokens
or or that type of thing. In order
broker,
>> honest broker is one of them. You're
right.
>> I would assume that he's probably
playing around nine order runes and
three fury runes. And also having the
access to fury runes gives you the
ability to play your Rex eye from
champion zone with the red one because
the typical mono yellows were playing
the five drop Rexi which is not as
powerful in my opinion or not as
flexible as the red one which allows you
to play your units from the top of a
deck accelerated as well. And remember
that the acceleration is being paid from
the color of the unit.
>> Right. Right. So if unit is yellow, you
you pay a yellow power even if it
doesn't have like a built-in
acceleration like the honor broker
played from the top of the deck. You
would play for additional energy and an
order rune.
>> Yeah, that is something to keep in mind.
I will say this has been a couple of
turns of just passing from our Lux
player, which normally is really scary.
Normally when your opponent says, I'm
going to pass and all of my runes are
up. Uh normally you think, okay, that
that's problematic. But for now, not
really seeing anything come through. And
here is our first
>> the big bad
>> view of the Ferris 4Runner for us this
tournament, which we're expecting to be
oh so pre uh prevalent throughout the
weekend.
>> Okay, so first portions of the removals
are being played. I'm wondering why did
we maybe not have the uh there has to be
a reason to play this wages of pain on
the on broker instead of the
>> borrower. Yeah, cuz you would envision
perhaps taking away the accelerate,
although that is uh you know further
used in this uh environment. Rexi will
play a hidden card. Marshall will play
that down on the uh battlefield.
Although, you know, when you're playing
up against order and you you see a
hidden card, you're like, okay, is that
just hidden blade and they're just like
posturing to just kill their own unit?
Not so much in this. It's not quite like
the Victor where you have lots of
smaller units, but you can some decks
are running like unsung hero and and
that type of thing that that has good
good combination there.
>> Yep. And we can see that hand of
Marshall has two void rushers already.
One undertitan was being in his opening
mulligan and it was on the bottom of the
deck. So there are very small chances of
actually hitting an undertitan in any of
the potential uh void rushers or for the
void burers. But now we have a really
important card. Uh, called the weak has
to be used in moments when there's not a
lot of units in play overall.
>> Okay, so in this situation, Marshall
values the the Rexside Borrower over the
Ferris Forerrunner, but then wants to
make sure that you can get the card draw
and then kill a a mech, I imagine, off
the back end of that. So So yes, that is
a heavy swing and is one way of dealing
with a Ferris Forerunner, but two cards
going into the hand from the Rexside
player. Uh, still anytime you can get
Ferris 4Runner down and one of the mechs
within the same sequence of events is is
actually not so bad if you're the Lux
player.
>> It's not so bad. But the thing is
typically against any other type of deck
that is not Rex eye, you would be pretty
happy with this development.
>> But unfortunately, when the Rexi has
access to so many cards all the time,
you're just not going to grind out the
player very easily. Right. So you can
see here Lolo is like shaking his head
like visibly stood a little bit where
the Rexa is just going to replay more
units. She's going to just play more
units all the time. Conquer. You're not
going to probably stop both concurs at
the same time. And even one goes through
that still triggers the void burer
potentially giving another unit. There's
also one thing I wanted to add. There's
also one play pattern that you will see
Rexai players do. They will play a two
drop for example or a seal before
concurring which potentially triggers
the legion from Noxus hopeful
>> right
>> that can be on top of the deck.
>> Yeah. And legion hopeful the the void
rush there reducing the cost. I believe
that's how that works right is like
because void rush has been played as a
result it can then be played for zero
which is why Marshall did not have to
tap anything from that. So it does make
sense. There were some changes that
we'll keep on uh through the rest of the
day with regards to Nox's hopeful and
some of the
>> I can explain that legion changes.
>> Yeah, when it comes up I think later
maybe is the uh the best time for us to
do that as Marshall is stacking a board
here with with a bunch more units. This
is what exactly the Rexi can do, but
another kill spell comes out to drag
under on the Rexi.
>> Mhm. And as you can see here, yeah,
that's a good move. Remove a unit from
the battlefield and deny your opponent a
point. But the problem is there were
just three units being played this turn
as well.
>> He's already restacked
>> and the looks player has to have a lot
of energy and a lot of cards.
Fortunately, the legend of looks, lady
of luminosity will get you the card
draw, but you're not going to have
enough energy at some point to remove
all of the threats. And it doesn't
matter if the threat has one, two, or
five might. They all will score a point.
>> That's what I love about Ripbound. It
It's like it's not about how much might
you have because it doesn't matter. you
just need to essentially make sure that
you can conquer a battlefield even with
one unit. So the game dynamic is so
different from any other card game that
we have on um in the industry.
>> And this is uh the finally a unit comes
out from uh from our Lux player in this
moment. I was you know we had seen some
in hand but I was like wow this looks
like those victors that were just
playing kill spells only. two cool weeks
already. So, there's a little bit of
open space now for um any of the units
from looks being played.
>> Yeah, we'll keep an eye on how the point
total comes cuz that is one thing. You
can keep on top of your opponent's units
for a while. That is uh a salvage coming
through. You can keep on top of their
units for a while, but if you don't
start scoring your own points, you're
going into the extreme late game of the
real bottom of the deck uh in order to
to turn the game around. And that's
something that looks wants to do because
um the starting battlefield the
aspirines clamp will make the game
longer go to nine points right which is
also by the way very important scoring
typically you want to score in even
numbers but because the game goes to
nine you can actually have one odd turn
when you just score one point and put
yourself at at even odds when it comes
to finishing the game because typically
we want to go to six points and double
conquer for example right to win the
game here you will have to go seven to
for this to happen.
>> Every time I play Aspirin's Climb, I get
to six and I'm like, "Yeah, I'm about to
win." And then I'm like, "Oh, that's my
own aspirin climb and I have to go
another turn." So, yeah, always got to
keep that in mind. But again, that's
what Lux wants to do is go to that super
super late game. Marshall is hellbent on
getting the void rush to uh to just keep
playing units, keep playing things.
There is a battering ram. Yeah, and this
battering ram is being uh drawn to hand
and then most like we're going to see
more card draw uh more cards being
played by Marshall which will sub
subsequently make the ram cheaper. You
could also play this ram directly from
the void rush but it will only count the
void rush as being the one card play and
then it would be also deducted by the
two from void rush. So it would make it
for two energy. Yeah, it's it's not
quite as uh as effective on its own as
as Miracle Battering Ram when when that
was prevalent. You just play three in a
turn and everything would be great. But
Marshall is just constantly finding
units off the top of his deck.
Constantly finding uh you know ways to
deal with things. And of course, it's a
nice way of putting more things into
play. That is a just a massive massive
swarm of units in base.
>> You know what Lo is thinking about right
now? He's like, "Man, I need ruination."
>> He's like, "Wait, which set are we
playing?" Or he's like, "Can you just
move everything to battlefield to like
unchecked power just a second?" Like
>> that's also, by the way, funnily enough,
I think Unchecked Power is going to be
very popular in the next set.
>> Okay, interesting. I I I would love to
hear more about that. Um I always again,
it's a spell where I'm like, "Oh, I need
to hold the battlefield." So I I
>> I mean, we're going to have hold
strategies, right? Ivan, we're going to
have Leblanc. We're going to have um Vex
of course and all of those decks are
going to struggle against unchecked
power.
>> M and uh on the other side of that like
these wide boards you already said we'll
we'll have some some board wipes coming
in pretty much for the first time in a
overall sense definitely the the kind of
place you would want that to come
through because at this point now we got
to look at okay what does what does Lux
have to deal with multiple units. I
think the Jace Vanguard's Armory side of
things is not at this point in the game
what you need. Like that's too slow to
really deal with this board from
Marshall.
>> There's the problem that Marshall is
going to keep everything in base apart
from two units. And he's just going to
send two units concur. He doesn't have
to hold anything. The only thing that he
needs to do is conquer battlefields. And
because of that, that makes the combos
from looks like the decree and vanguard
armory not really that successful
because you can only kill like two units
that are on the battlefield. So you need
to find a way of dealing the damage
>> in the base. What is a card that deals
damage in the base in the blue?
>> Well, in blue you got singularity can
what a very cheap one that goes for one
energy and has repeat.
>> So you can bellow's breath if you
>> that is the MVP card here. Here we go.
That's the one that we needed for this
to matter.
>> And without this card, it would be very
hard to start controlling this game. But
now, because it will clear potentially,
it was that five units.
I think it was five if I'm not mistaken.
That is huge value. The problem is the
Rex eye still has cards in hand in hand
and she will still have possibilities of
concurring playing something from the
top of the of the deck and refill
essentially the hand to some degree like
in a different matter but yeah typic if
this was any other deck if this was
Darius for example yeah right
>> probably would have been a done deal
because Darius would lose everything
right
>> and now I think we look into like is
this the sense of turning the corner
against the Rexai like is this enough
wiped out to now in following turns Lux
to to turn it around. I I will say
that's one of those interactions that um
I'm I'm sure our players on stage have
in mind, but I always go, "Oh yeah, you
can choose different targets with battle
breath with Imperial Decree and one
damage battlefields. You can choose
battlefield and a base. You can choose
different targets in one in one location
as well. The one thing that
>> the yellow version of Rexai
>> does not have though is the
acceleration. That's the only thing that
she lacks and that's here is being
supplemented by the uh chosen Rex side,
the red Rex side from the champions, but
unfortunately that's already dead
>> and but we do have Zenzho who doesn't
have accelerate but comes into ready. So
>> thankfully this is the double point that
um Marshall is able to do here and
trigger the card. Look at this.
Oh my. This is the You have to probably
play the although maybe you already have
six cards in your hand. Yeah, maybe you
would like to play another unit just
without dramping. Yeah, gets gets the
reveal on that and will now once again
rebuild everything in base from
Marshall. Another unit played. I mean,
at this point, Marshall's kind of
saying, okay, if you don't have exactly
again another Imperial decree and
another Bellow's breath repeated,
>> probably can can ek out a win here being
on seven. You've got to you've got to
stop my hold, which is going to make you
commit multiple units or spells. And
then you've got to deal with all four
units in the backline or at least deal
with leaving me only with one. So it is
quite sus a specific way forward for Lal
to turn this one around. And again
that's that's the other thing is it's
kind of an onslaught of relentless units
in this because Lal has such a long
climb to go up on Aspirin's climb from
zero to up to 9. There's some good cards
in this with regards to Singularity, but
here's two
>> armor man. Oh my.
>> Vanguard Armory is not going to help
here. Jace is not going to help here.
That is uh uh four cards in hand that
are not exactly what you're wanting in
this situation.
>> Yeah, it's this is like quite literally
how the matchup typically goes. At least
in game one sideboard, it might be a
little bit different, but this is going
to be very hard for looks to stop. Is
there even a way of stopping double
concur over here? I uh I couldn't see
that like the last card in hand past it,
but it's a singularity takes out two
leaves three units still there and I
don't think it's enough.
>> I mean, you already mentioned how we
we've seen like spectral matron bring um
accelerated units back from the or at
least the zingo entering ready back from
the the trash. So, I don't know. And
maybe the draw off the top, how lucky
was the draw, not lucky enough is going
to be the fist bump in order towards
head towards game number two. So the the
pace of of Rexi the go wide deck. This
is one of the decks that we expected to
come back a little bit into the meta or
come into the meta we should say.
>> This is the first moment for Rexi to
show I would say in the meta game. So
it's awesome to see um it being
represented quite a bit. It's 5% of the
entire meta game here at regional
qualifier in Liil. When it comes to
looks this is more of a side quest for
the metal foil legend I would say. But I
do know personally two players who are
playing looks because they just like
looks coming from League of Legends for
example and they just like the
character. Now the thing is did we have
any particular cards? I didn't
>> I was looking there was a watcher in
there which is kind of helpful like but
not much
>> but not much. Yeah, exactly. Uh salvage
is gear disruption so we're probably not
looking at that. Um, I there was a final
spark in there, but you know what? I've
played such little lux. I can't really
off the top of my head.
>> Is gonna have a lot of ferris on her
>> and brin here. Does Brin here come in
here and stop some of the spells or are
they mostly slow speed so you don't
actually
>> slow speed? So, you would care about
bellow's breath in your turn for
example. Uh, sometimes maybe wages of
pain as it can be also hidden as a
reaction as well. So to some degree
maybe, but at the same time I'm not
entirely sure if I would even have spots
for those cards to be slided in because
you definitely want to put it in under a
ferris for hana. That is like the
perfect answer to blue and yellow combo
because it's so hard to remove and then
get rid of the two mechs. The the game
in game one actually had one of the most
perfect counters because Rexa helped
>> like the hidden blade on its own first.
It was to some degree helpful for the
looks, you know,
>> whereas you're right, like what what
what else do you use? Singularity or
something you you have to recycle so
many resources and then it gets replaced
by two small units on on the back end
which then you need multiple spells or
another big spell to deal with.
>> It's very clunky as a
>> as a looks player to get rid of the two
mechs which are now in base, right? So
you would have to like and if for
example even if you play watcher and you
do minus three on the board the mechs
that are coming out of the ferros that's
going to get killed by a watcher they
are not affected by the minus three
anymore so you can't really like
bellow's breath into the base and just
kill them. So that there's a lot of like
puzzle solving from um from looks here.
And I feel like the win condition for
for looks here would probably be getting
the Jay's Vanguard combo as soon as
possible. Okay, one of those things will
try to accelerate the game and also give
you enough ammo to give a Imperial
Decree for example a chance to shine
earlier earlier in the game. So, does I
I I w I can't quite remember the full
Lux list, but that means you basically
have to create a gold token from the
unit or spell you play around in game
one, right?
>> Uh in in in turn one, cuz you want to
hit that Jace cuz I think Jace is four.
>> Jace is four. So, in theory, you can
play the Vanguard Armory on your turn
two.
>> On turn two, if you're really lucky in
>> if you're really lucky, right? But it's
it doesn't have to be turn two, but
ideally, it would be. Would the best
would the best way of doing that be
plundering parro turn one pass a turn
you get it back you conquer get a gold
and on your turn two you get that Jace
going is that like what we're thinking
is perhaps the best turn of events
>> but but I'm thinking now Arena's
greatest on going second
>> Marshall's laughing about it they're
like oh do do we have to okay yeah take
that point right away is it
>> that is interesting strategy I'm I'm not
certain that's very helpful we already
have one point for looks and you have
two drop. So, you're going to be a
little bit ahead on points for looks
here. Typically, you start the with
arena's greatest when you're going
first, when you have guaranteed going
first, right? Very aggressive opening
here by Marshall plays his um seal
>> in turn one and a V captain which puts
in a massive amount of might. That's
five. Also, in this deck, we have a
combo with rally rally the troops which
gives you seven might if you have it the
same turn. Is it in hand? Is this move
create a gold token Jace sack it for the
Mangard Army? That would be nuts. That
would be so cool if it if it is. I It's
something that in my games that I've
casted. I haven't seen it come off and
I've never seen it on turn two in the
games that I've casted. So, this would
be great. Uh we'll move to void gate. Um
I I guess the benefit there is you're
trying to bring your opponent in to
challenge so you can then utilize it. So
the bigger unit will go into the void
gate to go in over the porro and stay
there. So it can get affected by two
damage spell for example.
>> But unfortunately that's it. We created
the gold. We have four energy open which
can potentially now kill one of the
units that are being put um uh put to
like challenge the pora on the void
gate.
>> So Marshall's going to go to two. And
now this is where Arena's greatest is
one of those interesting things is how
much you don't have to go to three on
this turn. You also for instance on next
turn don't have to go to five. So now
you get the reveal from the Rex eye. You
can you can choose how much you develop
on on this turn, how much pace you want
to keep up because this is going to
already stack a giant board uh on turn
two and turn three of the game. So
potentially, you're right, you don't
need to go to three points. But at the
same time, why give the looks like a
breathing room with with the poor as
well, just you have so many units,
you're just going to throw everything at
at the looks and just try to make a use
the resources as well, right? So most
likely wages of pain are going to be
used here, I would say. Um, otherwise
this might be actually a little bit
clunky because we don't want to use
bellows breath for this. would have to D
ramp. Yeah,
>> which is not ideal. If you're planning
for a singularity next turn, right, then
you have to get your six runes and then
you will damp by using one gold and one
blue. So, you're going to be at seven
after the round that so you can play
Vang Armory from hand. But the game is
going to go fast. That's the problem.
You're going to be losing points. You're
not going to clear. Your opponent will
double conquer every turn. If that would
be the plan like singularity and the
vanguard armor armory then your Rexai
opponent will be already at like seven
points. Sorry, six or seven.
>> I would love
>> Ah, I did the meme. No,
>> you did indeed. You did indeed. I'd love
to see what Lal has in in hand because
that was just accepting that showdown
resolution without playing an action.
So,
>> we know there wasn't a Jace and Armory
combo combo that I'm guessing wasn't a
wages of pain. It looks like a bellow's
breath. That is the singularity you were
talking about. So say choosing not to d
ramp off. Um
>> maybe there's a bellow's breath in hand
then.
>> There is. Yeah, there was one. I'm
pretty sure I saw that.
>> Wait, he didn't use the gold. Oh, so if
he didn't use the gold,
that means he's trying to keep the
combo.
>> Yeah, that would be my inference there
as well. Wanting to keep that around.
>> So does that mean everything else is
then in hand? I haven't had too much of
a look past the Bellow's breath. That's
what I was focusing on last time. We
ended up seeing Lal's hand. We'll go
back to Marshall's turn for now, who at
this point has the the two recruits.
>> So much tempo. Oh my two Zen Zhou a
Ferris for Does he have a red one? Uh a
red rune.
>> Uh yes, has two of them. So will be able
to play it when he wants to. But I I can
see the the thought process here of just
like, okay, I'm going to continue to
just play units, play units, play units.
uh don't want to like slow myself down.
>> I I like this because the thing is you
play Ferris Forana to have essentially
an unkillable unit but at the same time
the odd option is you know what I'm just
going to play a three drop and then a
get a concur effect and play another
unit from the top of the deck which is
most likely almost the same as a ferris
but I'm not dramping because I'm not
going to have to play
>> red because we have these yellow seals.
the solution to a full board is a lot
harder to find and and a lot more costly
like with the imperial decree bellow's
breath combination that you're talking
about rather than dealing with the six
might ferris. So I I I do understand
that there is some of the combo there's
no chase. There's also one more synergy
that maybe the Rexi players could be
looking at the end is playing the
champion zone Rexi. Yeah.
>> And then using first for Anna which can
be like
>> you know die maybe or like sack it with
your own cool the week and then you can
accelerate the mechs.
>> Oh because they come Okay. Yeah, that
makes
so you can accelerate them and have
additional like units to just go in.
Right. H that is uh that is a another
layer of like thinking about how that
actually plays out of the effect coming
from Ferris 4Runner. So another cinch
out will get played. That's a lot
moving forward as going to go in
>> relentless. No, it's like a tsunami wave
going over and over.
>> And the other thing about the the
recruits here is like Lal really doesn't
want to use anything to deal with them.
Like that feels so bad to to use a full
spell or D ramp in any way to deal with
one might units
>> either. Nothing was being played. And by
the way, if you are a little bit newer
to the rift bound, if you reveal several
cards and you have to recycle them at
the same time, you have to do randomize
order. That's why Marshall was asking if
Lolo wants to cut it,
>> which is always funny. Uh you do have
the choice normally a competitive real
at that point. Most people wouldn't just
to save time, but uh you can be uh can
be playing by the exact rules if you
want. Um as Marshall will now move a
second unit in
>> so wanting the honest broker to
>> the thing is just you maybe don't want
to keep like three units in one location
against splitting up a little bit so
it's like a little bit more awkward to
target everything,
>> right? Because if this is Imperial
decree bellow's breath turn then you
would lose the entire backline with one
bellow's breath and then repeat lose
everything
>> you will
>> for the future like maybe it will matter
like maybe you will go back
>> very little difference here if it's in
base or in the battlefield and against
looks against a deck like this like
looks will not going to try to attack
you most likely unless it's a watcher
turn but if you do a watcher a watcher
that's exactly eight so you don't have
any energy left to do anything after the
watcher. So, that's not not ideal
typically. Oh, wait. No, you actually
can add energy from the looks um crown
guard, right? So, you're going to be
able to play a bellow's breath and d
ramp for one. Okay.
>> Oh, wait. We have gold. So, we can
actually do the full combo with the
watcher and the bellow's breath over
here if needed.
>> If needed, which at this point, I would
say needed is key. Needed. This is the
time. I think we're learning a little
bit more or at least confirming what we
suspected is the meta right now is quite
quick on a lot of the decks that are in
the top uh of the meta do like to play
out quite fast, get points early. It
we're a little bit back towards the
origins pacing of like rush to six and
then whoever can get over that last
little line really quickly with just one
more burst rather than slowing the game
down and and avoiding combat. So here is
the watcher. Mhm.
>> Watcher is going to come in accelerated.
>> So minus threes will hit.
>> I'm not certain we really badly needed
the acceleration though.
>> There is the tap on Lux. So
acknowledging the the Watcher uh minus
three on everything.
>> Gold used recycle. So that is going to
be Bellow's breath played exactly as you
said. So most of the board is going to
drop here.
Uh that was always pretty much going to
be Hidden Blade. So it will be hidden
blade on the own recruit. That bellow's
breath will not therefore deal with the
the recruit and the honest broker.
That's where the watcher is going to go
next. So that will clear everything.
There is the the full clear on the
board.
>> And that also answers my question. Was
the acceleration needed?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Because it's got to tidy up tidy
up the last few units that um that that
remained. So Lal I mean this is the the
the most empty Marshall's board has
looked with the most full the board has
looked on Lal's side. This is one of
those moments where actually this looks
winnable. But the problem is now
Marshall is already at seven points and
his opponent has two units. If you have
two cool the weeks, that's an answer. If
you have even one cool week, it actually
kills one of the units that is very
valuable and that would make it very
uncomfortable for Lolo, right? Like
which one do we kill? Okay, so we start
with the accelerated.
Are we going to actually see the accel?
No, we can. We cannot. I was thinking we
can play Ferris Forana from hand acceler
um and then kill it somehow but we don't
>> one energy short right for for that. So
but it will be a conquer. Oh
>> oh here we go the map. So this is the
first time we actually has see an under
titan revealed. So just so people
watching will understand titan when
revealed in any way adds two energy to
your pool. So now we just essentially
have additional two energy and that
changes the entire round. How do we play
this? Because we have additional two
round two energy that we typically would
not have. That's one of the ways of
actually going over 12.
>> Yeah. Am I crazy? Or we didn't need to
use that two energy for the Noct is
hopeful, right? Cuz it was revealed from
like Rexi
has already been played and then
revealed it and it's minus two. Maybe
I'm going crazy. I thought Legion would
have already applied from Rexi being
played. Uh but um we'll continue.
>> Yeah, it was. It should have been
applied.
>> Okay. I think
>> so. But you still have to play pay two
for the Noxus, right?
>> Because it was void rush. It was void
rush before. Thank you. That that's one
of the things about this deck that can
can be can be a little bit keep track of
is like what are you revealing from? Is
it a void rush or is it from the the
Rexai? Yeah, you're absolutely right.
Thank you for for for picking up on
that. That was just the legend ability.
I like what Marshall did here. He is not
like, you know, worried about the tempo
of the game. He is ahead on points so
massive. He's actually insane. 7 to
four. He just completely refilled his
entire board. He also drew a card from
conquering a battlefield at seven
points. Has now put again a win
condition, right? Because the Rexai is
now a win condition. Yeah. So the focus
from Lolo has to be I have to remove the
Rexai. If I don't remove the Okay,
that's it. I guess there was no way of
stopping everything, right?
>> Shows the vanguard armies that were in
hand and that means Marshall from
Riftband report is going to be
successful in round two of RQ Le. Um I
really would have loved to seen more
time for the Lux deck, but that is the
meta that we're in or at least we're
expecting to be in is like pressure
early presence early on in the game and
and Lux not being able to stabilize um
is not quite enough unfortunately. Well,
to be fair, I think this might have been
one of the worst matchups or looks like
ever. Uh, like
>> even
>> when you play Rexai, you're like, I want
to play against blue yellow. And I the
best way of playing against blue yellows
against typical control decks which
don't play a lot of units, right? And
that's essentially what almost happens
in every single uh game. But um I would
say that the looks if we will have seen
that combo a little bit earlier like I
mean we didn't see it at all.
>> Yeah, I was going to say we need just
need to see it. Uh
>> there's a possibility that's one of the
scenarios where the looks can actually
try to stabilize the board and I feel
like uh um in general the looks players
might still do well and go to top day
two in this meta game because I feel
like it might be a little bit easier
than in the previous meta game against
miracle decks for example. Interesting.
I'm I'm looking forward to hearing and
and seeing more from from the Lux side
of the day because once you do get that
that combo out, you kind of just get
those free resources every single uh
turn. You get the recruits, you can
utilize them with, you know, Imperial
decree. They're a lot more expendable
than the the the kill spells that come
from just out of hand to deal with
things. So interesting to see. I mean,
first successful Rexai that we've seen
today. Um there are a couple of builds
of Rexi. I think one of them uh has
fallen out of the meta a little bit more
with the Phoenix's. I know that things
better this
>> I knew Metal Card Hunters uh some of the
challenger TCG players were playing it
but I know that they changed for in
instance Legion with Sundisk you were
talking about you know knowing that
those interactions so interesting to see
where we're at with Rexi.
>> Yeah I feel like uh the most popular is
going to probably not even be what
Marshall played okay is going to be the
red Rexi with red seals but it just
plays the full package of the red
creatures. So I'm going to have Kai'Sa
Daruses and Ferros for all three of So
basically you have like a very
consistent mid-range. Uh but also what
you have to think about in this
particular deck is like when you have a
deck that can play a seal and Darius
that is one of the few decks on the in
the entire game that can play a seven
might unit on turn two going second and
attack into a battlefield. That changes
the math.
>> Yeah, that does
>> quite like in a big way. it shifts the
entire dynamic of the game, you know,
but um I'm very happy to see like my
personal bias comes in because I'm a Rex
player myself, but uh I really like to
see the Rex perform because this is
probably the best moment for a Rexai to
for the first time go into like a top
eight of a really big tournament and I
feel like it it is doable. I don't know
which type of Rexai could be doing that,
but I feel like the the hybrid version
should probably be able to. I'm
terrified of seal turn two Darius.
That's scary. Darius, one of the most
scary units in the game. Um, we finished
that one so quickly that we can go into
our second feature match, which means we
can bring you more Riftbound. We can we
can talk about cards being played uh in
the game. So, in just a moment or two,
we'll jump into the last game of this
series. And you know, we were talking
about Darius
>> different potentially, but I have heard
rumblings. Oh, it is Champion Zone uh
Trafarian Darius. I've heard rumblings
of Hook Darius being uh quite well
placed yesterday in the pre- regional,
>> but probably it's going to be the other
version of Darius because if you played
Hook, you probably played the yellow.
>> That's what I was thinking. That's why I
was was interested by the change of
chosen champion. That being said, we are
into an inser round. So, it will be
interesting to know whether this is a
change of chosen champion, which of
course for newer Rifan players, you are
eligible to change your chosen champion
following game one of a series, but I
think that this is likely uh as you
said, a different Darius deck. We will
keep an eye as we go. We're against the
Yasawa, which is another deck that we
don't see too often. Um, people like to
call it kind of like Ireelia at home in
some ways. Um,
>> it's unfortunately it is kind of like a
budget version. I would say not
essentially budgeted, but it it feels
like just a downgrade from Aelia to some
degree.
>> Does a lot of the same things with the
movement uh and utilizing, you know,
high high mobility units within the
game. So, treasure hunter comes forward.
>> Look what they an explosive turn one.
Rally the troops into Noxus hopeful.
That is turn one on three resources,
right? Three energy. You add one from
the Legion from the Darus and you
suddenly have a five might unit on turn
one.
>> Yeah, that's scary. That is uh that is a
good place to start. Meanwhile, on the
other side, Celicorn Herder, one of I
think the best units poundforpound in
Spirit Forge meta of Rift Band. The
number of cards this this unit will draw
is insane. Treasure Hunter is going to
uh give its life for the gold token.
seen this enough uh to happen now that
we don't have reaver's row or anything
in the meta anymore. You move that
treasure hunt to the battlefield, those
chances are it's dead on the next turn.
>> Also wanted to point out uh there's a
very nice battlefield here being used,
seat of power, which is great in
aggressive colors. What I mean by that
is that if you have access uh to ready
units or accelerated units, it's pretty
easy to like conquer at the other
battlefield and then conquer seed of
power as the second one and draw a card
because you're controlling the other uh
battlefield before. So it is potentially
a three card draw for both players. But
in the metag game, I feel like the the
decks that take full advantage of this
is essentially yellow and red.
>> Okay. While decks like purple probably
are playing with lower amount of units
or they want to move back from the
battlefield. So they might not even like
get the possibility of conquering and
holding the the two battlefields at the
same time. So or will actually bait
people into staying on the battlefield
to get that as well. So um it is a very
neat like uh uh battlefield to be chosen
in the current metag game. I really like
it a lot myself.
>> Speaking about battlefields and
placement, um it's rare you see people
stack one battlefield. I I would guess
is the reason for this on Darius because
as you ready on the next turn, your
first action with a Darius can be to
bring it back to base and then you play
two cards and it's going to untap anyway
and you'll move it to the second
battlefield. So,
>> but he will stay on the battlefield
then.
>> Oh, you you keep him on the one
battlefield.
>> So, essentially what what um Son here is
saying is that I don't want to risk like
a discipline uh something on top or like
an equipment to kill my Noxious Hopeful.
So, I'm going to stack 11 might, which
is very hard to break with five energy.
Six. Was it six or five? Anyway, it
would have to be like a very unlikely
combination of multiple cards to
actually break this or had to be like a
charm, which would also cost an energy
uh sorry, a power. So, it will damp. Uh
and in this case, holding the
battlefield allows you to not lose your
Nexus hopeful. And now we're going to be
able to go back to base and decide if
you want to attack with the Darius at
some point. Get the draw by the way as
well, right? Because you're going to be
having the red Noxes on the other
battlefield and then go back and
probably sacrifice the Darus to a
potential attack in the future turn.
>> Okay,
>> but this way you are essentially
guaranteeing that you don't lose the
Noxus.
>> Okay, that makes sense. Uh we saw a
speller come out from Ayaso, a card that
outside of we haven't seen too much. Um,
and or that's mostly for for uh prize
card hunters. Of course, it will, you
know, give additional effects based on
equipment and that type of uh thing.
We'll see where that pairs up with as we
go.
>> So, here we have two cars being played.
They untap the Darius. He might go into
the seat of power, but I wanted to
finish what I was saying.
>> This Felonger is most likely here for
the purple Yasuo that is in the champion
zone, the Yasua Wind Rider because
you're going to be able to get double
points moving, right? So you might have
like this kind of illusion type of combo
uh with less cards.
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> But you still have to put in the effort
to actually move in, right? So you have
to like move with the legend, do right
the wind or something like that. Uh or
flash and u emperor's divide. I'm not
sure what list is playing. I'm not an
expert on I'll be honest with you. Like
I don't know the the the list by heart.
>> Yeah. But um potentially there are some
ways of accelerating the game by getting
points where you shouldn't be getting
them.
>> Yeah, that is uh a fair point on
accelerating the game.
>> I was thinking something very exciting
is happening because of the slow-mo.
It's like, oh, he's going in. He's
attacking for 18. We have to look at
slow-mo and destroy.
>> You're just talking about accelerating
the game. And we we we figured we'd go
the the other way for a little moment.
Uh it's interesting. We, you know, I I
don't want to compare Aurelia and Yaso
too much because they do have their own
flavor to it. I will say though that
while playing in this color combination
um of, you know, chaos and body, you are
missing defiant dance, which is like the
best combat spell
>> and you don't gain much.
>> Yeah, that's the only thing you do gain
like another way to win the game, which
is cool with Yaso. I think that is
really cool. You get, you know, another
way of moving things around. So, I I'll
be interested to see how the rest of the
deck uh kind of fills out around that. I
feel like we're watching like a Rexai
game again with a number of units that
has just swarmed on to the base and
battlefields for Darius. As you said,
rightly at the beginning of the game,
not hook Darius. This uh is very much so
the other direction.
>> Yeah, this is the Storm version and it's
and you're right, it is very similar to
Rexi. the same deck essentially uh
specifically because they play the token
version here of uh we can see like it's
it's the one that wants to play as many
creatures as possible rely the troops
buffs everything when it's being played
that potentially like really powerful
bursts uh with units from the hand but
the thing is the difference here is that
Darius doesn't really have a reliable
way or reliable way of refilling his
hand and refilling the board so Darius
against looks for example would be much
better matchup for the looks.
>> Okay. Right.
>> Because you have to deal with a faster
outpost of units because of the legion
from hand of Noxus and potentially like
a very powerful unit like this Noxus
hopeful at five might turn one or like
multiple units turn one which will speed
up the game as well. But if the looks
would have had multiple answers to units
then the Darus struggles with refilling
if he doesn't get for Kaisa for example.
>> Right. Whereas Darius, maybe you're like
you're hidden blading your own recruit
to try and draw, but you're still using
resources to to refill rather than Rex
eye where it's like reveal off the top
and then you
>> for free. It's just like think about it.
Rex is kind of broken. It's like a card
draw every turn. That's crazy.
>> Rexite players are celebrating hearing
that all over the place. So charm goes
on to the Darius to soften up that uh
the seat of power a little bit. A lot of
cards in hand for
>> that.
feel great though. No,
>> none of them on their own feel like
they're going to be able to break
through the Darius. Like I I feel like
this combination of colors is a lot
about getting one really big unit, which
if you can't win every combat with that
all the time, it it can be a struggle to
deal with multiple units, but that is
another discipline coming off the top.
So, we'll just immediately get it used
and that will be enough to take out the
uh the unit on the seat of power. But
the problem is we fully tapped out now
as the Yasu. We can go back to um to the
base. Yeah, we at four points. We
cannot.
>> Wait, does he have two more energy? No,
I thought he was he might have moved the
uh Stellon Herder to the arena's
greatest to essentially get ganking, but
I don't think he has.
>> So, we had a tide turner bring it back
to the base already. So, I I'm assuming
if there is a way of doing it perhaps
with the Yasawo. Um I'm looking at
exactly what we've got available. So it
is a a hidden card coming through. Of
course, no fight or flight anymore. So
uh it reduces one extra um possibility.
There could be another tide turner which
would potentially save the the Celicorn
Herder at least for now.
But there's a lot of units and one of
them is a Darius as well which is only
going to be more scary. I think it's a
precarious position for our canours to
be in. Darius just eclipses another unit
on the the base because the the space
we're running out of.
>> How much might do we have here? That's
that's incredible amount of might. Oh,
so this just gets slammed for the Titan.
>> You get a card out of it. You get the
card draw of the Titan. It was do this
or lose both of them anyway. Uh, so I
guess
>> get the card that's kind of doomed to
resolve the rest of this turn anyway
with the way that Darius is likely to
play this out.
>> Now we get the plus two on the Daruse.
We don't even care about the ready, I
guess. And we're just going to go in
and win the win the battle over here. 7
to five. Yeah, this is looking bleak for
Yasu, I would say.
>> It's another reason why Brin here so
prevalent in the meta. Uh the ability to
shut your opponent out for a turn is is
not to be underestimated with how much
it could do in this turn doesn't really
do too too much because our canours
>> was already uh pretty much fully tapped
out for the turn. But on a turn where
you do have runes available, it forces
all of those spells to come out first.
And you can also see the the reason why
seed of power is being played in Darus
over here because again this color is
great for aggressive plays but you're
just puking out cards and you have to
refill somehow in your hand. And in the
case of seat of power here it's very
easy to get that refill right. So that's
one of the battlefields that kind of
really fits well into the strategy of
your deck.
Whereas uh I mean anytime I see a
Stellicorn holder I'm like yes draw more
cards but sometimes there sometimes
there's a limit to it. Sometimes you
>> I mean
>> sometimes you just have a handful of
cards that don't win the game for you in
the situation.
>> He has what nine cards in hand
>> at least something like that feels
>> and but energy there's less energy than
cards in hand.
That is that is a a bad problem to have
and especially when you're running low
on units and one of the only real
choices from here is like to play the
Yasawo out from the the chosen champion
zone because you know your opponent
pretty much has this unlock last turn.
You have to clear at least one
battlefield to a standard they cannot
reconquer next turn.
>> Yeah, I mean there's win condition right
now on the board, right? There are two
holes over here and then in the base you
have a potential reconquer. So, it's
really really dire for Yasaw. But I
wanted to point out to something like
metag game wise in this match. You can
see how opposite of the spectrum that
both of those decks are.
>> Yeah.
>> One of them is just playing as many
cards as possible as fast as possible
getting as many as many points as
possible as well. The other one is more
a little bit like I will lose some
tempo. I will play a speller. Uh that
that that didn't do anything this this
particular game, right? It could have
been equipped to the Stellacon herder
and damp and get me even more cards.
Yeah. Right. But that doesn't win me
anything. Right. So here we have um a
lot of the cards that that were being
used for Yasu that are trying to convert
you into the late game, but the problem
is you're playing against a deck that
doesn't care about the late game and
wants to finish the game earlier. So all
of this potential card draw that
Arcantos over here has doesn't really
matter. Like you will not have the time
to use all of them. And even if you will
use some of them, you will probably
dramp again and that gives debriefing
room for the Darius to again play more
cards.
>> Yeah, there there are some games that
you play where you're just like, I'm
fine with you drawing more cards because
you already have a quarter of your deck.
Like fine, take another one. It's fine.
>> I'm not going to play sabotage against
12.
>> Exactly. Like go for it. It's it's fine.
At this point, uh Fizz will be able to
take one. The back end of this is like,
okay, there's two energy available for
the next turn. Uh, and so many units in
base to go past this Fizz. You get the
hold on the arena's greatest and it is
eight, of course, that we're going to.
There's uh no no additional uh
requirement past that. So, I really just
don't know that there's much the other
side of this. I think Arc canource is
just thinking through every option,
thinking through every last thing, but
is likely the handshake comes through.
Yeah, San will be able to stack just an
overwhelming board and take down game
three of this best of three.
>> Crazy rounds two. Two yellow red decks
are taking over. Who would have thought?
>> I realized they said game three. I
second guessing whether it was. Doesn't
matter.
>> I think it was 1 zero now.
>> I think you're right. I think it was two
and zero. Anyway, it's uh it's early on
in the day. We're we're warming up on
things as San will end up getting the
win on the Darius, a deck that, you
know, I saw it on the top tables a
little bit yesterday and I'm like, okay,
I I see you Darius. I I see you there
hovering around the edge of the meta.
>> It's one of the decks that will struggle
against um removal based decks, right?
And potentially I'm actually I don't
think it will struggle against mid
Draven. I'm not an expert over here. I'm
not going to lie to you. I'm like, "Oh,
I was playing mid Draven against Jarus
so often and I know everything." But I
feel like from the perspective of the uh
fights that are potentially happening
between those two two decks, mid-range
Draven might actually have a problem
with winning combat and if he doesn't
win combat, he will not get control,
right? And then if you're like have the
ability of controlling the base with
potentially cool the week because Darius
has access to cool week, has a lot of
tokens, so he doesn't care if someone
something dies on inand uh and has um
still like overwhelming amount of units
coming all the time. I feel like you
should be favored into the mid-range
race.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's it's an interesting
one. We'll keep an eye on throughout the
rest of the day. Uh we can take a look
at the standings following round one of
the day. So, it's very early on. We're
looking a little bit at some of our
featured players. That's what we are
actually keeping our eyes on.
>> I like how Alan Alan's here.
>> Alan got his round one win while having
breakfast this morning. That was his
win. uh will come through. Unfortunately
for Yamato Cannon um who we saw in an an
interview at the beginning of the day
will start zero and one unfortunately
that that Kaiser build not necessarily
>> the third most popular deck in the game
right now. Sorry and RQ li
>> but to be fair I don't feel like Kai'Sa
is a great choice for this particular
event. Kasanova holding up the the
banner for the casting team uh in
general for for Riftband winning his
first round. Some other names of course
those of you that that will follow
Riftbound on social media just in
general will will recognize of course
Ry's up there as well. I'm guessing
Randy had a buy. I feel like Ry's played
and won enough.
>> I think he has buy for the next year
all the all the regionals for the up to
2027 or something like that. He's
probably has all of them.
>> Yeah, I think Randy is pretty safe in
the knowledge of uh getting through
round one of of most of the tournaments.
>> And we have seen also I think
Specialist, the best of winner from
Teemo.
>> Oh, nice. Yeah,
>> the name was Spy, but I'm just assuming
there was just like a few letters
missing and that should be specimen who
was in Bologna. He won the best of card
with Teemo and he was playing a very
aggressive uh Teemo version with Noctton
for example.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. Uh I am curious what kind
of Teemo is playing now because the deck
doesn't have access anymore to some
crucial cards like the cold shot for
example, right? Which then cuts out
Noctton for example, right? But he's
again playing Teemo. So playing for that
metal foil play legend I guess.
>> Well, once we have him come across the
feature match area, we'll have a better
understanding of what he is playing. Um
there's a lot that I'm I'm interested in
seeing throughout the day. We've seen
some Aurelia already. Um, I think I'm
I'm good to see some more Kai'Sa. I
think I know people from Origins are
like, "Ah, we've seen a lot of Kaiser."
But you know what? I think it's kind of
well placed right now as interesting
matches. At some point, I'm sure we'll
get a Kaiser and Aurelia because that is
such a difficult match for Kaiser that I
I do also love the intricacy of how
those two archetypes of deck play out
against each other.
>> Correct. Like it also very heavily
depends on how the Kaisar is being
built. Yeah,
>> there are like two potential ways
actually three. Like you have the more
tempo oriented Kaisar that is more about
units and then some removal that is very
tempo efficient like falling star and
piercing light and less about like for
example singularity or uh Cafe and Rain
is not even in the metag game that much.
But anyway, the point is you either have
the the more and tempo oriented list or
the more controly list that is for
example playing get excited and time
orbs and you potentially have a way of
killing Ireelia through spells which is
not something that typically happens
right
>> and one thing that has affected both of
those decks uh both from Kaiser in
Origins and Aurelia in the release of
Spirit Forge is the change to
battlefields. We've obviously had the
bands dreaming tree is huge for both of
them to go out of the meta. So this is
our metag game breakdown for
Battlefields being played in Le. of
course we have three removed in Obelisk
Reavers and Dreaming Tree. So Taran's
Peak, everybody wants to be Annie.
Everybody wants to uh
>> Why does not play Annie? Hello.
>> Exactly. Sanka Temple going to be there.
Zorn Warren Arena's greatest being so
high prevalence and Vile Mo has dropped
a little bit but I think that you know
we were seeing a lot of
>> dropped. You think so? I feel like it
actually went up.
>> Okay. I I that it maybe because I'm an
Aurora player. I play Aurora and Ahri.
So I'm like I'm just gonna put Vl. So
maybe you're right. Maybe it's come up a
little bit. Uh void. I
>> feel like the Vmar's layers are going up
in uh play because of yellow blue
>> also being up in the population. Like
for example, Victor is the fourth or
fifth most popular deck right now in in
in RQL. Uh but overall it's definitely
nice to see more variety in the
battlefields that we currently have in
the metag game because obvious compiler
was really homogenizing the the entire
field. You know it's like it was making
the game a little bit more stale and
here we have a lot of more interaction
as well having tag and speak being a
most common battlefield. You have to
learn how to utilize this for yourself
to actually have a chance at winning the
games where your opponent will be using
them as well. You have to remember that
tagon speak is most likely the
battlefield that you're going to be
choosing when you're going first, right?
It also one of the very interesting
aspects of build tech building in
riftbound is like understanding which is
your neutral battlefield. Which one is
your battlefield when I'm going first
and which one is the battlefield when
I'm going second, right? And Aruna's
greatest is the best example because
it's so aggressive that you want to
always go first with it, right? But with
target speed, it's very similar. So you
can play Arena's greatest and target
peak most likely in the same deck, for
example.
>> Yeah, I think that's one of those things
that makes these matchups so interesting
as well because you know a lot of
battlefields can be asymmetrical in like
I want it for my deck and I know it
doesn't do much for you and then you get
into a mirror and you're like wo how do
we both play because suddenly everything
is good for everybody. So, um, yeah,
we'll keep an eye on Battlefields
throughout the rest of the day. Lots of
fun stuff going on, lots of changes to
the meta, even though I know people
thought it's just a little bit of a
shakeup. I think the versions of the
decks that are being run are quite
drastically different. I mean, we have
different um versions of the Draven, for
instance. We've had changes to Kaiser.
Um, different version of Ezreal. Ezreal,
last event in Bolognia was all about
locking your opponent out of the game.
Now, it's more about intricate math and
saying, "Okay, I need to make this unit
low enough to be able to gust it back
and and how to actually balance that."
So, I think there's a lot more at stake
in the meta on on those minor decisions
than before.
>> I Yeah, you're right. You're you're spot
on. I think also what is one of the most
interesting things about this meta game
is that the deck variety went up. Even
though they're potentially the same
legends, but the variety inside of the
deck list,
>> yeah,
>> they are bigger than in the past. We had
very optimized lists with the previous
state of the game specifically because
with access to having cards like scrap
heap, cold shot, and ezro prodigy that
if you play purple, you're most likely
to play those nine cards, right? And and
because of that, your deck building
process gets simplified. Right? Now, you
have to find other options and how do
you how do you play this game now
without having the access to so many
options. there's going to be deck
building process like where you cannot
have many one-offs because now you have
to actually get to draw them more
consistently by normal card draw or like
more expensive card draw than for
example cold shot. So the purple decks
that we're going to see nowadays they do
not play like one rebuke they most
likely play two or three rebukes if they
feel like the meta game is revolving
more about Ferris Porana and you have to
have an answer because otherwise you're
going to struggle. So, I feel like the
game is in a really great spot. Like
from a both competitor and viewer
perspective, it's going to be more
variety and also more interesting
gameplay also because of lack of fight
or flight, which changes the dynamic of
how the math works out.
>> Yeah. And you don't have to worry about
a just a hidden power cost card that
affects you for like minus 5 orus.
>> It is huge. Big big swing. I mean,
you're right. We we're in such an
interesting spot in the meta, especially
knowing we're getting a whole new set
worth of cards uh in, you know, a couple
of weeks time. I mean, we we have a few
moments just as we're getting things
together for round three. Of course, we
uh need all around two matches to finish
in time so that we we have a couple more
minutes to talk statistics and talk a
little bit about the cards that we're
seeing and how things are shaping up as
we're only in round two, but we do have
our stats at play. So, we can take a
look perhaps at some of the cards that
we're expecting. Actually, you know
what? I said we're waiting for for
teams. We've actually got something more
interesting than us yaking. Let's hear
from our last champion. Let's hear from
Alan who's with Barcode. Sweet.
I'm in the air. We're actually back on
the floor with Marshall indeed who is
with me. How are you doing today?
>> I'm doing really well. I've just did my
game on stream. Uh who owed it against
the looks. I'm feeling very confident
today. I uh yeah, the games went perfect
on stream and I was hoping I can
continue that going throughout the day.
>> Yeah, when I saw that I saw that you
were playing Rexai and that's absolutely
insane because this legend some players
saw that it might be able to win it all.
So why exactly did you choose this deck
and did you pick this legend? So, I
played Darius in Bologonia and I went
five and three and I figured out that
the deck was struggling in some of the
areas and Rexi fixed those areas. Mainly
the draw. Rex eye giving you that extra
card with the legend trigger just helps
you with your hand. You can find the
cards you're looking for. Uh but yeah,
overall Rexi is performing very well for
me. I want to skirmish on Sunday. So,
yeah, I'm I'm just hoping that I can do
better. Maybe go 62, maybe make day two
tomorrow. So, we'll see.
>> But for now, it's going very well for
you. Did you hesitate with other legends
or was it a straight of choice for the
Rex eye?
>> Uh because I played Darius last regional
qualifier. It was potentially that I was
going to play Darius, but after testing
Rex Eye and with the games that how the
games were going, I was quite happy with
the list and I was just like, "No, I'm
going to stick with Rex Eye. I'm not
going to look at anyone else." It has a
really good match up into Aurelia, which
is the most brought deck, I think, most
brought deck for today. So, I'm hoping
that I find a lot of Aurelia and then I
should make it quite far.
>> Is there a particular hard match up for
you? Yeah, I don't want to see any
Kaisers. If I if I see a Kaiser, they
they can ruin my day. Um there is quite
a lot of Kaisers about. I'm just hoping
that I fall into the more Aelas than
Kaisers, but it's not unwinable for me.
Okay, so it's not unwinable. That is the
most important because some players
sometimes they pick a deck and I mean
there is an unwinable matchup and when
they are paired up against this deck
that is so hard. So unfortunately for
you, you're not in that situation. We're
going to hope that it's going to go well
for you. But speaking more about the
venue itself, how do you think the
atmosphere is right now?
>> Well, it's the biggest regional
qualifier, I believe. So, there's a lot
of people about with just short of 2,000
people playing in the event. There's a
lot of people. It's very loud when
everyone's finished with their games.
Um, but yeah, atmosphere is really good.
The atmospheres here are always really
good. Uh, so yeah, I'm just hoping that
everyone's has a fun time and that they
uh try and win and do the best that they
can. I mean, yeah, it actually makes a
lot of sense. And I can see on your face
that you're taking a lot of pleasure. We
can see right behind us that there are a
lot of players and all of them are ready
to try to win it all. You're doing great
for now. We are going to wish you that
it's still going great throughout the
whole day. Maybe we'll take some news
about your Rexai strategy. But for now,
we are going to go back on stage.
Hello everyone and welcome back.
Regional qualifier Leo. We just saw
round number two and you're now seeing
me as Blevens. you as Amy, we are here
to get us ready for round number three
coming up.
>> Yeah, getting straight back into the
action. We've already seen four totally
different kind of matchups and decks and
we even got a bonus last round. So, we
got to see two of our feature matches
which is incredible seeing the diversity
of that Rexai deck and really what it
can bring to the table.
>> Yeah, I mean I I'm not going to hold it
back. I know Marshall, so I was I was
rooting for him in the back. So, uh
thumbs up for Marshall there. But Rexi,
a deck that we knew knew was knew was
going to be uh more represented in this
event. I mean, I think in in Bolognia
and even Vegas, not I mean, we saw them
obviously because people are always
going to be playing for best of metal
cards.
>> Uh but I think now Rexi is a real
contender. I would not be surprised if
we see a Rexi in the top eight.
>> No, we saw how aggressive it can be
right there. Flooding the board early on
and then just keeping up the pressure
forces your opponent to respond in turn.
And if they're just not a deck that can
do that,
>> which a lot in the format aren't. A lot
of these decks right now, especially
things like Ezreal, which has proven
very popular, it's slow in the
beginning. You're slow and steady.
You're trying not to use too many
resources. Rex eye forces your hand.
Yeah, Rexai can be super aggressive like
we saw and but it's deceptively has late
game as well because we saw Marshall was
playing that, you know, had the ability
to play something like a Ferris
forunner, spend all of their energy to
do that, but instead they're going, "All
right, I'm going to play a small unit.
I'm going to conquer. I'm going to
trigger the void borrower, which is
effectively drawing me an extra card."
Oh, yeah.
>> And I'm keeping cards in hand. I'm
putting cards in onto the board and
keeping up that pressure while also
keeping cards in hand. I mean, that's a
recipe for success in any deck. Yeah, if
you ask me, you know, it's got a lot
more powerful since some of the bands
have turned the tides a little bit,
being able to push back decks that were
troublesome for Rexi, which have also
faltered in popularity as we've seen
from our standings and how we've kind of
got that really on the tippity top at
the moment.
>> Yeah. So, it definitely Yes. order was a
a domain that really I think this is the
breakout tournament for we've seen
definitely uh we've seen obviously Rexi
I know Azir is is out there Victor is
one of the most represented decks as
well even Fiora I mean doesn't feel as
much it feels more like a body deck than
an order deck but it it has order set
too I know one of your favorite set is
is coming back I mean fight orflight
gone set emerges from the ashes of
fighter flight and is ready to uh to do
some sit-ups and and really uh crunch
this event.
>> Exactly. And he crunches the numbers and
that's exactly what we like to see. So I
I just said it. Aurelia is at the
tippity top there. Finally taking that
top spot from Draven in regards to
popularity of choice of deck. Draven's
still up there. Don't get me wrong. I
think, you know, originally people
anticipated it to drop, but I've always
seen it as still this really strong deck
and it's lost a lot of key pieces, but
that doesn't mean that it's still not
powerful and it's still keeping up.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean, we went from I
mean, the miracle deck is gone for sure.
Uh or unless you're an absolute
psychopath, but we could see it. Uh it's
gone for sure, but yes, like you said,
Draven's still a very good deck. You can
take a lot away, it can still be the
best deck. Uh, and it it is a very broad
deck and it's got a a nice matchup
versus almost anything. You've got game
against almost any deck, which is a good
place to be in an event where you need
to play eight rounds of Swiss. But yeah,
like we said, a lot of order decks up
there. And one that I see that has not
gotten a lot of talk, it's Master Yi.
People forgot about Master Yi from
Origins. They're like, "Oh yeah, that
that that card rotated out." No, it's
still there. It is the fifth most
represented deck in the event. And I
think quietly it we could see it sort of
rise to the top and then we're going to
be forced to talk about it again.
>> Definitely. Um in fact, you know, I was
at a skirmish not long ago, finals
Master Y mirror.
>> Yeah,
>> there you go. Like honestly, it's a much
better deck than people have counted it
out for recently. And I think there are
people who have been cooking with those
lists, staying at home, making sure that
they're keeping those tactics hush hush,
and then bringing them to an event like
this can really take it by storm.
>> Yeah. Well, we're going to let the
players cook a little bit more. We've
got a little bit more time for this
round to start, but we do have an
interview for you. So, we're going to
throw it over to Barcode. Take it away.
>> And look at that. I am with Ako, the
real one. Look at that. cosplay. That's
absolutely amazing.
>> Thank you so much. How are you doing,
me? I'm doing great. How about you?
>> I'm doing absolutely great. This is
absolutely awesome to have you there. I
mean, we met yesterday, but off camera,
we're not You want to talk about this
one?
>> Yeah.
>> Echo, how do you feel being here in the
venue with your cosplay?
>> Genuinely, it feels like an amazing
memory already cuz you're walking around
everywhere where you look, it's Riff
Bomb. And well, as a rip bomb player
myself and as an avid fan of League of
Legends, it's like a dream come true.
It's like a your own little League of
Legends card. Yeah, I can totally relate
with what you are currently saying. But
there is something funny about you.
You're actually cosplaying Ekko and
pretty well. I'm going to say that. But
who's your favorite character in League
of Legends?
>> Well, yeah. Everyone expects me to be an
Echo main. Well, my main looks quite
often as Echko. It's Nico.
That's literally surprising, but still.
Why exactly did you choose to cosplay
Ako?
>> Well, it is actually quite a funny
story. When I started cosplaying, I was
like, "Okay, um, I'm going to ComicCon.
Everybody is cosplaying, so I don't want
to be the odd one out." So, I was
checking like, "Which character do I
look like?" And a friend of mine was
like, "Eko. You have to cosplay Ekko."
So, I did my first Echo cosplay, which
was true damage Echo. And let's say that
hit off quite the situation with Ryan.
They were like you. And I'm like, "All
right." And since that moment, I just
kept on cosplaying Echo each event that
I went to. And uh well, that kind of
feels like I became Ekko that way. I
mean, yeah, I can just tell you that.
You got me. You got me. I saw that. I
was literally talking to Ekko yesterday.
You sound like him. You look like him.
And that's absolutely insane. What was
the most challenging part of uh
cosplaying Ekko? Is there something that
you had some difficulties with trying to
do the cosplay?
>> I think the most difficult part of
cosplaying Ekko is getting the cosplay.
>> Actually getting the cosplay is the most
difficult part. I am not that much of a
fabric crafter myself. So working with
fabric and foam is not my forte. I would
much rather work on like props, making a
zero drive and stuff, but making the
outfit itself. I'm screaming out. I'm
like, "Yo, somebody help me, please."
But if I will had the resources or a
person that could make every outfit, no
cosplay is the limit. They're
comfortable. It isn't that difficult.
And yeah, I just have to wake up like
this, so I'm fine.
>> That's absolutely insane. By the way, I
was wondering, do you cosplay some other
characters as well? Actually, I'm
planning to do another cosplay.
Which one is it? Currently on the list
high up Ashen Knight Pike. Wow. Pike
would look absolutely amazing. I can't
wait to see it and I'm sure that you're
going to be a great bike to be honest.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Well, thank you for being here with us.
Do you have any socials where we can
find you?
>> Yes, I have some socials. On Instagram
and Tik Tok, I am known as Shimiku. on
Twitch and YouTube. I'm known as Shimiku
Miku. That's is S H A M I K U. And
that's it for the Echo interview, guys.
Take it away.
>> Thank you so much.
Wow, thanks Barcode bringing us in with
the Echo. How incredible was that?
>> It was incredible. It's like, hey, I see
them in the game and then we see them
out there. It's like, wait, oh, right,
Ekko can like teleport and do time
travel. So, it all makes sense
thematically for sure.
>> Yeah, exactly that. You know, I can do
some time travel as well. I was in the
background of that video, didn't you
see?
>> Well, I saw you run out and then sprint
back over.
>> Yeah, and the outfit change in between.
Yeah, I mean it was very impressive. I'm
surprised that you got it done in time,
but we
>> This is the This is the magic of
regional qualifier Leil here as we are
>> eagerly awaiting the next round. I
cannot wait. Uh we have already seen
some like like I said amazing matches.
We saw Lux, we saw Rexi, we saw I mean
Lucian of course, Aurelia, which I have
a I have a feeling this isn't a spoiler
because I don't know obviously, but uh
we're going to see a bit more Aurelia
today if I had to guess. If I had to
take a slither of a guess, I would hope
so. But what deck you what other decks
are you looking forward to seeing today?
Have you got any favorites in mind
personally?
>> Yeah, I mean, obviously I mentioned uh I
mentioned Lucian, but one that we've
talked about a decent amount and we've
talked about some uh and we've seen
success in the past, but changed quite a
bit with this uh new bands uh obviously
is Ezreal, of course,
>> a few different ways to play it. Of
course, we had the Allen ZQ uh control
variant that we saw in obviously take
down Bolognia and do well in Vegas
changed drastically here with called
shot being gone. You have to change your
strategy. We saw a few events actually
already with the uh the bands and even
before the bands that were playing a
more tempo and aggressive version of
Ezreal, which was uh a really a
different take on Ezreal, but still
taking advantage of the fact that you
can play those two domains. you're still
able to play a lot of the most powerful
spells and be able to draw cards with
Ezreal as well.
>> Drawing cards is one of the most
powerful effects. We've said it before,
we'll say it again. And I really enjoy
the new tempo version of Ezreal that's
coming out of the woodworks here. I'm
not smart enough to play control. I I
get bored and I'm like, ah, yeah, I'm
just going to attack. Um, but I really
enjoy this tempo version because it does
give you that kind of
>> it gives you that advantage through
owning resources and through resource
management and I am good at that. So, I
do really enjoy it and I hope we get to
see some of our best players showing it
off today in good fashion.
>> Yeah, I mean any deck that can play
sneaky deckand is a deck for me. I
played it in Annie in Origins.
Unfortunately, Lucian can't play sneaky
deck hand, but I've got a few cards that
do a sneaky deckand impression. A little
bit more expensive. It's okay. Uh, so
I'm excited about that. I mean, another
one that I'm very excited to see is
Azir. Actually, it's another one of
those decks, but we're not going to talk
about Azir now. We've actually got
another interview. Let's see some more
barcode. Take it away.
It is going more or less an interview
but more information about one of the
key players of the tournament indeed.
I've got some good news for you as
enjoyers because yeah, Alan ZQ is of
course here in Leil and he's playing
pretty well considering the fact that he
won his last game 20. So for now the
Ezreal strategy is still in the
tournament and still going great going
well. Speaking about Ezreal, a lot of
players saw that maybe the deck was a
little bit worse than before, but it
looks like it is still performing very,
very well alongside the other decks. For
now, we don't have some words from Alan
DQ. But no worries because in a few
rounds we will probably hear from it
about the tournament, about the choice
of deck itself, and also about what he
thinks about Ezreal in this meta game. I
know that you want to have it on stream
and it might happen a little bit later.
Of course, Ezreal, you know that there
are two version now like the usual
version which is a control one and also
the tempo one. So, which one is Alan ZQ
playing? We'll find out a little bit
later, but for now, we're going to get
back to the desk. Guys, take it away.
There we have it. Maybe maybe a little
bit of foreshadowing there. Perhaps
we'll see Allen uh play at 2 and 0. So,
I mean, anything could happen. Of
course. Of course. Maybe one of those
was a buy, but we'll take it. Hey, we'll
take it. We'll take the wins where we
can get them in an eight round event
like this.
>> Not like you didn't earn it at your
local skim,
>> right?
>> You got to reap the rewards, right? And
>> a round one buy is a phenomenal start to
the tournament. You get a little bit
more rest. You can kind of get in the
zone. I know that round one of a
tournament for me is always um where I
make the most misplays. We're still
warming up. We're still getting into it.
And I I I come out of the game and I
think, "Oh my gosh, why did I do that?
Why did I do that?" And for a lot of
these players, just having that extra
time to decompress, walk around, get in
the zone, and not have to make those
misplays and not have the risk of losing
game one cuz it's disheartening. Losing
that first round could be really
disheartening. But there's also a never
give up scenario. I've seen a lot of
players lose round one and then just go
and win the rest.
>> Yeah, and we've seen it happen many,
well, maybe not many times before, but
we have seen it happen before where a
turn a player loses that very first
round. And so many players,
>> maybe myself included at other events,
say, "Ah, this one's I'm chalking this
one up, it's done. You lose the next
one, you go play side events. That's
fine." But having that determination and
will, that back against the wall
mentality of, hey, it's all about the
next round. What happened last round?
That's fine. Doesn't matter. I need to
win this round.
>> Yeah. Cont.
>> What's going to happen next round? Don't
care. Need to win this round. We win
that one. You get to the next round.
What am I do? What happened last round?
Don't remember. Going to win this one.
And you just keep on going, keep
building that up. And that is really uh
what separates truly top level players
from even just very good players. It's
like that mindset, playing the game at a
high level, that that's a given. It
needs to happen, especially in an event
like an RQ. But having that mental, that
mindset is what is really going to push
these players over the top.
>> Absolutely. And that's exactly what it's
all about. There are there are almost
three elements at play. There's top
level gameplay. There's your mental
health and your mental stability and
your endurance of getting through the
day. So, it's about mind, body, and
skill here. Absolutely. And you can
circumvent a little bit of that by going
to your, like you said, your local
skirmish. If you win a skirmish, hey,
you've got that free win. There's so
many times where it's like you played
that event, it's like, ah, I just won
the first round at Leo and they're like,
what are you talking about? Like, that
was a buy
>> that I I win.
>> Yeah, that's a win. And again, the the
converse of, you know, you lose your
first round, you're you're back against
the wall, you know, you're you're down
in the dumps. You get to come into the
event, you get to watch all of these
players that didn't win a skirmish, they
have to play. Uh there's nothing better
than walking around in round one knowing
that you already won because you won a
skirmish. You got that by. You just get
to walk around with the smug face and
like, oh look,
>> wouldn't wouldn't want to have to play
this round. Already got a win. Yes, I am
saying this to someone who did that in
Bolognia and have a buy. I have a buy
banked up for Utrect as well. So yes, I
am speaking from my my high horse right
now. Honestly, it's a good place to be
and like we say, it's not like they
didn't earn it. It's a very prestigious
honor to be able to come into a highle
event like this and just have one viewer
round to play and that's going to again
help with that endurance.
>> Yeah, when you need to go six and two to
make day two, making that and said, oh,
five and two, there's a big difference.
Every single win racks up and uh having
that one for free at the beginning is a
great place to be. Another great place
to be is with another video here. We're
gonna get to the round really quickly,
but we're going to throw to a video
right here. We'll see you in a few.
>> I'm with P with a French competitor in
the main event as well as a French
content creator. Pel, how are you doing?
Fine. And you?
>> I'm doing pretty well to be honest, I
mean, the crowd is absolutely amazing.
And speaking about the crowd, I mean,
this is a French event on the French
home, French territory. Does it feel
special for you? Uh it's pretty cool to
have a French event or event in France
particularly because um often American
game think like Europe is like one big
country. So you have to travel to a lot
of different places to play those kind
of big events but I know that Leil is a
particularly cherished city to host
events especially in the this place the
the Grand Pal. So, uh, it's not the
first time I've been here to play such
big events, but the first time for
Rebound. So, it's always a pleasure.
>> So, of course, yeah, for the people who
don't know you yet, you played a lot of
TCGs before, you've got a huge
background around the TCGs, but speaking
about Riftbound specifically, what is
different and what do you like about
Riftbound, especially about the venue
and about the game?
>> Uh, the game is really exciting to play.
Uh it takes a lot of um mechanics that
exist in different games with a twist,
particularly the rune and the champion
unit, the legend. It's a really good mix
to u to experience even if you played a
lot of different TCGs. I think I
experienced like all the other TCGs
before. So uh uh I I particularly enjoy
rebound for this. And the concerning the
this event, it's like really chill like
you can do uh side events, the main
events which is really competitive. Um
you can try to win uh metal cards. You
can try to win uh a metal card and the
event uh I'm not trying to do any of
those. I'm just trying to have fun this
weekend. So uh no pressure. And uh yeah,
>> I mean yeah, you were talking about
having fun and I think this is the most
important part about Reebound. Yeah, of
course you can compete at a higher
level, but you can also just enjoy
yourself, just chill. And to chill,
which deck did you choose? I choose to
play Victor. Uh I played Victor since
set one, but I often um thought like
maybe I should switch deck to experience
different game play. And uh the setu
came. Victor was still a pretty good
deck mid I think. Then the ban occurred
like few weeks ago. Victor became more
popular. So I was like why change? Just
keep playing the same deck and I hope it
will carry me for this tournament. I
mean it actually makes a lot of sense.
Victor is one of the best decks right
now and it might probably win the event.
Speaking about winning the event, you
said that you are not going to win it
even if we just wish it for you. But
which deck is going to win it all?
>> Uh I think Kaisa oria
is pretty
or the best deck actually. Draven are
still a good deck but uh they lost so
much cards. Uh they can't really compete
with Ireelia who lost who lost also some
cards but not that much. uh who benefits
from the from Draven going lower on the
field. So I think yeah Kaisa because it
can win like every uh weird matchup
because of the metal car chaser oria
because it it has a good um uh proactive
plan against lot of decks too.
>> I mean it makes a lot of sense actually.
Thanks a lot for your insight. That was
really cool having you here on stage.
And for you at home, don't go anywhere
because we're going to be back real
soon.
Oh, hi everyone. Welcome back. We're
here round number three, RQ Leil. I'm
still Blevens. That's still Amy. And we
are getting We are eagerly anticipating
this round three, which should be coming
up real soon.
>> Absolutely. And I can't wait to see who
we've got on broadcast. Can't wait to
see what decks they brought with them
and how it's all going to go down. But
in the meantime, let's have a little
chat about chosen champions. We heard
there about the differences between each
of them and what would go into a
player's mind.
>> Yeah.
>> When they're considering which one to
bring because there are kind of two ways
to be a winner, right?
>> We can either be going to win the whole
event.
>> Yeah.
>> Or we can be going for that prestigious
best of prizing.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. Well, when I'm when I
personally was looking into to playing
in Bolognia, for instance, I picked
Lucian. One, because I thought it was a
good deck. Two, so I didn't think that a
lot of other people thought it was a
good deck. So, I thought maybe if I can
be the best of Lucian, that's a that's a
good spot to be. I mean, I want I mean,
I want one of those metal cards for
sure. I've been I'm going to be going
for one in Utra. Going to be going for
one in every single one of the RQs that
I play. Um, and I think that it's a
really great way that you can play the
game. You don't have to. There's still
plenty of players that are like, I only
care about first place. I am going to do
as good as well as I can in this event.
I'm trying to win the event because I'm
the best player. That's a a noble place
to be as a rift bomb player. That's just
not me. I know I'm not the best player.
I'm not trying to be. Uh, but maybe I
can be the best of a smaller pool of
players that are playing a deck. And if
I can hone in and focus and and master
this one deck, not only do I get the the
benefit of being able to maybe find
different lines, different cards that
are good in this deck that other people
aren't ready for, but I have that sort
of I can just play this deck. This is my
deck. I am this guy's deck. I mean, I'm
not. I just I didn't win the I didn't
win the best of medal, but I am a guy
that plays Lucian and I enjoy it. And I
think that's a really great way to play
Riftbound. Honestly, it's one of those
that it can be incredibly advantageous
for you just to focus on one archetype
and taking that set to set and then
building upon that knowledge and having
that experience with the deck when you
move into a new format
>> that can bolster your chances of getting
those best off prizing. It's something
really fun to work towards that's not
just the beall and end all.
>> Yeah. Well, we heard it in that
interview there with PL said, "Yeah, I
was playing Victor in set one. I played
it a bit in set two and I was thinking
about changing and the bands happen.
It's like, oh well, why would I change?
And we'll see those players, especially
an event like this. Like the bands, yes,
they happened a few weeks ago. It has
not really been that long of a time.
This is the first really big event with
this
>> card pool really. So, if you come in and
have had the experience of playing
Victor for that long, you're going to
have a big advantage against other
players. And again,
>> if you are just playing for your best of
battle cards, you don't need to win the
tournament. You just need to win the
little mini tournament of all the other
players in the event as well.
>> But if you do win the event overall,
then you also get best of course.
>> That is also true. It's it's it's the
rich get richer. Yes. If you win the
event, you also get the best of metal
card, which is uh which is really
amazing there. So
>> that's spectacular.
>> I mean, we're going to see that
happening for sure. But Amy, what deck
if if you were playing in this event,
what deck would you have wanted to
bring?
>> Set.
>> Set for sure.
>> Yeah. I'm a one trick pony. What can I
say? uh one one trick Stella corn
herder. It's not in the deck, but uh
honestly I really love the deck and I
really I think if I was going for a best
of cuz I know I'm not the best player in
the room. I know I'm not going to be
able to win the tournament. So I would
100% go with the deck that I know the
most about that I've played since day
one and that I'm relatively confident
that I can have a decent win percentage
into at least 50% of the meta. I think
that would put me in a good position to
be going for best offset. And that is
also the metal card that I would want.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Well, we've got some
very interesting graphics here. We've
got card usage here. So, this is the
percentage of decks that are using these
cards. We've got Rebuke all the way at
41%. So, almost half of the decks in the
room are playing Rebuke. You look at
Hard Bargain, Brin here, there,
Knoxville. I mean, we're seeing we're
seeing mid-range Draven in the uh in the
top here. Ferris Sportrunner, of course,
in the top there. Ride the wind as well.
I mean, this is uh really not not too
surprising. Amy,
>> seeing uh which colors are present in
these colors is also unsurprising. And
of course, in calm, we see that it's all
of those spells that help us to prevent
our opponent from gaining advantage.
>> Yeah. And we saw we've seen the the the
talk of the meta being you either need
to be playing Ferris 4Runner or you need
to be playing Rebuke. And it looks like
players have pretty much come to that
same consensus. You need to be playing
Ferris for you, you need to be playing
Rebuke. Ferris forunner of course is
essentially pound-for-pound energy for
energy, whatever you want to call it,
the most amount of might that you can
get in a you can jam into a single card
because it's not just the six might on
the front end. It's the two three might
units on the back end that are are
really the most scary. And if you're not
running rebuke to bounce it back to
hand, there's really not a lot of great
ways to efficiently remove the 4Runner.
>> No, you've got to either be running a
very viciously aggressive deck so that
you can just backto back take them down.
Alternatively, of course, we've got
these Aurelia builds now that are
running more charm, so there's potential
with that where you drag them forward
and take them out. So there are a lot
more decks that are kind of planning for
Ferris Sportrunner, but it is the most
efficient big body unit that we've got
for bang for buck. Realistically, it is
our best value for money.
>> Mhm. Yeah, there's really not much more
you can ask for out of a card. I mean,
honestly, it's uh it's so strong and it
creates these just really awkward points
for your opponent if you're playing an
order deck. You know, you've got this
call the weak, you're able to take out
these big units. You go call the week
and you go, "Oh, wait. I actually have
not changed the amount of might on my
opponent's side of the board. That's not
a really a great place when you've spent
a card and paid a power to do that and
maybe even sacrifice one of your own
units as well. That's just not
>> it's not an efficient use of your time.
>> It's not a winning proposition. So, like
you said, you need to be having one of
these hyperaggressive decks where it's
like, okay, I can kill the 4erunner one
time and that's going to get me ahead.
You move the units back, I'll kill it a
second time. Maybe it's a hidden blade,
maybe it's something else. It's
inefficient, but uh efficiency doesn't
matter when I get to loads of guys.
Yeah. When I've got loads of guys or
when I get to write that W on the match.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> It's one of those where actually if as
long as you're ready for it, you're
okay. And with those statistics, we see
that you have to be ready and someone
else who's ready on the floor for us is
barcode.
>> And yeah, I am as the players are
getting ready right behind us. I am with
Adibu who is a famous French host. How
are you doing today?
>> First of all, peron my French and I'm
really fine. I'm so happy to be here
with the all the crew cast from OTP. I'm
from France. So,
and Kachus my man. H it's a pleasure to
be here. It's incredible. So many
people, so many production value. I
mean, I'm so happy to be here and see
the real bar for real. You're real. You
exist, man.
>> Am I real? Am I real? No. That's so nice
to have you with your smile. You smiling
is absolutely incredible and you being
here is a chance for us as well. But for
now, the players are getting ready. So,
why don't we just go over the game?
>> All right, we are back and I think Amy,
we saw the players in the background
there of Barcode getting ready to play.
I'm so excited. I'm I'm like I'm shaking
with anticipation for this match. We've
been quietly, very quietly and
peacefully waiting for this match to
start. And it looks like we are jumping
in here as the players are shuffling up.
Very excited to see what who we've got.
>> Do has anyone in chat recognized either
of these players? Have you played
against them at Locals? Who are you
rooting for? We don't know what decks
they're playing quite yet, but they're
just setting up and getting ready. So,
we'll have our feature match ever so
soon.
>> Yes. when it's like it's like when you
it's like when you hear the the keys
jingling. My my mouth starts drooling. I
know we're going for a walk here, but
this walk is going to be round three. It
looks like we've got
>> the two decks we talked about versus
Ezreal.
>> H
>> we didn't plan that. I'm just going to
put it out there. This was not a bit.
That was pure beautiful unbridled chance
of opportunity to see these two in
action.
>> Yeah, I know almost everything I do is a
bit. This is actually one of the times
that it's not a bit. Uh, but we get to
see Azir versus Ezreal. So, we're going
to be seeing the order deck here in
Azir. And we're actually going to be
taking a look at the deck here. Very
standard looking version right now. Lot
of equipment, lot of gill spells, and of
course those three Arise.
>> Yeah, that's exactly what we want to be
seeing. Lots of Arise, Desert Cool,
Guardian Angel, Charm, Defy. Lots of
ways to not only create a lot of your
own units, but then push and pull others
around from the opposing side. It's
almost like a control deck, but it's got
enough aggression to pull through early
game and overwhelm with units.
>> Yeah, it's like the Victor control decks
that we've seen where you're playing a
lot of uh destroy spells. You're playing
a lot of different uh manipulation of
might with discipline and and pump
spells there, but you're able to unlike
Victor who gets to make a one might
recruit. You're making a two might sand
soldier that, oh, by the way, is also
getting equipped with an equipment. So,
very threatening unit. And like we saw
in the Aurelia deck from the round one,
we're seeing more and more charms main
deck. The meta is shifting even in the
main deck to accommodate the the new
metag game that we're playing in. and we
were just talking about it how important
it is to respect those larger units.
Speaking of larger units, decks that
absolutely thrive on using them late
game. Here we are with Ezreal. Of
course, we've got the Mind Splitters and
Thousand Tail Watchers for late game.
But early game, we're using those cheap
and efficient Raven Blue Students and
Plundering Porro to be able to build our
board. And we're using so many cards to
draw more cards and effects to draw more
cards so that we are creating a
beautiful unbreakable late game board
state.
>> Absolutely. And that does look I mean at
the start there looks a lot more like
the control deck akin to what Alen was
running in Bolognia, but obviously a lot
of a lot of differences there. We're
actually playing some two drops. We're
playing the card sharps there. So we're
playing more of those units. Of course,
we don't have access to our entire deck
via shot and Ezreal there, but still a
very controlling deck. So, we're going
to be seeing almost two control decks,
and we'll see how they can adapt to each
other here as we jump on in. Game number
one, round three, RQ Leil,
>> jumping straight in. Let's see how many
sand soldiers we can count. I feel like
we need a sand soldier counter. Just
like a grain of sand at the bottom of
the screen for each sand soldier.
>> All right, let's let's get that made.
Grain of sand counter incoming here
for specifically the Azir matchup and
nothing else yet.
>> We need to think of other other little
counters and fun things that we can have
for each one otherwise. But here we are.
The first stack deck. We will have to
see it from Ezreal bringing forward more
options being able to build that hand.
Oh, that's a tricky one cuz we have the
mind spplitter which we want. We don't
want it at the bottom of the deck, but
equally it's not useful right now. It's
far too big.
>> Yep.
>> It is. It is definitely one of the It's
It's the hard
>> the hard choice there. Are you playing
for the long late game? Are you playing
for now? We are.
>> We're playing the long game and and I
respect it. It's a horrible card to have
to go to the bottom because it is one of
those driving forces to just score those
last few points and stay in the lead.
Plundering Porro goes down and then
we're back onto uh Rocklo's turn to see
if we can actually pull through and pop
some units in play this turn.
>> Yeah, and a couple couple interesting
things here. So, Rocklo actually was a
best of Azir winner from a previous
event. So, very very high skilled player
here on Azir. Uh, one other thing to
note though from the last turn, turn
one, a lot of times what you want to do
as Azir, play a oneost equipment, make a
sand soldier on that turn one. They
missed it of course there. So, they're
already a little bit on the back foot.
>> Yeah, pacingwise, you need to be just
keeping that up. We played a little game
of Azir yesterday, didn't we? And it was
exactly that. As soon as you get that
early game lead, you want those units in
play. And unfortunately for Rocklow, um,
Ezreal does that really well as well,
especially in this build, in these newer
builds where we are running those two
drops and we are able to cipher through
our deck using stack deck quite so
efficiently. Again, going for another
one right now, two this early in the
game really does set you apart. Looks
like is it what? Stupify and Bellow's
breath.
>> Yep, two bellow's breath and a stupify
saying I will take the stupify here. get
that get those break points made and
draw a card for the trouble.
>> The sad part is those two bellows breath
are at the bottom of the deck. And
although Ezreal draws a lot of cards, I
don't think it's going to draw that many
cards.
>> No, we're we're not really I mean it can
if the game goes late get to that second
cycle of the deck, but it is not the
norm like it was in the previous decks
with with of course the uh called shots
there. Uh we are seeing the setup here.
We've got a lot of late game in on the
side of Ezreal here. There's a thousand
tailed watcher. Of course, we saw the
mind spplitter as well taken. So, it's
going to be, hey, can we get some points
here with this poro? Can we get a few
gold gear tokens? And where are we going
to end up? How aggressive is this year
going to be able to be?
>> And that's exactly what it's about here.
We're trying to get
units on the board. They don't need to
be tough initially, but we're going to
make them tough cuz we're going to give
them so much gear. And then we're going
to use pump spells and removal to be
able to just push ourselves in to the
aggressive point. But right now, we're
just looking low on those soldiers, and
that's not going to be particularly
helpful going forward. Now, luckily, uh,
Rentoy wasn't able to get another unit
down. So, while Porro is the only
standing fella,
>> yeah, and it looks like Azir's going to
be able to go in. They have a one might
advantage here, of course, with that
equipment, but we did see the stupify.
So, it's going to be a matter of what is
Ezreal going to be willing to commit
here and then what is the followup? We
do see a defy in the hand of Azir. Not
sure if they're going to want to do that
here. It does effectively stop them from
drawing a card. Looks like we're just
going to use a discipline instead.
>> Makes sense. Again, you're trying like
both of these decks have resources that
they are trying to use sparingly and
unless it is gaining you the full
advantage of using that card. It can be
really damning to use it early on, but
at this point, drawing cards is
>> the most powerful thing that we can be
doing as Ezreal to build that hand to
give us the options for later. Stack
deck number three of the game.
>> Yep, we get three stack decks here. So,
really going to be able to set up almost
exactly what they want in their hand,
which is a scary part. It's a scary
place to be in as the opponent because,
you know, you're trying to get a read on
what could possibly be in their hand.
You're trying to get an idea of what the
range of cards they could have is. And
uh well, when there's three stack decks
that have been played, it's it's quite a
wide range of cards that it could be
>> massively. And that's the thing. We've
now built this almost cherrypicked hand
and you've got to be almost a worrisome
Azir at this point when you're facing up
against a deck which is at this point
very well known for being able to have
those control style elements and there
are plenty of them in hand. So although
we only have Lone Porro in this combat
who is going to go down, we've got a lot
more where that came from.
>> Yeah. Yes, Ezreal has been able to
sculpt their hand for the late game. But
of course, Azir is going to be trying to
in this matchup say, "Hey, uh, we need
to expediate this game. We need to make
this game go as quick as possible
because the later the game goes, once
those mind sweaters start to come down,
once those thousand nail watchers start
to come down, it really starts to get a
lot harder for Azir.
>> Got sacred shears now in play. Okay,
we've got a death now draw one which we
know that's a powerful effect and of
course then it's just going to keep
going cuz it gets to put that on the
unit and we can keep equipping and it
also gets the plus one might.
>> Yeah, it's a it's one of those cards
that seems like it's not that strong but
you're able to keep your hand filled but
well one way to not keep your hand
filled that is a mindspplitter coming
down. That feels like an early mind
splitter, but we have just been ramping
those runes and getting to that point
quite quickly thankfully and those stack
decks certainly did help. We're really
only in what I would consider the early
game and we've managed a mind splitter.
phenomenal play and we've assessed how
crucial hand knowledge can be here and
in a matchup like this where both have
these spells like hm let me think defy
that's right there being able to know
that the potential of defy is there
especially with its cheap cost
>> you've just got to be aware that they're
around
>> yeah it creates the that interesting
scenario where you know you know that I
know that you know that I know that
there's by there. So, when I play
something that can be defied, are you
supposed to defy it or not? That's the
that's the interesting question that
comes into play to do that.
>> It's too obvious. Um, but that is the
the beauty of cards like that. Of
course, the arise taken from that mind
spplitter, one of the I mean, in our
match, the arise was what was really a a
turning point in that game. And it can
certainly be a turning point. one of the
I mean literally the signature spell of
Azir and a signature uh game changer for
sure.
>> Yeah, it's not too difficult to remove
sand soldiers. It is much more difficult
to remove lots of gear that you can
plunk sand soldiers into. So, it can
make a huge turning point. Back over uh
to Renektoy's turn, we've got a single
mind spplitter. Much energy, plenty.
We've got lots of great cards, but I'm
looking. Yeah, we've got some
singularity being considered. We've also
got fantastic cards like Fizz, which can
bring lots back whenever we need it. And
having played those early cards like
Stupify, although, you know, we didn't
use it to its natural full effect, we
can just jump back and grab them when
needed, which just feels great. Such a
fantastic card that, you know, we still
have access to.
>> Yeah. And this is uh we talked about
this Ezreal control deck being a a
complex deck. There's a lot of
decisions. I mean, if you look at if you
look at Ezreal's hand right now, there's
>> probably about 50 different iterations
of how this turn could go and there's
probably about three of them that are
correct. So, it's not just, oh well,
just play this card, play your cards,
pass the turn. There's so much that goes
into it. Are you going to play the
singularity? Yes, it seems. We're going
to wipe the board. That's a pretty
decent way to go. If you if all else
fails, clear the board. I think you're
going to be in a pretty good spot.
>> Oh, but we're saying absolutely not
today. Not today. And of course, Ezreal
is going to go ahead and draw a card off
the effect. Still having targeted those
sand soldiers. We're still able to draw
a card.
>> Brilliant use of singularity because we
still get an effect. And although,
hey, there we go. We're going to stupify
and we're going to keep drawing cards.
see if we can get ourselves out of this
situation. Adding to the stack, adding
to the effects,
>> and the sand soldiers go down.
>> Yeah, as we as we saw it there,
singularity doing six to a five might
unit. The discipline brings it up to a
seven might unit. The stupify brings it
back down to six. So, even as the dust
dust settles, all of those sand soldiers
are gone. And I mean, that's it seems
like it's it's quite a a nice win for
Ezreal there. But also, those weren't
real units. Those were free value units
made just from playing equipment. So you
almost feel bad clearing the board
there.
>> I don't know. They did manage to get rid
of the Arise. So honestly, it feels
quite safe.
>> Still still very good. It's just, you
know, I spent all these real cards to
There's something about that that that
irks me in a way. I never want to do it
even though I have to.
>> I think I think they used it on the
perfect turn. I think that was a really
full value turn when we're talking about
um use of resources. Rentoy did have to
use a lot of resources to make it happen
to get rid of, like you say, essentially
free units, but those free units can't
necessarily come back. Now, we know that
we've taken that arise away. So,
Rocklo's going to have to be a little
bit more tricky and do this the manual
way by using cards, spending more of
their own energy, and using Desert's
Call to bring two of those back is a
great start. Yeah, Desert's Call as a a
mini Arise is quite good. And then, you
know, we're playing a another equipment
there to get another sand soldier. And
all of a sudden,
>> that whole clear Yeah, that whole uh
board clear is uh has been rewound.
>> It's kind of like Renick Toy just
knocked down the sand sand castle and
Rocklo went, "It's okay. I've got a I've
got a perfect shake bucket right here."
And bish, there we go. We're done.
>> Here's second sand castle ready to go.
>> Oh dear. So we've got the troops are
very much back. All got their equipment.
So they're a lot bigger than they seem.
And now Rento back on this kind of same
pinnacle they were on before. We've got
the mine spplitter. We got the whole
point. But if you look at how things are
looking board statewise. Rocklo is
seeming very calm. That's because
they've got this really strong board
state which is going to last. Renick Toy
now has the really difficult position of
having to continue to build up a board
to be able to close out this game. Three
points aside, we're not out of the woods
yet.
>> Yeah, both players at three. And again,
we we've talked about in the previous
rounds, it's not about getting to a
certain point. It's about getting to
those even point thresholds. So yeah,
>> they're both tied in points right now,
but it looks like Rocklo is likely going
to be the first player to get to that
fourth point, which means they're ahead
on point tempo, which means it's going
to be on Ezreal. It's the ball's going
to be in Ezreal's court to somehow
disrupt that or else the game is going
to end.
>> Exactly that. It's all about that tempo.
This is strategically refound is much
more about the mathematics of when you
score those points than a lot of people
first assume. And you're right, we need
to get to those even numbers and getting
to those high even numbers like four and
six are the really big swing points of
the game. If you can't get to six before
you've swung the game in your favor, it
is not looking good, my friend.
>> Absolutely. And this is a scenario that
is is marketkedly different from the
pre-ban scenario for Azir specifically.
The scenario like this, you can have all
of these equipment. You can equip one
unit with a bunch of equipment and take
out something like a mindspplitter. In
the previous meta with fight or flight,
that really was almost a hard counter to
that because it would be stranding those
equipment on an exhausted unit. Now,
there's not really great ways to deal
with a unit with a bunch of equipment on
it and strand the equipment. You can use
rebuke to get rid of it. You can you can
destroy the unit, but all of those
equipment are then going to be freed up
to go on another and cascade those
equipment with another unit. So, Azir in
this specific scenario is actually in a
better spot than they would have been in
a pre-banned world.
>> Absolutely much, much better. And we see
why Azir has had that uptick. But as we
were talking, Rocklo goes ahead and
scores that fourth point, putting them
much in the lead to head towards a
victory. If they can keep this board
state up and just consistently gain
those points here on out, they're taking
this win easy peasy.
>> Yeah, this is now the point of the game.
We're ahead on tempo. Yes, your
opponent, if if all things go as
Riftbound would would say they are,
you're going to score you can score two
points this turn. That is a fair and
balanced Riftbound, right? We're not
we're not playing Lucian. We don't have
a lot of these point skippers. We're not
we're not scoring two points or three
points a turn. We're not scoring three
points a turn. Two points a conquer
rather. So the way that you need to
break that tempo is by holding. So at
some point there is going to be a hold
by Ezreal or stopping the Azir from
scoring those even point thresholds. But
it doesn't need to be right now. Azir
can pass the turn. They don't even
necessarily need to score this fifth
point. It's going to end up being
roughly the same as being at four if
you're able to conquer those two on the
next turn.
>> So very true. And I got to say, I'm
going to point it out. Rocklo got best
of Azir in a previous event.
>> Yes,
>> that was pre-banned.
>> That was in fact pre-banned. So
>> this deck is now in a more advantageous
spot than it has ever been. and having
those reps, having that experience,
clocking us up to five points in this
game. Still climbing with those sand
soldiers is pushing Rockllo into a
phenomenal position for, in my opinion,
this entire tournament. We're on round
three here for our regional qualifier in
Le. And I got to say, I think that Azir
is looking like one of my kind of
favorites for the turning point of that
ban list.
>> Absolutely. Definitely seems like Azir
has been put into a very advantageous
spot here. Looks like we are going to go
for both of these battlefields here.
We've got of course four might on one,
five on another thanks to our amazing
might graphics at the bottom of the
screen. I was about to do math. I don't
need to. It is shown on the screen for
me. But we get to see that here that we
do have
>> here's the thing. We've got what would
be considered good attacks into these
battlefields. But there's so much
energy. There's so many readied runes on
the side of Rockla. Like how can you
make these attacks? I don't know. I you
have to be very meticulous is is one
thing for sure.
>> You've absolutely got to we've got to
remember the effects of the battlefields
themselves as well. Void gate will be
giving spells and abilities bonus damage
while war camp is actually giving extra
might to these units. So on both sides
these can be utilized for very dynamic
showdowns.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
War camp of course very good for Azir
because the more units you have the more
effective might you get from that
battlefield. And of course, Ezreal
playing a lot of direct damage spells
wants to get that extra damage from the
void gate here. And now again, there's a
lot of cards in Ezreal's hand. You may
think, "Oh, that's a that's a good thing
for Ezreal." And it is, but it's does
not make the decision of how to play
this turn any easier.
>> No, not at all. Especially with that
Azir in the backline kind of staring us
down, being able to move uh those sand
soldiers into a battlefield with it
again, making that war camp even
stronger. So, can get can get pretty
tricky. So, uh Rentoy's got a lot to
think about cuz there's a lot of energy
standing on the other side of the board
ready to rumble.
>> Yeah, and this is another scenario. Ooh,
Bellow's breath.
>> Looks like Bellow's breath repeated. So,
it's going to do
damage there, of course, on the void
gate and then damage in the backline
here. Of course, going to be an extra
damage on that void gate.
So, we are
>> now it's how we follow this up to finish
off some of these units. see if we can
clear the board a little bit more to
allow our units to kind of run a bit
free considering if we want to stop that
in its tracks, which I could kind of
tell might have been coming by the fact
they didn't want removed from the board
straight away.
>> Yeah, Defy comes out. Yeah, there
there's some sort of shenanigans going
on with Bellow's Breath for sure. So,
you want to avoid that if possible.
Let's just defy the Bellow's breath.
>> That is a no thanks, sir. and cheap and
cheerful to boot. So, still got plenty
of energy for any particular shenanigans
that may still occur. Now, Rentoy
definitely has the advantage when it
comes to pure might on units, but
Rockllo has a lot of guys and they have
equipment to boot and that's really
what's pushing up the numbers that's
making it a lot more difficult for a
Rentoy to be able to confidently move
some units into a battlefield.
>> Absolutely. And again, we're trying to
figure out what is the best way to
sequence these cards. I think we were
trying to go for a Bellow's Breath
Watcher play before, of course, that got
thwarted, but maybe not because now
we've got a Fizz that can bring back the
Bell's Breath if you would like to.
Looks like they may be doing just that.
Looks like it. Fizz has shown why it's a
fundamental card in Ezreal where
Bellow's brething again. Seeing if we're
going to let that go through or whether
Rocklo's got another trick up their
sleeve to prevent some of that. So there
we go. Just popping that to the bottom
allowing that damage to float on those
soldiers and Azia for now.
>> And let's see how we combo this up.
Again, we've got to try and deal with
some of these units. Equipment on its
own, not so scary. It can't do anything.
It can't score us some points. But the
moment you got a sand soldier holding
it, no, that's a bit of a problem.
>> Yeah, once you start getting those
bodies with all that equipment again, it
really stacks up. You can cascade
equipment into a large battlefield if
you need to. There's not a really the
threat of it getting stranded anymore.
So, it gets really, really strong. And
of course, you know, all of this has
been happening. There's still that
hidden card over on the Trafarian War
Camp, which is really again throwing a
wrench into all these plans cuz there's
just so many things to have to consider
here. There there's no shot I would be
able to play an Ezreal control deck in
an event like this. My brain is already
fried casting this event in round three,
let alone having to play it.
>> And it's such a tricky matchup as well.
Oh, okie cookie. Here we go. Targeting
down that Azia,
noting that that is kind of a bigger
threat. So smoke screen jumps into play
reducing that down once again.
>> Yep, the smoke screen smoke screen will
reduce Rir by four to a minimum of one,
but which is fine. Can stay a one
because it's already got that one damage
on it from the bell's breath. There is
another defy. Love the patience from
Rocklo.
>> Had the defy for the bellow's breath
before. Countered the first one said,
"Okay, the second one goes off.
feigning the fact that they didn't have
another divide. Such a high level play.
>> So good. Really goes to show why they
could achieve best of Azir in the first
place. And now we might be seeing just
why that is and the things that you have
to be careful of. That was such a
fantastic kind of double bluff there,
making sure that your opponent kind of
makes those suboptimal plays. And the
thing is with Ezreal is that you need to
be using your resources well. You need
them to have full effect. And at the
moment, Rocklo keeps just saying, "Nah,
I'm not going to let that happen." We
got to stupify. Bringing that sander
down a little bit. And Rocklo's
floating. Yes. Oh,
>> there we go. We're going to be able to
transfer that might over to the other
sand soldier here and draw a card. That
is a really great exchange there. of
course, keeping the cards flowing on the
side of Rockow, potentially even taking
down this Raven Bloom student who's
going to be really great. And even if
all things went downhill for the Stand
Soldier, if it dies this turn, you're
still drawing a card because of this the
shears.
>> Absolutely spectacular being able to
know the correct timing for the pacing
of this game to when to let a unit
perish. knowing that you still got units
on board, you've got this equipment, you
can re-equip it or you can just put new
sand soldiers straight into those kind
of huffs.
>> Mhm.
>> Absolutely spectacular play. Using that
energy so calmly, so collectively. You
really can't tell kind of what he's
thinking. Brilliant body language. Not
giving anything away to your opponent at
all. Not giving them an inch.
>> Yeah. And after all of that happens, all
of those spells played, all that
sequencing, an Azir holds up to six
points, we're just going to at the end
of all that. Hey, you did your work. Uh,
by the way, here's a hidden blade. I'm
going to target my own unit just to draw
three cards here. Let's refill. Let's
refill the board and then threaten to
win next turn.
>> I think that's exactly a fantastic play.
Don't be afraid of playing your cards on
yourself. Hidden Blade allowing us to
grab those extra cards could be the
difference between winning next turn and
not winning next turn. Uh so we go
ahead. We're going to score that seventh
point now because we can. Going to go
ahead in there. I the Herald comes down.
>> Going ahead and bringing another sand
soldier
>> straight into play. Gets that nice equip
from weapons master. Oh
>> the arise.
>> That's why you draw a bunch of cards.
get that arise again. Yeah, Mindsplitter
took that Arise what felt like 300 turns
ago.
>> It did, but it wasn't enough. We've
jumped into another Arise, bringing sand
soldiers galore into play, filling the
husks of those uh equipment with sand
soldiers. And now we've overwhelmed the
board.
>> Oh, and I really like this too. You get
to play two of the sand soldiers ready.
And you can play them anywhere. They
don't have to be in base. If you if you
control a battlefield, you can play them
there. We saw one of the readyied sand
soldiers get played to the battlefield,
equipped the eye of the herald, then
moved it back because guess what? When
you move with Eye of the Herald, you get
another recruit. So, even more tokens.
>> Why not,
>> right?
>> Why not have more? That's only going to
better our chances of winning next turn.
We only need one more point. We just
need to take these battlefields and we
have a lot of recruits to do so.
scooping it up and Rocklo takes game one
of this round three of the regional
qualifier.
>> Yeah, that was a game of resource
management I think. I mean, we saw
Ezreal have so many cards in hand, so
much card draw. They got some really
quite favorable exchanges and then just
cool, calm, and collected on the side
side of Azir saying, "I have these. I
have a limited amount of resources, but
I know exactly when I need to play
them." them and we saw that I mean that
defy turn if you are looking at how to
spend your cards how to feain weakness
and take advantage of it rewatch that
turn cuz that was amazing
>> honestly chef's kiss could not have done
it better myself cuz I literally
>> I would not have done it better myself I
again I I know that it can be common
place to be like well I don't want you
to do that again no I'm going to use my
cards but actually knowing that it's
more efficient in that moment to hold
back.
That is resource management at its
finest. Knowing that that bellow's
breath alone isn't doing enough to be
worthwhile. There's got to be a there's
got to be a follow-up. And the followup
is the thing that's more important for
me to counter,
>> right? You spend all this time asking if
you can, but you need to be asking uh uh
uh should I be countering that spell
here? As we take a look at the
sideboards, we see a a fan favorite
here, Vex. not not unleashed Vex which
we of course did get to play a little
bit of as well but we do see the OG from
Spirit Forge here Vex cheerless there's
no cheer in that Yortle but it is a very
very strong card especially in a matchup
like this where so many of those
exchanges were done in combat and over a
specific combat on a specific turn can
really turn that around. Yeah, indeed.
And some of these larger units as well.
Although Rocklo might have numbers,
sometimes you can overwhelm just with
some really chunky guys like Dr. Mundo
who can really swing the swing the
trade. If you stack up a battlefield and
say, "I don't think you've got
>> I don't think you got the numbers to
deal with this." Or if you do, you're
going to be spending a lot of resources
to do so. And that's what this is all
about. This matchup in particular is so
resource dependent, resourceheavy, and
knowing when to expend those
is crucial. That's the difference
between winning and losing. This matchup
can go either way,
>> but it's the players that make that
difference.
>> Absolutely. And you bring up Dr. Mundo
in the sideboard is a very nice card
against these equipment focused decks
because a lot of times what you want to
do is an equipment focused deck. You
want to have a lot of units. You've got
a few equipment. You can what we call
cascade the equipment. So you're getting
double value out of the equipment. You
send in a unit with a bunch of
equipment. You trade off with some of
their giant battlefield units and then
you put all those equipment on another
one and then take the the battlefield.
Does not quite work against a massive
might Dr. Mundo because uh you don't get
the double value against Mundo. Mundo
goes where he pleases, which is stay
right here on this battlefield.
>> Exactly. So maybe that will have been a
consideration as well as a way to combat
the overwhelming
nature of Azir. Now going first,
Renektoy jumps in with a stack deck.
We're going early again. I don't know
how they do it. These these Ezreal
players when I play Ezreal, I'll never
see that stack deck ever. It's at the
bottom for me. I don't know what goes
on, but no matter what I do, no matter
how well I shuffle, they're at the
bottom.
>> Mhm. I also love that I can tell from
the foiling that that is the Nexus
Knight promo. Those are the the ones
that I like to use as well. Stack deck
from the Nex Knight promos here. But
again, we're seeing Ezreal being able to
set up for the Midame here. We've got
Raven Bloom Student, of course, a very
very strong two drop that uh we see here
and and really is deceptively powerful
cuz if a Raven Bloom student attacks
into you, you really don't know how big
it's going to possibly be.
>> No. And that's that's the fearful part.
And it's such a cheap unit to start the
game with. Actually, this is a a much
better start almost than last game for
Renick Toy. So, we're able to take
advantage. And that's what we really
need to do with this Ezreal build. Now,
we saw that Azir just got going after a
few turns, but there were slower turns
in the beginning. But if you allow
Rocklo to start the momento, then it the
momentum then it just kind of flows into
disaster so quickly. If you can find a
way to push the lead early with Ezreal,
that's really what we need to do. And we
need to keep pace. But at this stage,
we've already got two sand soldiers in
place, so this student's going to have
to work hard.
>> Absolutely. And we saw a really, it was
actually a weirdly interesting decision
that does not happen in a lot of games,
but with these two battlefields
specifically, we've got Vile Lair, which
means if you move in there, you're not
moving back to a base. The other is
Sigil of the Storm, which means if you
conquer there, you have to channel a
rune or you have not channel a rune, you
need to recycle a rune, uh, which is not
great. So, actually a very interesting
decision here from Rocklo to go into the
viol saying, "Hey, this sand soldier,
you're going to stay here, buddy." But
more importantly, it is going to dictate
where this Raven Bloom student is going
to end up.
>> And honestly, both of these battlefields
are trying to make it difficult for your
opponent
>> while it's not so bad for yourself. Y
>> and so it's going to be an interesting
>> kind of battle to see exactly who goes
where and when. We're going ahead and
challenging this first Sun Soldier. I
think it's the right move. You've got to
try and keep pace. You've got to try and
score the points to keep up. If you
don't keep up, we've seen what happens.
>> Mhm. We see yet another stack deck here
really just to give the Raven Bloom
student plus one might to get over the
sand soldier which got the discipline. I
think Rocklo was more than happy to
accept that trade if it were to happen.
Of course, did not in this case. Raven
Bloom student is able to take over that
first point, but like we said, Raven
Bloom student is now stranded in Vile
Mosair.
>> Yeah, she's going to have to do her
studies from there because you're not
moving anywhere anytime soon. But with a
unit that can gain extra power, might
like we are looking at kind of it being
okay that they're there. A stand soldier
is going to need some equipment to even
start to deal with it. And speaking of,
here's a BF sword.
>> Mhm. BF sword's going to come down. We
now have a five mightite sand soldier.
And it looks like we are going for the
attack here. Saying, "Hey, we need to
get that Raven Boom Student out of
here." And if we do, we're in a really
good spot.
>> Yeah. Again, taking that lead, pushing
forward. Student can't stick around for
too long. If you know, Rentoid doesn't
have any other units in play currently.
Looks like we're going to consider a
Wages of Pain. Yeah, Waitane would offer
a trade here, which again I think Rockow
is more than happy to accept.
>> Yeah, I think you've got to I think
you've got to you've got to try for it,
right? You've got to try and make sure
that you're pushing the sand down as
quickly as you can. You've got to manage
units while also staying equal minimum
on the points race. And so both players
are going to be attempting to keep these
units in play or accept a trade. But
then you're on equal footing still.
>> Yep. But we see another discipline here.
So we're going to go from five up to
seven. Three damage on it. Three from
the Raven Bloom is going to be six
damage. Not enough to take it down. And
that is a big swing here for Rocklo.
>> Huge. Managing to keep that momentum,
keep pace, and take the lead. Being able
to have two sand soldiers in play to
Rentoy's
zero current units. Huge. But it looks
like a big play is on the way. We've
spent the gold token. We're going in.
>> And here it is. Singularity.
>> Yeah, Singularity will clear the board.
But again, it just it just doesn't feel
as good as if you killed real units. Two
sand soldiers we took out. And there's
still a BF sword.
>> Just a bit of sand. And the BF sword's
just there ready for another one to take
of it. So it doesn't feel great, but
you've got to because you don't have a
choice. You have to keep pace. We're
going for another stack deck. And it's
all about that resource management.
We've got Fizz. We've got cards in our
deck that can recycle these amazing
spells from our trash. So, actually
having them there isn't too much of a
bad thing. And we had the gold to kind
of eat up one of the recycle costs
there. So, it didn't feel as expensive.
>> Yep. And we see the shears come down.
That's another equipment that's going to
be a sand soldier for Azir. We did um we
did see two acceptable losses get played
in the early game. So that's why we're
seeing a relatively low gear count, but
that is an arise. And even if it's just
two sand soldiers, that's still fine.
>> That's great. We have more Arise. We can
do it again later. The important thing
right now is keeping the momentum. And
we know that we've got two units.
They're on battlefields. We've got four
points. Our opponent has zero units and
they don't have any units in
Battlefields especially. So it currently
doesn't matter.
>> Yeah, this is just Rocklo really seeing
how the game is progressing right now.
You know, a two unit arise in a vacuum.
It's not ideal. You're even it's even
kind of less than that cuz you're you're
missed out on an activation of Azir. But
Rock is saying no, I need to score the
points here. That's going to get me to
four. That's that even break point.
>> My opponent has nothing in play right
now. So, they're not threatening
anything. I might even just go to six
here just for existing. Let's make my
opponent actually do something.
>> You're forcing your opponent to have to
play these larger units. You're forcing
them to have to play something like
Thousand Tail Watcher because they're
stuck on that really un uncomfortable
one point and so you're forcing them
into a situation where they're going to
have to start pushing forward. Now, Rock
doesn't have any energy left, so they're
not going to be able to respond with
anything. They don't care. They're happy
to take those units uh to allow those
units down at this point. Going in with
Fizz, grabbing our um
>> acceptable losses back and removing that
BF sword. Huge.
>> Yeah, and it's crazy. So, acceptable
losses allows the player themselves to
pick which equipment they destroy. And
they chose the BF sword. the adds two
additional might to the shears but says
I need the cards from the shears way
more than I need the might from the BF
sword just really and that was an
instantaneous thing there was it was
notesitation yeah there was no
hesitation whatsoever that is I
absolutely know what the correct
decision is and that's how Rock's been
playing this entire match
>> and honestly that really goes to show
what a high level player they are
>> that goes to show exactly why they've
chosen this deck I you know I don't
think it's a best off at this point I
think they're they're choosing to
attempt to go all the way
Well, that's like what you said before
though, Amy. If if you win the whole
tournament, you still get the best. You
don't need to pass that down. It's it's
you know, why not just have it all?
>> You're going to have another one. Why
not?
>> Uh but you know, Rentoy is doing
everything in their power to stop the
overwhelming nature of the sand
soldiers. As Zia not having quite as a
fun time right now, keeping those on the
board. Definitely putting up much more
of a tussle this time. managing
resources really well with these extra
gold tokens this this game unlike game
one really trying to push themselves but
unfortunately still on that one point to
five at the moment. Rocklo likely to go
up to six this turn and that is really
where you want to be sitting to be able
to launch yourself into a win at any
moment.
>> Well, this is Rocklo is really trying to
figure out how do I thread the needle
here to do to actually set myself up to
win. They had multiple ways to actually
get that six point like you said, but
saying maybe I don't need to do that
right now. Maybe I actually just need to
develop here. They've got Azir that they
can accelerate from the chosen champ.
They've also got another Arise in hand
that can also effectively accelerate as
well, but saying, "Hey, you know what?
>> I'm just going to take my time. I don't
need Yeah, you're right. It could have
it could have accelerated a unit, taken
that sixth point, but when your
opponent's on one and their board state
is, you know, it's reasonable, but you
want to have the standing energy to
imply that you can, you know, you can
respond to whatever they've got to throw
at you. The confidence is mesmerizing.
>> Yeah, you need to be able to figure out
what what do you actually lose to here.
And a big one would potentially be wash
your bellow's breath be clearing uh
getting way more value than it needs to.
So Rocklo putting out effectively the
minimum number of units to uh or the
minimum amount of power out to actually
still threaten the board. And we see
there there's
>> Yeah, I like that being like, "Oh,
actually um I'm going to make you not be
able to get kind of
the full effect. I don't want you to
have too much when I when I pass my
turn. Uh so I'm only going to leave
these two out. And if you deal with
those, okay, that's fine. And that's the
scary part is that when your opponent's
cool with it, you know there's some
scary stuff coming next turn.
>> Yep. And we see the frigid touch there
to finish the units there. Of course,
the damage does not go away if the
combat showdown does not happen. So the
frigid touch takes them down. And there
is that one damage from the bellow's
breath killing both the units. And now
first maybe little bit of breathing room
for Ezreal here. Cleared the board has a
board of themselves. Actually able to
develop a little bit more and get to
that second point as the slow grind
starts here for Ezreal.
>> Back on a rock close turn. We've got
plenty
of energy to work with. But how will
Azir get closer to closing this game
out? I imagine it will be via many a
sand soldier.
>> There we go. Start with the desert's
call. Again, even though those sand
soldiers are not created from Azir, they
still have weapon master. That's just a
passive ability on Azir. So, we're going
to get to automatically equip those.
Looks like they have passed the turn.
Just set up that board. Pass the turn.
Don't spend any power there. So, we're
going to be generating all of our runes,
get some get some might into play, and
then have some of these accelerate
threats for the next turn.
>> Rentoy Knight does have that breathing
room you mentioned. We've got units on
the board finally. We've got energy in
play. We're now able to see if we can
take and hold these battlefields cuz I
think that's going to be the key. Now,
do you
>> do you side with just going on one or do
you try for both? Is it too risky? First
of all, Fizz.
>> Yeah, the the beauty is that Rocklo is
not threatening to win next turn. So,
you get to play a little bit safer than
you might than you might have otherwise.
If if Rocklo is at six, then you're
going to have to commit probably to one
battlefield here. Now, you can maybe
send in the Plundering Porro, get your
fourth point and then play defense on a
future turn. Let let future you deal
with that. You don't need to you don't
need to worry about uh losing right now
cuz you're probably not going to.
>> Yeah, you could even bring the viz
that's uh currently ready. You know,
you've got that in far more so. So,
you're not too worried about that. Going
in for a watcher,
not accelerated, just going for the
regular play, reducing those sand
soldiers down. So, furthering the impact
of the bellow's breath.
>> Yep, that would threaten to kill the
sand soldiers. Looks like Rocklo has
>> We're not having it. Not today. We're
going to boost them back up again.
>> Yep. We're going to boost one of them
back up. We're going to sacrifice one to
boost the other. That of course is going
to be the shears one. So that's going to
be a a card drawn from the death nail
from Shears. It's going to be a card
drawn from the spell as well. And we're
now going to be going into next turn as
Rocklo with a lot of cards in hand.
>> Well assessed. Plundering Porro jumping
on in there. Cig of the storm grabbing
finally that extra point and gaining a
gold token which hopefully will help
with our resource management for this
late game scenario. Finally at our even
number that we like to be at so much.
>> Yeah, there we go. And and now we see,
you know, Retoy was very far behind.
Have scraped into one turn of point
tempo behind.
Not really a board on the side of
Rocklo. So this is of course going to be
a pivotal turn cycle. What is Renektoy
going to be able to do? Is Rockllo going
to be able to easily get a point here to
get that six point and then set up for
the win next turn?
>> I see an arise in hand. We've got lots
of equipment.
Two of them on one sand soldier
currently going in and having a little
hello with fist now. Maybe
>> got to decide. So the sand soldier is at
three and then of course we'll have an
eye of the herald recruit token. So
could go in
destroy the fizz have a recruit token
left over to get that sixth point.
You'll also draw a card off of the
shears which is great. And then it's a
matter of how much might can I put in
the backline? How much of a threat can I
put forth to try to win on the next
turn?
>> Here we go. Fizz is being challenged. We
have the extra recruit token.
And will it be enough? Will we get? Yep.
We're going to take down the Fizz. No
response by the looks of it. No. Don't
have enough energy to do anything in
response. So, of course, we get the card
draw still, which is great. And the
recruit remains inval.
>> Yeah, the recruit remains. And I'm I'm
wondering if there's a consideration
there to actually destroy the recruit
instead of the sand soldier because
you'd strand those equipment. Of course,
weapon master can take them off, so
that's not really a consideration, but
you would have prevented a card draw
potentially there from the side of
Rocklo. I mean, it's probably not a big
deal. You would maybe rather have less
might in play as your Rexo, but it is a
consideration. like a card in the hand
of Rocklo is certainly not something to
sneeze at.
>> No, that's not I I personally wouldn't
want them to have more if I were playing
against them. So, realistically, I think
that this was a pretty good play. And
again, knowing which of the units to
take down. Uh even with targeting your
own, as we saw in the last game, it can
be very advantageous to know which ones
to leave hanging around and which ones
actually no, I don't really need that.
But what I would like is more cards.
>> Yeah, Rocklo has to decide here how much
are they going to commit? What do they
want to commit? Because you want you
don't want to overcommit and then lose
to, you know, Bellow's another Bellow's
breath watcher or something like that.
You don't want to lose too much to that,
but you also don't necessarily want to
leave all of these runes stranded cuz
it's effectively like you just didn't do
anything on that turn and you want to be
progressing your board and try to win on
the next turn. Getting the conquer point
there was really all we needed. It's
better, I think, in this instance to
have all of our resources for that kind
of finisher turn. And of course, yes, we
have the hidden blade there so we can
take out our own recruit so that we can
draw cards, which we saw last game work
to great effect. And it's exactly what
Rocklo wanted. Rocklo wants as many
cards in hand as possible to be able to
piece together that perfect winning turn
next turn.
>> So, has Fizz done them the favor they
needed?
Yeah, they've now got a lot here. And I
think we've seen a handful two wind
walls in the hand of Rocklo to be able
to have a counter for any sort of spell
shenanigans that may be happening here
if there's some big spell coming
through. Rocklo is going to be able to
counter it. But do see a mind spplitter
as well on the side of Renekto. And it
looks like that may be what's coming
out. Where are we going to bolster our
defenses here? Looks like on the Vile
Mos layer.
>> Going for that mine splitter. It costs a
lot, but it could be worth it. Let's
have a cheeky look at the opponent's
hand. Of course, we do have that Arise.
It's been lurking there for a while, but
we've also got Defy. We've got lots of
equipment. I think the Arise feels like
the obvious choice.
>> It does. And you have to I mean the rise
I feel like is the obvious choice but
you have to also you need to be able to
beat the rest of the stuff in hand as
well. And it's not going to be easy with
the Azir because we can take one
battlefield and then Azir can
effectively
>> double up those uh those tokens there.
If you can make additional tokens you
can bring them all in. Does not matter
if they are ready or not. Here they
come.
Okay, really bolstering
on Val's layer there. We talked about
this earlier. Here it is in fruition.
Both players on six points a piece. What
are you going to do about it when you're
Ezreal? You've got to make the biggest
threat possible in one battlefield. You
can't take rock. You can't let Rockow
take them. You've got one plundering
porro in base because you need it if you
want to advance your own game state next
turn. However, right now the most
important thing is Rocklo, I'm not going
to let you take these. I'm gonna do my
best and I've got a stick here. I'm
staying in Valor's Slayer and you can
try and challenge me for it, but this is
the stand that I am putting up and it's
a fantastic one at 20 total might in
Valour's layer right now.
>> Yeah, 20 is nothing to sneeze at. That
is absolutely for sure. We're going to
start with an equipment coming out. I
would imagine we're going to move the
Eye of the Herald unit over so that we
can generate that extra one recruit
because every point of might is going to
matter here very much. When you're
trying to take down 20, you need every
bit of help you can get.
>> We certainly do. But here we go. We're
starting.
>> We're beginning and we don't have like
what we can do here. We can chip away at
things. We can we can take down a unit.
We can draw a card from the shears. We
can send a we can re-equip that. We can
then send it back in. So, we can do
multiple instances of combat here.
That's no problem. And it might be the
way that we go about this is chipping
away and going in and out until
eventually we've got through all the
units. First of all, a stupify is going
to come and reduce the amount of damage.
We are choosing to defy that.
>> Makes sense. Yeah, this is exactly what
we talked about before. Cascading the
equipment. Going to take out a few units
here. Still 14 on the other side.
Nothing
>> respectable. Absolutely. But we've dealt
with at least some of the threats
available. And now, like you say, it's
about cascading that equipment down.
We're going to reuse it. Reduce, reuse,
and recycle, my friends, cuz we're going
to be uh not quite reducing, but
increasing the damage output each time
we do this. Mhm. And we make the recruit
there. We equip. We channel or sorry, we
recycle Aroon.
>> Yeah. Bake back up to seven. We're
close. Bringing Azir in. And of course,
accelerated. We're going to move into
Mars. We're going to take everyone with
us.
>> Yep. Just making sure that all the tees
are crossed and all the eyes are dotted
here. Doing the math. Rocklo seeing can
I attack with Azir bring over everything
also get another recruit over as well
because yes that eye of the herald unit
is going to be moving again.
>> Yep. You can drag him along as well as
this says hey mate I'm over here and uh
oh yeah you as well buddy. Oh my
goodness. Taking out the thousand tail
watcher straight away. The ball is
thoroughly in Rocklo's court here. Now
we've got only seven might on Renick
Toys side. And that's the handshake as
Rocklo takes his 200.
>> Yeah, that was
>> that was a 200. Well earned. It felt
like that. I felt like there was like
four or five games worth of games in
those two games that we saw. And I will
keep saying games over and over again.
>> That was only two games.
>> There was only it was only two games. It
was 200, weirdly enough. That was a 20
and it was I mean it was a really a
masterclass in Azir resource management.
Every single card was put to its maximum
effect. Every card was played at the
exact moment it needed to be and even in
moments where like that def I still I'm
going to be thinking about that double
defy turn
>> in game one forever.
>> I just learned something. We've learned
something today, kids.
We yeah, we learned you don't have to
play the defy just because there is a
target for it, even if you've already
defied that exact same spell that turn.
You can just let the second one resolve
and then defy a different spell later.
Insane.
>> Mind blown. Honestly, I could watch that
game again and again and again. That was
phenomenal from both sides. Even being
able to put up such a fight with Ezreal
was phenomenal. They did everything they
could
>> and it just wasn't enough. And honestly,
I think they both played spectacularly
though. Being able to put up that much
of a fight against an Azir opponent
quite so privileged and so so decorated.
>> Yeah.
>> There as Rocklo is just amazing. And
they really did both play to every out.
>> Oh, absolutely. I mean, you can be you
can play Ezreal at your locals, your
skirmish. You can win a skirmish with
Ezreal, do really well with Ezreal. I
played Azir a bunch of times. There's a
bunch of guys at locals that play Azir.
I win all the time.
>> But were they the best of Azir at a
recent RQ? I'm going to go ahead and say
probably not cuz there's not very many
of those people. One of them, of course,
was in that match we just saw and took
that down in spectacular fashion, but
like you said, it was back and forth. I
mean, we saw multiple times where Azir's
board was completely cleared. There was
nothing on the side of Azir able to
bring it back, though. And you know,
Ezreal again put up a great fight. Mind
spplitter thale watcher. Great great
late game from these Ezreal.
>> Perfect. That's exactly what you're
expecting from Ezreal is okay, I've got
my little guys. I'm going to deal with
your board. I'm going to go. Yep.
Goodbye, Sand Soldiers. I'll see you
later. Okay, they're back. Right. Okay.
Bye-bye again. Okay, very good. Go. Go
on. Okay, now I've got enough momentum.
I can go for my big fellas. I can remove
things from your hand. But wait, what?
How? How are there more than before? And
why do they have so much equipment? And
that's unfortunately what Azir was
bringing is on this occasion, our Ezreal
just wasn't strong enough to keep
pushing the sand back. We didn't have
that. We We were using Bellow's breath.
We were, you know, pushing it back as
much as we could. Lally blowing the sand
away, but it wasn't enough.
>> Right. I mean, this was really, for me,
this was a a solidification of Azir in
the meta. Absolutely. I had heard people
talking about Azir maybe being a real
deck. It it obviously got better post
bands.
>> Seeing a very highlevel player play Azir
in a match up that I did not I'll be
honest, I did not think that that was
necessarily going to be a great matchup
for Azir because Ezreal has so many
resources. But when you can take what
you have and use it to its fullest
extent, the deck looks completely
different. Every time I play Azir, I
play Arise on like turn two. I've got no
runes in play. All my sand hold solders
are gone and I wonder how I even got
into this bot. So,
>> how how am I losing? I don't get it. But
absolutely, we've seen some spectacular
play just there. And we've got just the
person to talk to about how they go
about learning all of those tips and
tricks.
>> Hey, James here with Rocklo. Rocklo
Hushian, hello. Welcome to to Leil. Um a
successful round three for you. Um
coming off that game against Ezreal, you
just took down the winning deck from the
last RQ. How are you feeling?
>> Um thank you for asking. I'm feeling
pretty good. I think the matchup uh is
quite unwinable for Ezreal especially
after the ban list because they are not
playing the things that let's say was
collateral damage for the Azir. Um, for
example, uh, since no one can change it
now, pick pocket is good. Down well was
really good because, um, Espri always
has more runes than Azir. And if you
down well in a turn where you had like,
um, some gold tokens, you will always
win the game. So, it's really, really
important um, for Astreas to know that
Azir is a wall that they cannot beat
right now.
>> You're just letting them know. Letting
them know. Now, the deck lists are
locked. As you said, you can't make the
changes, so we're all good.
>> And everyone's playing Ellen ZQ's deck
list. And I know the deck list. And um I
think he changed some cards that are
like even worse against Azir. I saw uh
what's it called? Sprite Call.
>> Okay.
>> The thing is like Sprite Call beats two
drops. My two drops have three might
>> and then you give him a BF sword and
then you give all these other things.
>> Uh I feel like in general matchups that
want to um what's it called? remove have
a lot of removal are really really bad
against Azir right now um because they
can only decide on killing the gear or
killing the units. Most decks or like no
deck has the capability to kill
everything and then have enough runes to
do anything.
>> Okay. Okay. So, how how have the deck
lists kind of changed? I saw your tweet
the other day uh looking for Eye of the
Heralds and Doran Shields like a day
before the tournament. Was that a last
minute thing for you? No, it was just um
me uh picking up high rares. I I
>> the thing
>> uh because of work I have no time to
play Nexus Knights and um in the new
Nexus Knight promo packs there were I
have the Herald and Dar with the promo
foiling
>> and the foiling looks like it looks
great and I had no time to get them
myself. So I just asked on Twitter and
one guy also called Felix like my first
name he just gifted them to me. So shout
out to him. He's the goat. Thank you so
much. It won me all the games.
>> Something lucky there about Felix and
that. So as you said, Nexus Nice. You
get your promos. Thanks for the plug.
Great great plug there from Rocklo.
That's the the journey you can begin
for, you know, making best of Azir.
Although that would mean you're looking
for your third best of Azir. You've
already locked down Bolognia and Las
Vegas. Are you confident for today?
Surely.
>> The thing is I'm always confident, but
I'm not delusional. The thing is Azir is
not a consistent deck. So it can just
happen that one guy is also like
performing great and has like let's say
one or two less bricky games than me. So
we can just And the thing with Azir is
the deck is so difficult to play. Anyone
who will beat me deserved it. Like it's
not like
>> if you can play Azir like that has
nothing to do with luck. It's so
difficult to play. If you if you saw the
game with Ezreal like I permanent
permanently equipped every turn
everything I did the math on every turn.
So there was not a single useless
conquer where I went in and he played
like even if he had like four or five
seven runes I wouldn't care. Um if I
conquer I win the conquer. That's like
the purpose of Azir. And that's what
everyone has to keep in mind if you play
Azir. So yeah just keep your runes man.
>> Keep your runes. That's that's some
great confidence as well. To be the best
Azir. You've got to beat the best of
Azir. I'm not going to keep you for any
longer. I'm going to let you go off for
your next round as we head over to
barcode and get ready for the next round
of Riftbound.
And yeah, we are back on the floor with
one of the best players in the room
because yeah, I am with Randy. Randy,
how are you doing today?
>> I'm pretty good. How are you?
>> I mean, I'm pretty fine as well. We just
had an Israel game on stream and it was
absolutely amazing. But you on your own,
you're not playing. What do you play
today?
>> Uh, I'm playing Airelia.
>> Ireelia. very interesting choice. We've
seen that. I mean, you posted some
pictures of some of your cards and
everything. Players were like, "Is he
really going to play?" And finally, you
are playing it. Why did you choose
Aurelia to be honest?
>> Um, I figured after baiting everyone for
like two months straight, I might as
well just play it one time and see how
people react. Um, no, seriously, I I
just think the deck is pretty good. I
didn't want to take Draven. Um it would
have been it would have felt really bad
taking a deck that was just hit by the
bun is just straight up worse than what
it used to be. So I tried to go for
Aelia. Um which got hit by the bunnies
pretty hard but um not the same not as
bad as Raven I think.
>> And for now it's going pretty well for
you because you are a three record. So
everything is fine for you. You are
aiming at the victory right?
>> Yeah that's the goal. That's the goal
for this weekend. trying to win this
event
>> finally because uh I mean during the
last event you were always short a
little bit uh with the top cut and
everything this time we wish you that
it's going to be better and let's hope
that you took the greatest picks but
isn't it hard against Victor with
Ireelia um it's pretty hard uh yesterday
night at like 11:30 I decided to just
say [__] to Victor and not play anything
for Victor and just take the L if I face
it just like hopefully it goes well um
if I face no Victor maybe I have a way
better chances of the field.
>> So, last minute changes and sometimes
it's for the best, sometimes it's for
the worst. For now, it's going pretty
well for you. Let's hope that you don't
face too many victories. I mean, for
now, it's going pretty well. Are you
confident that you can win it all?
>> Uh, I think so. Yeah, I'm pretty
confident.
>> Are you going to win it?
>> Yeah, I think so. I I think it's it's
doable. I think it's uh I have a good
chance.
>> Doable or will you do it?
>> I think I'm going to do it. Let's put
it. Okay, that's some very very
confident says. But guys, back to you.
We're done with Randy now.
Hey, welcome back to the cast desk here
for RQ Le. Uh we're closing in on the
next round of games. You got a few
minutes. Just bear with us as
everybody's pairings are getting put
together. Correct. Of course, we are
running a big big event. Nearly 2,000
players in the room here. So, we have a
few moments. Um, you and I haven't
talked too much about Azia yet. We just
saw some Azia, some some Ezreal. So, I
just heard from Rocklaw his his
confidence in that match up saying it's
basically unwininnable for Ezreal in the
current way that decks are built. Um,
key thing he was saying now that deck
lists are locked, he doesn't mind saying
that cards like Downwell that aren't
getting played are the ones that would
beat Azia. So, I thought that was really
interesting. Yeah, that's very
interesting because it seems like
acceptable losses can put like a very,
you know, big problem in in front of us
here when he doesn't have enough um
equipment to just constantly have a way
of juggling it to get the might and go
and conquer. Right. in in this
particular match that we just watched, I
felt like that was one moment when the
Ezreal could have grasped the control a
little bit by replaying again the Fizz
with the acceptable losses instead of
going for the singularity there because
I feel like
>> it does feel like un losible for Azir. I
agree when the opposing player is just
trying to find the answers without
putting the pressure at the same time on
the Azir.
>> Sure. And then Azir has a way of
rebuilding the board, finding the time,
finding the answers. And the biggest
problem for us here at least from my
perspective is that we don't have a lot
of cadral. There are the shears which
will give you the cardro if you have the
units that are dying of course right but
other than that like maybe there there
are some builds potentially with the
green azir and then silicon herder but
in the normal version that rock is
playing actually for the what third time
during the original right it's very
similar the deck list to the previous
ones um he doesn't really focus on that
right so we have the discipline like
replacing itself can tripping and the
shears so if you are running out of your
equipment that is trying to get you
value consistently on the board which is
kind of like a kadra to some degree.
Wald didn't going to have problems but
it's interesting to say that he's
thinking that it's almost un losable.
>> Yeah, very interesting. And of course
that is one of the aspects of having a
tournament where you have to lock your
deck list obviously coming into the day.
So you can't make any adjustments. You
can't watch Rockler's game in day one
and say hang on a second let me make
some swaps. No no it's locked. you uh
have to maintain your deck through the
entire tournament, which is for newer
players, maybe something that you don't
always factor in on your Nexus Knights,
but that's something that when you come
up to a competitive level, playing at
competitive uh rules and regulations
level, that deck list has to be clean
and final and all submitted.
>> And also, you have to make sure that
you're not sideboarding cards before you
start like
>> that can happen often, by the way. But I
wanted to go back a little bit to the
Azir still because
>> I'm thinking now a little bit more about
the concept of how Ezra is being played
and what we have seen here from Renekton
Renekton abuser here uh was a little bit
more
>> late game version
>> right we didn't see the winds singingers
for example we didn't see I think a lot
of copies of gust in it as well
>> yeah we yeah
>> so and those are cards that essentially
are saying like oh I'm I'm just removing
a token like permanently. You you said
about um downwell, right? Downwell is
mass gust essentially. So the versions
of the Ezreal that I had more experience
with and against and and play myself
where the ones where you are a little
bit down on on the board and you're
trying to be like going underneath
people.
>> Mhm.
>> With the sneaky tech hands with this
wincers, right? And and you have the
access to almost infinite amount of
bounces. Yeah. Right. And I feel like
that copy, that kind of Ezreal,
>> I don't think it would be unfavored
against, right? But this is where the
rift bound beauty comes in.
>> I can have this perspective on this
matchup without much experience. I
cannot really back up back it up with
facts. Then a player who is like very
efficient at his own legend is going to
tell you that he's favored into
everything. Yeah.
>> Right. And then there's the re reality
which is probably in between the two,
right? Uh, but Riftbound really has like
what I really loved about this game is
the fact that even though some matchups
can be unfavored, if you are truly like
a master of your deck, you can get some
points towards yourself and and win
those unfavored matches more frequently,
you know.
>> Yes. Yeah. I I'm hearing that we have a
few more minutes before we get to the
round.
>> Perfect. We can Yeah. So, luckily we
prepared a lot of things to talk about
the meta coming into this uh coming into
this event. Uh and I know you were
focused on a bunch of decks and we're
actually going to take a look at some
footage we did yesterday with yourself
and Blevens looking at a deck tech.
>> So, we're not yapping.
>> Welcome back everyone. We are here again
for another deck profile. We're going to
be talking about Victor. I am Blevens
joined with Lothar. We're going to play
a little uh little show match here and
talk through my deck that I've got here.
Victor, going up against Rexai.
>> Yeah, I will try not to win this
favorable matchup for me.
>> Well, at the very least, I'm going to be
talking about my plays. What I'm wanting
to be doing is controlling the board as
much as possible. I don't want you to
have units out. I'm able to make units
every single turn.
>> I'm going to try to kill as much as I as
I possibly can of yours and make units
on my side. And uh with that, let's just
dive right in. We randomly determined
that I chose to go first and uh let's uh
do this. Mulligans are ready. Let's do
this. Good luck and have fun.
>> Have fun.
>> Okay, I'm going to start off and do the
the very victor thing of making a token
on turn one. And
>> I did not predict that happening. Okay,
three energy for me.
One thing that I'm thinking about with
Victor is at almost all points in time,
I am going to want to if I possibly can,
I'm going to want to make a recruit
token every turn. Um, unless there's a
specific reason not to. So, that's what
that's what I'm going to be thinking as
I am playing this game here. And it's
interesting because Victor is one of the
decks that benefits from going second a
lot. Yeah, it does actually benefit from
grow second, which is nice because not
every deck allows you to actually get
that value from going second. I will
>> Yeah, you go
>> conquer.
>> I don't have a hex tech ray by the deck.
You know, every once in a while someone
has
>> our good friend Hexte Ray. That is not a
recruit. Let's make another recruit and
just make it nice and easy and pass the
turn.
>> Okay, so three open. That smells like a
removal spell to me.
>> Ah, what what's that? What's that mean?
>> All right, I'm going to in this case
attack with the honor broker to zone
warrants. I don't want to give you a com
here. No, no, no.
>> So, honest broker. I'm thinking here and
I am thinking that I'm actually going to
want to play an action.
>> Mhm. M.
>> So, I've got a nice little action here,
and that is the card blood money.
>> Blood Money. Okay.
>> Kills a unit out of battlefield with two
might or less. And if it was an enemy
unit, I get a gold gear token. If it was
my own unit, I get two gold gear.
>> So, I'm going to answer with a long
sword and I'm going to give it plus two.
>> Yep. That is going to effectively
counter the blood money, which is fine
if it has tempo of this, right?
>> That's true. You did you did end up
paying a power there. That's going to
give you a point and the Z warren
trigger.
>> One point for me. Now I'm going to do
the Z warren trigger first and then I'm
going to also put the void burer on top.
So void burer resolve first.
>> Yep.
>> Uh-huh. I played a card already. I'm
going to play the Nox hopeful base.
>> This one goes to the bottom. And now I
do the zones warrants. I'm going to
discard the call the weak because it's
not the best card against Victor. I'll
>> got plenty of weak to call. That's fine
with me.
>> And it's your turn.
>> All right. I am going to get a hold
point, which is awesome. That's going to
get me up to two. We're going to channel
two runes and we are going to draw a
card.
I have to decide how much I care about
that.
>> This looks like a great singularity
turn.
>> It does in fact look like that. Thanks
for reminding me that I don't have a
singularity in my hand.
>> But if you would have, Wow.
>> If I did, that would be fantastic.
So, I think we're going to play not
quite a singularity. We're actually play
this
a little interestingly.
Costs the same as Singularity, but is
not quite Singularity. It is our good
friend Riptide Rex.
>> Okay. When he enters, he does six damage
to a unit at a battlefield. I'm going to
go ahead and kill your honest broker.
You can get your gold gear token
exhausted. That's fine.
>> Thank you.
>> We're going to use this opportunity to
get our good friend, Mr. Recruit, out of
here. And unfortunately, I can't make a
recruit with Victor, but that will be
the turn for
>> You're not moving towards.
>> That is a great thing to point out. And
uh yes, I definitely did want to do that
for sure.
>> Okay, third point.
>> Third point of the game. And we're going
to discard
this wages of pain to draw a card. And
from
there,
I will pass the turn. That's what I
thought.
>> Okay, I'm tapping everything. Got my new
beauty over here.
>> Ooh, unleash unleashed rune.
All right. Now, I did get the gold, so I
can pay for the long sword. And let's
see if you were baiting me to remove my
only unit so you have a better chance at
using your colder weeks. I'm not sure if
that's the case,
>> but I want to attack into your RA
riptide Rex. You're going to first do
the ravens.
>> Yep. Let's see if we can hit. I do hit a
wages of pain.
>> Okay.
>> Um but I have no further response than
that. So, we're
>> So, we trading over here. trade.
>> Long sword goes back to base. And now
I'm going to play Seal of Rage.
>> Yep.
>> Pay one power.
>> And for the six, I'm going to give you
headaches.
>> Going to give you this guy.
>> Oo,
>> Borana. One of those cards that Victor
really doesn't like.
>> No. And I pass it.
>> I am going to get a hold point here up
to four,
which is my saving grace here.
You know, I I got the privilege of
revealing that card and it's just
haunted me ever since.
>> Okay.
>> Well, we're going to be casting a lot of
this card in this this during this
weekend,
>> right? I think you might just be right
there. Okay.
246 energy. Yep. I think we're just
going to
Do I have a reason to do that? Not Not
really. Card draw is always a reason,
potential card draw.
>> Uh
yeah, actually
you bring up a compelling point here.
Perhaps not compelling enough.
>> I don't even know which version do you
play. This is probably the more
mid-range version because you have
>> the beauty is that I think we we're both
a little bit in the blind on this
particular version. But
>> ah
>> we've got some we got some fun spice
here in the glass mixologist which does
allow me to recur a bit of value here.
>> Okay.
>> In the late game potentially. Yeah, we
we actually are going to move our
recruit in here. Go up to five.
>> Yep. We're going to make yet another
recruit in the base.
And I think what we're gonna do,
>> so we're gonna hide a card.
>> Well, you did show me wages of pain from
>> that is true. I did pass turn.
>> Okay. So, I'm at seven runes
and I'm going to play this way.
I'm going to play another seal of rage.
>> Yep.
>> Now I'm going to move my
ferris to zone warrants. No responses
from you. I'm going to get the second
point. I'm putting first zone warren on
the stack and then I'm put playing the
void burers. Void burus goes first.
>> Yep.
>> There's the sun disck and there's Okay,
so I'm going to play the sundisk. Sunis
enters.
>> I pay two for that.
And I tap red. Now I discard a card. I'm
going to discard my Phoenix. And I'm
going to Phoenix.
>> That's not fair.
>> And now I'm going to play. Look at this.
Oh, this is going to be so neat. I'm
going to tap my Sundisk. I'm going to
play two. Tap two, sorry. Uh, and
actually maybe three even. I'll play
even three. Pay one red.
>> Mhm. And my Phoenix is going to enter
ready and attack you for five.
>> Interesting.
Now I think what I want to do here
is first trigger the Room Conservatory.
>> That's the is going to give me a
stupify.
Now I've got to make a decision. That
decision, I think,
is going to be this one.
>> Is it a hidden blade?
>> It is a hidden blade.
>> Oo,
>> you have two cards in hand.
>> I do.
>> Yeah, I think I like the fact that you
have two cards in hand. I'm going to
target my own recruit.
>> Yep, for sure.
>> To draw two cards here.
>> So, I'm getting my third point. Yep.
>> And I'm going to play the Soaring Scout
into my base.
>> Yep.
>> And I'm going to pass the turn.
>> Okay.
>> This is my cold week. Uh
Call the weak protection.
>> Yes. Insurance.
>> I like it. I mean, I don't like it. In
fact,
I don't like it in fact. Okay.
I'm at five points here.
And I'm fully tapped out. Cannot do
anything.
>> Yeah. I've got to kind of not just set
up for this turn. I need to set up for
the following turn as well. That's the
That's the real key here.
So, I can go to
>> Are you playing miracle? You have like
nine cards there.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm I'm playing miracle. All
right.
Okay. So, I think I've got an idea. I
don't know if it's a good one, but I've
got an idea.
We're going to start by playing
a wages of pain on mortal
>> that kills my bird
>> because it will kill it. And also,
>> funnily enough, this is not a bird. It's
a spirit.
>> It's a spirit. It's a
>> Yeah. So, it doesn't get plus one from
Ivor's brush
>> there. Sad sad days. Uh I'm then going
to move my recruit into the
>> That's the sixth point
>> which is that all important sixth point.
Then going to make a recruit here. And
then I've got to count two, four, six.
So next time I'll have eight or I can
have seven.
I think that's okay. Actually, h
this is a weirdly relevant decision to
make. Maybe it doesn't matter.
Yeah, I'm the the problem here is I want
to do something, but all of my cards
cost power, and I just really don't want
to spend power to do a thing. So, I
think what I'm going to do is just pass
the turn.
>> Okay.
>> The thing is with Victor is that it h
does have efficient removal, but it
comes at a price.
>> It does.
>> It either costs you your own units as
well, or it costs you tempo,
>> because you're going to be paying a lot
of power.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. And that's it's tricky to play
that deck. That's for sure.
>> It definitely is.
>> And also what I really like when when
you play against yellow color,
specifically Victor, your opponents have
to adjust to your own gameplay. Like the
cool the weeks, you have to keep units
in base. Maybe sometimes you will not
even conquer on turn two because you
don't want to potentially lose a unit
very fast.
>> Exactly.
>> All right. So in this case, I'm going to
go No, I actually have to hold because I
cannot give you a point.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So I am
>> threatening to win next turn.
try to attack.
Yes, I will try to attack with the
Soaring Scout first to you over here.
>> Okay, Raven Bloom Conservatory first.
>> Oh, no. The
>> the key miss. I think
>> I'm going to just
No, I don't really need to do that.
Yeah, that this trade is is fine.
>> Okay, my unit dies. So, I was just
speaking about having an insurance
against Cold Week and now I don't have
one.
>> True. See, that's that's what you get
for talking too much. Now, I'm going to
accelerate my Rex eye.
>> Yep.
>> Going to pay one red. Uh, you have two
mana open, two energy open, so I should
not be hit by anything over here.
>> So, I'm just going to accelerate.
>> Yep.
>> And, uh, I don't need to tap the sun for
anything. Any responses?
>> No responses.
>> Fifth point, I'm going to tap Void
Burough.
>> Mhm.
And in this case, I'm going to play the
Noxus hopeful into my base. Oro goes on
the bottom.
And I'm going to also equip my long
sword to my Rexai.
>> Yep.
>> And I am going to pass the turn. Okay.
Well, this is a a key turn here. We're
at six, which means we're potentially
threatening to win here. We've got a lot
of might on the other side of the board.
>> Well,
>> however,
>> I just gave you a win if you have
singularity.
>> True. I don't have singularity. However,
I do have
1 2 3 4 five. Do have Imperial decree.
>> Oh, no. Which says when uh when any unit
takes damage this turn, kill it. Uh,
which you know, I could just trade in my
two recruit tokens to kill those two
units. That would be great.
>> Yeah.
>> But what's even better is Bellow's
Breath.
>> Oh my.
>> Which I can repeat to pay two and two
energy to do damage here. Get those off.
>> That's going to be enough to clear the
board and then overtake the two
battlefields.
>> Yep. That will wait. I will play my two
mech tokens.
>> You gota you got to make sure you
maintain the board state. Exactly.
That's going to be it. GG Lothar. That
was a little bit of a demonstration of
Victor what he's trying to do here. Make
units, kill your units. Keep that point
tempo. End the game with a big turn like
that. Hopefully that was a good example.
Hopefully you check out Victor as well.
But this has been our deck profile here.
Hope you enjoyed it and we'll see you on
the next one.
Welcome back to RQ Leil. It's going to
bug me every time I see that video. And
not only are you you don't bug me,
>> Blevins pulling another like rare card
out of the content creator like pre
>> You want to hear a story from that?
>> I do.
>> So
>> Blevens was sitting across me and we
were just making jokes that he's going
to get another signature because he's
always getting an overnumbered and maybe
a signature. So I said
>> I said look I'm just going to take your
set and I'm going to give you mine and
I'm going to swap.
>> And I didn't do it. I was going to say,
but did you cuz he told me
>> he offered and I was like, nah, I'm just
gonna keep my own, you know, and it's
like and then he opened the overnumber
portal and I'm like,
>> that could have been your over number
pal.
>> Could have been my um so uh as mentioned
and as I'm sure you can uh guess from
being at home, uh the last round is
still just finishing up and and getting
everything ready. Uh the pairings of
course need to come out for the next
round. So we will be chatting with you
for just a few more minutes before we
get hope
>> our next round. And I know here comes
the podcast uh is what's coming next. So
we're almost at the halfway point of the
day after this round. We'll be halfway
through day one of Swiss.
>> Correct.
>> Um
>> I think that's kind of the point that
fatigue really starts to creep in. This
is where like loss streaks start
happening like you kind of get a couple
bad results or you you're 4 and0 after
this next round and you feel pretty
good. like how would you as a player or
someone who has worked with pro players
uh try and keep that mentality in check
as you go through a long day like today?
>> I feel like it it is still a little bit
too early to even think about that. You
know, I feel like from a perspective of
a player, um, the fatigue is probably
coming down like at round six, like for
the last two rounds is going to be the
moment when you have to fully focus. And
every single player has their own kind
of ritual or maybe like habit of of
bringing themselves up to speed when it
comes to attention and so on. I know uh
some players like to disassociate. for
example, they like to just get some uh
earbuds, some headphones that will have
noise cancelling, really good noise
cancelling. It's really loud, by the
way. There's like 2,000 people
>> also talking outside. So, when they are
speaking, it's actually getting really
loud. So many players are just like
taking the earbuds, noise cancelling, go
out, listen to music and just try not to
think maybe about the game and just like
focus on something else to keep them
like you know refreshed or like do
something that they enjoy overall like
hanging talking with friends and like
it's always something
>> different for every single player. Some
of players would like to maybe drink a
coffee, you know, or or get energy drink
or whatever, right?
>> That would be me. And you mentioned
there's so much going on out there, not
only just for our main event. There's so
many people hanging out, socializing at
the event. I want to find out a little
bit more about what's going on behind
these walls of the broadcast. Let's
check in with Barcode.
Thank you guys. Yeah, back on the floor
with a very special player in front of
the gravity wall. Sorry, Flash. Welcome
in this event. I mean, you're doing
pretty well right now. Especially
considering the fact that you're playing
a legend that not a lot of players are
actually with today.
>> Well, I'm playing Teemo right now and
well, I lost one game, I won two. So,
that's I'm trying my best now and I see
how it how it will go.
>> And yeah, playing Teemo, I mean, this is
a fan favorite to be honest. A lot of
players like Teemo. Why exactly did you
pick Teemo and what do you like about
this legend? Well, first I picked Teemo
because like in my first packs when I
opened them, I I opened like three
titers and like the Teemo signature
spell. So I was like, I have to look
into it. And then I started playing it
and it was very very fun. I just love
the all the shenanigans you can do like
with the hidden part and like just act
like you're hiding something important.
In the end, you just draw two and and
then you see the face of the opening
being, oh, I should have I should have
gone. And then the next turn you hide
something important and they come and
then so yeah it's all that mind game
that's very fun to be fair. Yeah it is
really fun but when you are on the
opponent part I mean it is very very
scary to be honest and I was watching
some of your games uh just a little bit
earlier and I saw your opponent was a
little bit lost to be honest because I
think that they're not used to play
against your legend. So that must be
absolutely insane to be like that. I see
that you came to have a lot of fun, but
do you think that you can just go into
day two with your legend? How do you
think that you are positioned in the
meta game right now?
>> Well, day two sounds very very far to be
fair. I played in Bolognia, I was like
two points away from day two, but in
Bolognia I was way more confident like
because we had the fight of flight and
and I had the dreaming tree and stuff.
Now my list changed a lot since the
bands. So, I'm not that confident,
>> but I'll try my best and see how it
goes.
>> You'll try your best, and that's the
most important thing to do at an inter
at an international event, basically.
So, your round is starting really soon.
We're going to let you go. Hoped for the
best for you. Back to you.
>> Thank you, Barco. Thank you. With uh I
think I think you said Flash, one of the
Teemo players uh in the venue.
>> Few of them over here.
>> I was going to say there's a few Teemo
players. We know of course the best of
teamo from Bolognia is in the house
already. One of our featured players
that we're keeping an eye on. Again, you
I think you may just have heard the
announcement of the next round coming
through. I think it came through the
microphone there from uh from the
interview with Barcode. So, we are
getting closer and closer and obviously
we're we're keeping our eyes on on
specific players. I know that we put in
some requests for some interesting
matchups.
>> What did what did you put? Well, I think
one of the requests was for prismaticism
on one of our featured match up. So,
we'll see. But our featured matchup, or
at least our featured players that we're
keeping an eye on throughout the entire
event. Let's drop back in. We checked
this after round one. Now, we're
checking it after round three. Marshall
for Riftband Report. Uh two and one. So,
we saw his uh his first win of the day.
Alan, I think no surprises that the
machine surprises here
>> hasn't dropped a game in the first three
rounds.
>> Yeah. And then we have Yamato.
Unfortunately, one and two. He still has
a chance if he just wins from now on.
>> Just everything everything, you know,
it's still possible to do a sub
submarine quest over here and do go
underwater, you know. Uh but um Kai'Sa
overall, that's one of the topics that
when we we're going to have like a lot
of time to yap, I I would like to yap
about Kai'Sa and how she will probably
know is going to be well positioned in
this meta game because of Aurelia
matchup is still not really the best.
But I also feel like against the Draven,
she might still struggle because she
might just pivot to the more unitbased
build, you know, and that is a little
bit worse in the Draven than the control
version.
>> We definitely will have time to talk
about some Kaiser as we go through the
day. Another Kaiser there, 3 and0 Randy
3 and0 on Aelia. Kasanova two and one
still alive for day two.
>> I wonder what did he lose to.
>> We'll we'll have to find out from him at
some point. And I know uh Te the Bow uh
one of the best of Garens of course or
best of Garen I think it kind of just is
safe to say uh looking for another best
of
>> we have a one two score he's on point.
>> You know that's kind of that's kind of
the thing about the best of cards is you
just need to keep playing the rounds and
if you pick up wins towards the end of
the day when perhaps the day has started
not so great for you. All you need to do
is kind of just try and jump over the
line a little bit. You don't need to.
>> I will have to check. Did the even best
of I mean, did he get the best of Garen
for day two in the in Bologon
>> or was it day one? Right.
>> Was it day one? I actually don't know.
>> I have a feeling it was day two. But one
of the names that I put down on the list
for this round, I'm going to take credit
for it. Colin from Challenger TCG, who
is a a very, you know, wellrespected and
and well-known player, has played a lot
of events over the last uh few months.
Uh, shout out to our team behind the
scenes that are picking the featured
matches. It's not just me. I will uh I
will not actually take their credit from
that. Going up against Lucia Lucian. Go.
That's easier to say than to uh to
actually put forward. And it's Victor.
First Victor of the day for us. We just
saw the deck uh the deck tech that you
did with Blevins yesterday.
>> Yes, correct. Um we don't know which
version of the Colin never mind. Now we
know what version of the deck Colin is
playing. So this is more a unitbased
Victor. We do see that there's also a
Vangut armory in three copies, but no
Jays. So, not trying to combo it
anywhere. It's just an honest seven
energy card that you want to play. Uh,
but then you if you have access to this
card, like every single Imperial decree
is just going to clean up the
battlefields at the in that turn. So,
this is a more honest Victor deck and
it's I feel like it's pretty okay
positioned into the metag game. It
shouldn't have any like terrible
matchups apart from maybe Rex, you know.
>> Interesting. Interesting. I've seen a
lot of conversation going through about
Victor over the last few days.
Obviously, Victor has had such high
prominence over many, many tournaments
even since like kind of like the
release, but has struggled to actually
put up the results. So, on the other
side of the table for this match is
going to be Lucian. We've already seen
one today. Um, and of course we know
that the Lucian combo with Trinity Force
and Skyfall, like scoring points very
quickly, um, has had some some favorable
um, changes from the bands, less so in
the Victor matchup, but a lot of cards
were removed from the pool of
battlefields and cards that that made it
difficult for for Lucian to actually
play around the game against some of the
other decks. Yeah, in general there was
a very important erata to relentless
pursuit which allows you now to play the
card without having any equipment on the
board which does make it much easier to
like squeeze into the rounds. Also, I
like the way that um this build is being
done because we have a lot more tool
drops. We have the Poutiporo, which is
great against any, you know, any any
based uh deck based on removal. But we
also have the rare gods, which is
basically just an empty vanilla to um to
drop, but does have value when you draw
it later stages of the game because now
you can also have an accelerated unit
that will equip all the equipment that
you will have on your side of your board
and get get the value out of that. Now,
the thing is because the metag game is
swapping to a lot more yellow overall in
the game. Now, all most of the decks or
at least the decks that were trying to
build like one hero and just do like
some really sick stuff or like Urelia or
like revolution, we're trying not to
play any other units. But now, since the
week is such a common card, you have to
rebuild your decks around that. So, this
is why we see Desert Skull being a ch
being a card of choice in green.
Basically, if you want to make sure that
you're not dying to cold a week, you go
desert skull. In case of Lucian, we're
going to go into more two drops to not
get blown out when we are essentially
trying to win the game with the combo.
Like, you know, we only have one unit,
right? So, but you can see that there
are aspects of the deck which are quite
um tight on numbers. For instance, uh in
this version that that Irene is is
running, notice only two Ferris
4runners. That's a card that when I see
one in the list, I'm like, put three in.
Definitely more than one. Yes.
>> Yeah. Ex two in this deck. But I guess
my point is like but again you can't go
too high up in that cuz you want to
include some ruin runners. You want to
include a few other things. So some
interesting different parts of deck
building. That is always the interesting
thing at tournaments is we'll see where
Irene is going on the turn. The most
common Victor turn of just play a
recruit. I'll pass.
>> Yeah. Also very interesting way of
putting your legend and champion unit
together. It's a little bit tilting.
>> Hey, I mean, we don't have the zones on
the playmat this time, so we just said
do what you want on this one.
>> That's That's the Lucian just straight
up on the board that could be open to
call the week. Now, I'm not an expert on
Victor. Do you even do it in this case?
I don't know. Probably. Um, it does deal
you in a very weird position.
>> It does feel kind of like a a gimme
though where you're like, I kind of got
to do it, right? Will I get another
chance? Is there even a call the week in
the hand? I don't think so. That's a
hidden blade, Imperial decree, Ivangard
Armory on the left, and I think that
second to the left was like some I think
that was wages of pain, but I'm not
certain.
>> I think you may very well be correct. I
I did uh see it. We'll try and get
another angle on that as that'll be the
move to the battlefield for Candleit
Sanctum. And by the way, if you
remember, Colin was one of the set
specialists. Yes. Uh early in the game,
and he is just an very efficient player
in every deck that he's going to pick
up.
>> I think in hand it was two card shops by
the looks of it. The pattern looked
correct, but that foiling is
>> I love what Irene did here. Not many
people are actually taking the gold,
>> you know, because they're like thinking,
"Oh, my opponent is now going to get two
gold. That is just too much." But the
thing is, you don't feel about the gold
in a certain way when you know the
matchup.
>> In this case, the Lucian is going to be
the aggressor having access to gold in
this case when your opponent gives it to
you to this turn because it's active
immediately the moment you start your
turn, right? You're going to be able to
ramp up faster because of that. And
you're going to try to keep up pressure
because you have access to more energy.
So, this is really heads up play by
Aren. I love that. I love to see that
it's being proactively understanding
like the matchup here and it's very
important actually. Yeah, I think a lot
of people when they saw card shop were
like, "Well, you're probably never
taking the gold." And you're right. This
is a time where you're like, "Yeah,
actually I will take that gold. Thank
you very much." And uh play out two
powder parro. There are the two drops
that you talked about. And in this
matchup, I've noticed a lot of things
like ruin runner, pouty parro. Like
>> there are some spells in this like blue
yellow archetype that require targeting
units. So you can force them to damp. Of
course, Ker Week does not, but there are
many other cards that remove that that
do require that target.
>> Yeah. All all of the efficient removal
now is highly inefficient. Yeah.
>> Essentially, which is very important for
keeping up the pressure. You just try
not to lose them those pyers to just
normal fights, right? But by the way,
coming back to card shop, one more
thing.
>> Yeah, sure. It's a very interesting card
when you play it in a blue purple
because your opponents can take gold
from card shop to play around your um
acceptable losses for example.
>> Ah okay.
>> So that's one of the things in early
deck building that was being caught as
maybe a deck building mistake to
implement both acceptable losses and
card shops in the same um in the same
deck. And I feel like we're just going
to there is going to be a hoorde of
treasure in this game with a treasure
horde plus the card shops coming out
like a lot of gold, a lot of tokens
coming for both players, I imagine. Does
cop look a little bit like Scrooge
McDuck.
>> He's upside down for me. So I'm actually
not sure uh at this point. But let's
take another look at the hand. So
singularity zenzo uh decree armory,
right? That's what I
>> I think so that
>> yeah trying to just getting flashes of
Colin's hand to to to look in.
>> Okay, we're putting out the Victor
leader which if you're not accustomed to
Victor uh will create a token whenever
your non-token units are dying. So in
this case it would be card shop.
>> Yes. And importantly to know uh just for
newer players again there is that
restriction of it being in base. So you
do have to to to play around that
restriction as well. So even if you hold
the battlefields, it's not necessarily
like you can stack them up.
>> Um so Colin up to three points already.
And this is one of the things that this
this Victor deck does that's similar to
some of the other decks we've seen in
the meta. Just it swarms really well.
Like this is what Victor does has since
Origins. That is going to be uh the
sabotage coming through. So you you
immediately start looking to uh Imperial
Decree as one of the options. Um I'm not
s I'm unc certain if I'm even taking a
look at the Imperial decree like current
state of the board is we have weenies
you know
>> we do have a ferris forana in the in the
hand but it's still like the biggest
problem here is how much of a value is
that singularity that's the first
question right that's the first question
you have to ask yourself is a
singularity next turn a problem if it's
not then you can ask yourself okay now
can can we think about the combo of
decree and bellowrev against our uh
Ferros Fahrenheit. Is that is that a
problem? Sure. And then you try to
establish a sequence of plays from your
opponent and how will that affect you?
>> Yeah. So, Singularity was being taken.
>> Yes, that that makes sense with the line
that you're following. I want to ask a
quick rules question. I'm pretty sure I
know the answer to it. Um Bellow's
breath targets both the location and the
units, right? So you would have to on a
repeated bellow's breath if you targeted
both deflect units. You would pay a lot
of of he's not going to do that. Colin's
not not likely to actually do it. But
just double checking that that that is
indeed how that works.
>> But the thing is now now knows I hope
that's how you read his name um or their
name uh has the knowledge of Imperial
Decree and Bellow's breath being in the
hand of the opponent. So will we ever
play the ferris forana? Because if
that's the case, a decree comes out, a
token goes in into the ferros forana,
>> kills the ferrosana, mechs are being
spawned in the base, and now you just do
bellows on top of it
>> and just destroy everything.
>> That's a pretty clean way of still using
two cards and a token, but it is the way
to deal with a ferris, right? And this
ferris was being played this turn on
that battlefield.
>> And when the mech spawn, your bellows
will hit Lucian as well.
>> I am a little bit caught off guard here
by this play because this is like
>> it's one of the reasons why whenever I
reveal a Victor's hand and there's an
Imperial decree there, I'm like, well,
that's going to cause me more problems.
>> Yeah. So, that was I was thinking like
if we get this Ferris Forana into the
base, then it's like semi safe.
>> Sure. Yeah. You at least force multiple
spells, right? I feel like Colin's like,
"What is what is going on?" Cuz like my
opponent is all runes exhausted, no
resources available to play around this
just has to think it through, right?
It's just like, "Okay, is this is it?
>> Maybe I'm yapping and maybe it was this
Bellow's breath being removed or
something." No,
>> no, it was the singularity.
>> Okay. So, I'm not missing that. Okay.
>> So, it is decree and then the follow-up
will come come from it. Exactly as you
were saying. That is the sequence.
>> I am a little bit surprised. I'll be
honest with you. I'm I'm trying to
understand the reasoning here. Maybe
that's a bait.
>> And now you can just repeat the Bellow's
breath. One goes to the base, one goes
to the battlefield if you wanted to.
>> Or you can just sacrifice the token for
for the Pora as well.
>> But at least then you get to conquer it
on the back end, right? Or yeah, as you
said, you can sacrifice the the token
for the parro. Yep.
>> Yeah. I think that's that's such a a
difficult spot to be in now because
Yeah. Here comes the here comes the
Bella's breath.
>> Yeah. 1. Look, I'm not saying um
anything about this because maybe
there's a reason for this play.
>> Sure.
>> And we're going to see the follow-up.
>> I think the followup from Colin here is
I'm just going to make another unit and
>> I know what you mean from from our
Lucian player, but I'm saying
>> this is like incredibly efficient turn.
>> We talked about like Ferris 4Runner
being a difficult card to play around in
the meta in general. Uh, and and Victor
is one of the decks that can do it when
the board is set up for it. And that was
about as perfectly as a board is going
to be set up for a single turn to clear
out everything from a Ferris 4 runner
and units that were already existing.
>> Yeah. I mean, just look how difficult
this turn would have been if uh the
Ferris would have been in base, right?
Because then you have to play it. Yes.
>> Play the decree. Use the bellows rep.
the two mech tokens would have still be
there because you cannot target them
with the repeat of the bellows breath.
So there had to be another thing to be
played there.
>> Yeah, that's that is the the difference
there of it being in the base unlocked
the ability to just say hey okay a
recruit will take out a ferris 4runner
and now the followup you kind of have to
feel like Colin is likely to feel quite
confident from this position deciding
where to put the recruit token. Um
Lucian can come out of nowhere with a
lot of strength. Uh, this is a very
heads up play by Colin as well, putting
up here the hidden blade. I would, if I
would be in Colin's shoes as well, I
would be like, wait, he just did a
sabotage. He knew exactly what I had and
he still played into my hand. There has
to be a reason for it. And I feel like
Colin is trying to find it. So maybe
he's playing around like, for example, a
direct trifarian that would be able to
kill uh the um
the Victor leader, right? and try to
overcome his opponent now on on on one
of the battlefields. So the hidden
blades there being put on the
battlefield as a heads up play against a
potential push because he was expecting
something to come after that but they
didn't.
>> Yeah. And now here is the the Triforce
Skyfall played from hand just
representing that you know if we get to
the next turn I will potentially put the
combo together and you know that's where
we start looking at is it a ruin runner
in hand which again on its own okay
maybe a relentless pursuit on top of it
is is going to help.
>> Well you have to get it ready as well
right so there are few options here
either relentless pursuit or a first
mate. Yeah,
>> right. Those are the things you can
maybe try using relentless pursuit
during your opponent's turn as well to
then like not to not leave um or
>> how do I say this to to leave a lot of
questions unanswered.
>> And you know, Lothar maybe is starting
to make a little bit of sense because
Imperial decree is one of the only
things in this deck alongside Colin
Runner.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. Because in that scenario then a
ruin runner does die to a recruit. So,
if the setup is Irene saying, "Okay, I'm
going to play out a big board, force you
to deal with it, force you to use as
many of your big spells as possible, and
then on the back end, it'll look like
I'm losing, but I'll turn the corner
very quickly with this Lucian deck." It
It might be there to set up, but I I
think time is starting to run out.
Collins at six points. It has to be
right now or this game is done.
>> Yeah. As like you Yeah.
>> Yeah. There we go. I was thinking maybe
there's like a triple relentless push
soon and you're going to get
>> everything.
Four points in your turn and then four P
four points in your opponent's turn or
like double points or whatever.
>> My favorite thing about this is hidden
blade is almost never really hidden cuz
you hide a card and you're like, well, I
know it's hidden blade. It's basically
nothing else.
>> That that is true. I mean it well
actually could have been past. Oh, it
could be wages of pain. You're right.
Yeah, sure. That's fair.
I got some people in in previous metag
game. Oh, sorry.
>> Got to set up straight. Uh in previous
meta game, I got some people by hiding a
bushwack and everyone was like, "Oh, I
know it's a fight or flight. I'm not
even going to try to attack into it."
And then next turn starts and I'm just
bushwacking. It's like
>> I've heard people are doing that. I
heard a story on Friday in the the um
the pre-regional. Somebody was like,
"Why are people hiding bushwack right
now?" Like I'm playing against decks
that are randomly doing it. Let's take a
look at sideboards from this. Ooh, that
is an interesting sideboard card in uh I
I know people love trying to get Shen in
things. Uh salvage is one that we I mean
it's coming in right there's no you're
playing against yellow. They have
salvage in the sideboard. Salvage is
coming in against the equipment.
>> One of the best cards in the game when
it comes to removing equipment can
tripping that is also very important.
Okay, so another for honor definitely
comes in. Uh we are most likely siding
in the um the ruin runner just to have a
little bit more units
>> and the falling star. I'm not certain
how important it is. We did we actually
see we did see the captain
>> and we seen Zenzhowl.
>> Yeah. And if your opponent ends up
playing Victor, it kind of helps. But
yeah, it's one of those cards where
you're like, well, I'm not going to kill
tokens with it.
>> Recruits are bad to
>> unless it's to finish the game.
>> Sure. Yeah, that's a very very fair
point. But, you know, you wouldn't see
two recruits and be like, yeah, I'm just
going to damp myself a whole turn just
to uh to deal with that most of the time
at least. So, we are in round four.
Colin leads the series one, game to
zero. Um, I'm I'm interested to see now
where game two comes from from Irene
because we we saw the the the pieces of
the combo assembled throughout the game,
just not at the same time.
>> Yeah. And I'll be honest with you, I
think Lucian's an incredibly cool deck.
It's it has this kind of um very weird
dynamic because you think about
relentless pursuit and it's kind of like
right to wind but not exactly because
the thing is um in comparison to right
to wind you can play a relentless
pursuit on your opponent's turn and
still be kind of safe because after the
showdown closes when you moved with
relentless pursuit you can move back to
the base
>> during your opponent's turn. So, not
only you can become and uh you sorry,
you can get another point during your
opponent's turn, which is accelerating
the state of the game, but you're not um
uh you're not open to actionbased speed
uh essentially removal at that point
when you're doing it, right? I mean,
okay, you might be in the next showdown,
but anyway, my point is that it's it's
in our game, aggro decks are the ones
that can cut a corner when it comes to
the amount of points that you need to
get, right? In other card games, you
have to just get a lot of damage, for
example, to kill someone's character,
destroy a base, or something like that.
In our game, we have to get to eight
points, and you can get only two points
per turn. But if you're able to get
points during your opponent's turn, that
is accelerating the state of the game.
And that's that is a true aggro. Lucian
can do it in both both sides, right? You
can do it with the combo of Skyfall and
Trinity Force or you can do it with
Relentless Pursuit. And also one more
thing that kind of doesn't come up often
and maybe might be confusing to the
viewers as well if you're not accustomed
to Lucian. When Lucian is doing the
relentless pursuit, when your opponent,
for example, moves into a battlefield,
when you do a relentless pursuit to go
into the same battlefield as your
opponent just is trying to attack,
>> you are becoming the surprise defender.
>> Yes.
>> So that doesn't trigger your assault
from your equipment that you would have
on Lucian. You need to really understand
when do you want to use the relentless
pursuit as a defender or as an attacker
and understand how does this actually
affect the board state.
>> Yeah. And I think a, you know, Lucian's
uh assault for each equipment is one of
those effects that people also just
forget. Sometimes you do the math and
then you're like, "Oh, you're on the
attacker."
>> You would be surprised how many people
forget about master's ye pass.
>> Yeah. Oh, I do. I'm an ARI player and I
forget that I have to minus one. When
people
It's my legend. I'm like, "Oh, yep.
Forgot about that. Oh, well." Um,
>> is that a Wait, do we have even a two
drop over here? Ooh, ruin runner ferris
4runner trinity force and what what is
the fourth card?
>> I couldn't quite see it as it as it
flicked through as we will get into game
two as well
pass. That's that's difficult cuz Victor
always has a turn one play. Yeah,
>> that is one of the the things that is
solid about the deck is there is never a
point at which you have turn one. Oh,
I'll do a thing and then it's follow it
up, play another unit. Now we're off to
the races with Victor having two units
in base already.
>> Oh, this is going to be rough if there's
a cold week right now.
>> Yeah, that would be a very painful
>> and seed of power. Look at this. Wait,
seed of power is from coming from Colin,
right? No, wait. It's void gate should
be coming from Colin. So seed of power
which is Yes, of course it's stated on
the right. I am just blind.
>> So the seed of power actually now gives
a incredible effect for Colin. It's a
three card draw because he's going
second. That's one of those things that
um you have to think about when it when
it comes to choosing the battlefields
and maybe sometimes you will just use a
different battlefield going into the
second game because you know you have to
win it and your opponent has a very high
chance of having two units on their turn
one. And here this is a I I know it's
just one card but that one card can
change outcome of games. This is a very
big deal.
>> No, it is. And honestly, I'm going to be
totally open with you. I think a lot of
people were not looking at seed of power
because it wasn't how the game was being
played for a while. Everyone was like,
"Yeah, it's a 2v2 and you know that kind
of battlefield." But with the change to
these wide board states, suddenly you do
start to control a little bit more uh
easily at least through the game.
>> I can tell you who was playing seed of
power in the previous meta again.
>> Was it you?
>> Yeah,
>> it was because I was playing Sundisk in
in Rexile that could have triggered from
itself. So on turn two, you can trigger
with a two drop and attack both
>> fields. Okay. All right. We'll give you
the credit for that one then. Loa, I I
know I know now. I've known you long
enough that when you say, "Do you know
who's doing that?" It's normally you,
Lucian's going to go in for the
showdown. I think on the the void gate
is the sequence of events. So that will
uh tidy that one up. Dangerous to be at
void gate, although wages of pain would
would take out Lucian anyway. But of
course, Lucian's ability is going to
conquer, ready him, move him back to the
base. No problem. Nothing that Colin
could do about that. And that is now
illusion and a ferris 4runner in the
backline for now. Which backline that is
actually now a term being used in the
next set. So I'm going to have to stop
saying that. I'm going to have to say
something different.
>> So the thing is
this Feros forana is making up for a
little bit of that um let's say lack of
tempo in turn one. Right.
>> Right. Because we didn't have a two
drop. And now if there would let's
imagine this is a Darus instead of a
Ferris for any other unit. If there
would be a singularity, it would be
looking looking really rough for Lucian.
But because Ferros Fer is so hard to
remove in this position without leaving
a trace in back in the base with the two
mechs, you still have a way of making a
comeback even with this um like you know
efficient removal coming in from Colin.
All right, so no energy from Lucian, no
way of interacting over here. Colin is
trying to set up this turn in a way
where he has to find an answer to the
ferris for Anna or rather live it let it
live for enough time to just win over
it. He has advantage in points four to
one, right? So, he can just maybe like
try to hold one battlefield and just try
to negate the value out of a potential
push, but it's hard to do if you don't
have a hidden blades.
>> And you could see Colin kind of shake
his head from side to side, which way do
I want to go? Do I want to develop this
turn with the machine evangel and say,
"Okay, well, I'm going to play a big
unit that on its downside, you know,
when it when it has a death nail trigger
will end up benefiting my uh
>> my my units more." And that is the play
that is going to happen.
>> He's not super happy with this play. I
can definitely understand because he is
now in the driver's seat when he is
actually being really aggressive. But
playing Evangel over here is not
aggressive. It's just putting four might
for and and typically it it's being used
to have a backup when you're being
pushed away from from the site, right,
from the battlefield. And now you have a
way of using your recruits from um from
the base in start at the start of your
next turn. In this case, we might
actually see the other way around where
Evangel is going to push into a
battlefield, try to destroy something
and play the recruits into your base,
but then you have to wait another and
essentially get any value out of them,
>> which is tricky. You saw Irene also
reread machine evangel. Always worth
doing when you see a card that is
slightly less often played or at least
the one that you're less familiar with.
If you want to get that wording exact,
of course, machine evangelian
didn't get untapped.
>> Oh no.
>> So it's had the conquer, but now have we
moved past it?
>> Yeah, we moved past it because of the
went into the seat of power.
>> So that is a huge issue.
>> Yeah,
>> for Lucian right now. that is losing the
Lucian most likely for no reason unless
we're going to be using a relentless
pursuit.
>> Uh that is another way of doing it. Uh
Ru comes out here. Is it like
>> but I don't think it's worth it.
>> Is this also to protect for if Lucian
goes to the backline? Um I mean Imperial
decree doesn't hit Ruin Runner anyway.
So I'm just like thinking about like
what are you playing around if you are
leaving the Lucian there on purpose?
You're right. You have the relentless
pursuit to to get out. So there's uh
there is an exit strategy potentially,
but that is scary the situation we're
in.
>> If you're just leaving it there, it just
dies to the evangel, right? So you have
to like try maybe
bluffing anything like what punch first
maybe from the hand. So you get plus
five. So it goes to eight and now the
evangel just bounce back and leaves an
eight might lucian on board. Yeah, there
are quite a few like things represented.
>> Yeah, but the thing is there's a
sabotage in Irene's hand and it wasn't
used.
>> Yeah,
>> you could still bluff
>> the punch first sabotage.
>> If he leaves two out,
>> that for me is an information that we
either using one of the relentless
pursuits to save one of our units and go
back to base without scoring a point.
Unless Colin will make a a different
decision when it comes to sequencing and
he's going to take over the other
battlefield and then Irene is going to
go use the Renaance Puit to go to the
battlefield that was just conquered.
>> Okay. So to the old switcheroo.
>> Yeah. Guys, there's a lot of potential
outcomes here, and they all depend on
how Colin will read the hand from Irene,
>> which that is the innate skill at a uh
at a competitive level on car games is
you can only account for a certain
amount of of scenarios. So, reading what
you've seen in the game so far, reading
how that interacts with the current
board state and saying, "What is my best
option and what is the worst thing that
I have to play around?"
>> This is a really interesting board
state. So, if we're going to start by
going into void gate by attacking it and
we're checking if there is going to be a
um a punch first and this then oh we're
actually going into seed of power. Huh.
Not exactly. Colleen is also thinking
like okay he's attacking for seven into
the ferris for Anna. I like that because
it's forcing Irene to either play that
punch first to save the ferris for Anna.
Right.
>> Yeah. or just say hm I value the um the
Lucian more. But the thing is neither of
those things are true.
>> Is that also where you're saying okay if
I put three mechs in the backline?
>> Do I then want to clear them down? It's
a long sword is the other
>> it's long sword. He goes for the value
trade over here unless there's a stupify
in the hand. There's a whole clutch of
cards in Colin's hand to to pick from to
see exactly which option. Surely one of
them has to be something.
>> Well, he can play decree.
>> He can play the decree mid combat over
here because it is an action spell. By
the way, it is weird that it is it is an
action spell.
>> I do forget that so many so so much so
often it is just played early in the
beginning.
>> Exactly. Yeah, it is that
>> the Imperial decree counters essentially
the um the long sword. Ferris dies. We
have two mechs now in base and a
repeated bell's breath is going to kill
everything apart from the Ruin Runner.
>> Yeah, that is the strength of Ruin
Runner will not be able to be targeted
of course um in this situation. So, as
expected, here comes
Bellow's Breath.
>> He's going to clear out Lucian.
>> Still not terrible. I just want to
reiterate Lucian can still cheat out the
game in a positive way with the
Relentless Pursuits. Now, it's not going
to be easy,
>> but
>> there is a way of like trying to catch
up on points with the Relentless
Pursuits, but the problem is that your
opponent is at six right now.
>> Yeah. And that is that is a set one play
style where you put yourself at six and
now your opponent is facing a permanent
win condition essentially almost every
single turn and you have to find
solutions. This is the pressure point
where Lucian will have to find not only
a way of winning but also find a way of
not losing before you're able to win. I
know it sounds stupid when I say
>> no it makes sense. You you have to play
at a pace that allows your deck to to
win at the same time as preventing your
opponent. like it makes total sense.
That's exactly how that plays. So now
it's just we know that there are two two
trinity forces in hand. So that really
doesn't get the job done so much. Maybe
just stacking a lot of might, but then
you have to be able to threaten both. So
>> play clean, get the the the sabotage
down first.
>> Ooh. Okay. So salvage or sub um or
singularity. Singularity of course
doesn't do anything against the camo.
>> Yep. So that you can kind of ignore for
now as Irene will note down the rest of
the hand. So it's machine evangel
captain I'm pretty sure that is as uh we
get ready for the final turns you have
to feel like of this game. Colin being
on six means that you're threatening
every single turn. If I just hold with
one recruit you have to be able to clear
me out once I tick up to seven. Just got
to hold with one recruit at all times.
or resolution we know can quickly jump
can quickly leaprog with the uh multiple
Trinity Force.
>> Okay, we have Trinity Force but that how
many runes does that leave open? Four.
>> Yeah. So to play both out if you wanted
to would be everything. So you kind of
have to represent the Relentless
Pursuit, right? Like you
>> Yes. You have to use the relentless
pursuit in a way that will stop your
opponent also from conquering this for
the winning point. So here
it's going to be the Oh, he allows Colin
to go to seven because I was thinking
maybe we play the Relentless Push right
now.
>> You know, it's ripping off the top now.
If it's an Imperial decree, Colin wins
the game just off trading a recruit. So
it's all down to what the top deck is.
We've just had the sabotage come
through. It's a card shop. So,
you can take the the the beat here
because you know if it's an Imperial
degree, Colin slams that and just wins
the game.
>> And obviously, I was wrong because now
whether I think about it for more than 5
seconds before speaking my mind.
Obviously, playing relentless pursuit
when there are four recruits in the base
makes no sense, right?
>> Because then you have to use the second
Relentless Pursuit, tap out.
>> Yeah. and just get to one battlefield
and then you're on me and your opponent
here. You have a little bit more options
potentially and your opponent has to
play around more stuff because you have
four open. So let's see what Colin will
do in this position. And it is kind of
tricky though for for Irene from here
where you have to clear out both
battlefields on your turn every single
time now for the rest of the game. Like
you cannot let just a recruit sit there.
So
>> there's work to be done still for Irene
to be able to come back into this one.
You feel like Colin just has to weave
their way past that that the the Ruin
Runner is a little bit bigger than you
would like. It's not manageable without
uh Imperial Decree, especially with that
singularity not being in effect. Those
of you perhaps that are not familiar
with Ruin Runner. I know that we do have
u I believe it's Chinese version of Rune
Runner on the screen. Ruin Runner cannot
be the target of spells or abilities
your opponents control. So, singularity
is not available to take that out. It
essentially is protected from the
majority of what Colin wants to do. But
we are only one cull the week or one
Imperial decree away from Colin feeling
a little bit more secure. Irene's going
to show the hand say I don't really have
enough to get over this on the next
>> No, he he won't. That was a um Skyfall
and
>> So he shows him the uh the combo. Okay,
so we'll be able to hold both.
>> Oh, no. Wait, no, never mind. I missed
it. I was very confused. I thought he
can do
>> I I thought I thought he was uh showing
him the hand as if Nah, I got nothing. I
got nothing.
>> Okay, never mind then. I'm confused.
Yeah, sorry for that.
>> That's all right. It It was one of those
ones where to be fair to you. Lucian is
one of those decks where you're like,
"Yeah, I'll go from four or five to
>> He would go to five by holding then you
can play the combo."
>> Oh, hey, I wasn't wrong.
>> Let's like rewind the tape. Rewind the
tape. We're going back. So, I'm going to
cut under the confusion and say we are
going to game three. That was indeed
Colin.
>> I am redeemed.
>> As I said, Lucian, one of those decks
where you can jump from four to eight
really quickly with the right setup. So,
uh we we all just kind of swerved
ourselves a little bit there. I did
think when Colin put his uh his Victor
back into his pot, I was like, "Wow,
Colin likes to reset the board state
before he puts his deck away."
>> Yeah. I was like like thinking, yeah,
you can win from this board set with
with delusion. I know it sounds weird,
but you can. You can. You definitely
can.
>> Yeah, especially when you see Colin
stacking a board of just a massive
amount of recruits. I'm like, huh? Okay.
I Yeah. Anyway, we're in the middle of
the day. We talked earlier about how do
you keep uh how do you keep your head
straight when you're playing the game?
How do we keep our heads on while we're
commentating the game?
>> Maybe we should explain to someone who's
actually not accustomed to Lucian. So
what happened here is on the hold turn
because of Trinity Force the Lucian
player went from four to six and then
we're able to attach the Skyfall change
the uh the text from holding Omry to
also concur. Right? So that's the combo.
That's the Skyfall and Trinity Force.
Relentless Pursuit goes to the
battlefield wins the combat. Gets two
points for concurring. Finishes up the
game. So that's what that's literally
what happened over here. we just jumped
like very quickly because the player
just flashed the cards and said, "Yep,
I'm winning over here." Uh so, but yeah,
if you're not accustomed to Lucian, it
can be a little bit confusing that
something like this can happen.
>> Yeah, certainly certainly can be as uh
you know, this deck has a lot of
configurations that can generate
multiple points as you said from your
conquering, becoming holding and and the
way that that works with multiple
>> I one thing I don't know is I I don't
think he had the Skyfall in his hand.
>> He showed it. Yeah. Yeah. I think I
think it didn't before. Ah, okay.
>> I I can't remember it being in hands. I
was like, did he top deck it in that
turn? Because that would be crazy.
>> It would be. It would be. If only you
and I were looking at the screen.
>> No, I mean, yeah, sometimes I do.
>> Sometimes. That's the secret to casting.
We look at each other for even half a
second and something happens and you
blink and you're like, "Wait, the whole
game state changed. What happened? What
did I miss?
>> There there's no sound. We don't know
what they're saying." No.
>> I do love hearing table banter when we
can. That that is always uh always fun.
As somebody who used to play uh play at
the high level, I I'm sure you had many
a fun conversation uh over a tense tense
board state as we go to a tense game
three. Still plenty of time left on the
clock for this round. We're not worried
about timing yet.
>> No. Okay.
So, didn't quite get a look.
>> We have turn one player is going to be
what?
>> Sabotage.
>> You could sabotage, but it does damp
you.
>> So, we're just going to go with
illusion. Ooh, okay.
>> Which is always an option on when you're
playing when you're playing second. I
always want to say on the draw, but
that's not the right terminology for
this. So, when you're playing second,
you do uh as Lucian always have that
option from the chosen champion zone.
>> Yeah. And this time it's Colin on the
arena's greatest. He's the aggressor to
some degree.
>> We will see how the tempo goes from
that. Sunken Temple, the battlefield
choice from Irene. There is the Lucian
that we talked about just played out and
passes over to Colin. So now now is that
that moment of is there a cold week? Is
there a way of dealing with the Lucian?
But we haven't seen it so far.
>> We didn't see a single cold week.
>> Uh I haven't really seen them from from
Colin so far.
>> Oh yeah, that's what I'm thinking. It's
like
>> we did see as this coming into it and I
didn't I didn't take notes that it was
missing, but I will double check the the
deck list after this. You know what?
Actually, I think I have the technology.
We have
>> I think I have the technology to take a
little look.
>> All right, so Lucian goes in, conquers,
goes back to the base. Very standard
behavior over here. And now we have
accelerated Kaisa. No, not accelerated
Kai'Sa just to base. And this is a turn
when a singularity says, "Oh my, that's
a lot of value." Is there a singularity?
It would have been windmill slammed on
the board, I think, if there was one.
>> Right. But it could have been unyielding
spirited as well.
>> There is a similarity.
>> There's two. There's two in hand.
>> Well, you can only play one.
>> But you know what I mean? It's like
>> I mean he was so sure he has multiple.
>> Colin was just thinking like what what
is happening if there will be unyielding
spirit? Do I come back if there is an
unyielding spiring spirit that will
counter the damage uh from the
singularity? If the answer is no, it's
like I don't come back. Maybe there
would there could be a consideration of
not playing it. But if the answer is I
will probably even come back from that
then yeah that singularity is probably
coming down all the time but it's just
too juicy not to play I feel.
>> Yeah it's so so good at this point and
again we talked about how Ruin Runner
isn't susceptible to singularity. So you
get your two good targets from this
deck. Uh I mean forrunner as well as you
said but you get two very valuable juicy
targets with that singularity as now
these recruits I mean we said it was
Collins arena's greatest. Now, you know,
starting at one point, goes to two
early, jumps to four, and now is is
difficult because this solution deck can
can deal with one battlefield quite
quickly with something that's, you know,
a little bit explosive. But dealing with
both at the same time isn't exactly the
strength from this board state where you
have no units. You you really need a
presence to be able to fight that.
>> You would have to essentially like
accelerate a unit and then do relentless
pursuit for example. Yeah. And that
would be actually very doable. One more
energy like five five energy Kai'Sa into
relentless pursuit. You're drawing two
cards and you did of course paid two
power but you were able to um three in
conquer both uh battlefields.
What do we have? What are we what are we
doing here? We have two energy left.
We're passing it to Victor.
And Victor is at five points. Yeah,
Colin goes to five. So, we'll now need
to try and keep that point tempo
on the even footing. Singularity on one
unit is never never a good feeling, but
there's always that option. I think you
got to wait a little bit.
>> Do you just give your opponent's cards
in hand and say, "Okay, I've got a
hidden blade. I'll uh deal with that."
They'll say, "Ah, you're going to draw a
lot."
>> He could force his opponent to react.
Like for example, one of the options
could be could be trying to stupify
attacking Zenza, forcing opponent to do
something about this and then if he does
something about this, you hit him blade
if it's like punch first for example.
>> Sure.
>> Right. So that could have been one of
the things here. Instead of the stupify,
we're just putting another unit
>> going to go in just pure might on top of
>> mice. And this will probably be met with
a hidden blade over here, right?
Although it does damp Colin pretty
significantly because he already played
the Zenzho with the one yellow and in
this case he needs to find some form of
a solution. So he has six might the
opponent has eight and he can play
stupify to get him to seven. So that
doesn't solve the problem. So that's the
hidden blade. I like the sequence of
plays like from both players over here.
This this makes a lot of sense.
>> Can you just say there's more value in
going to six and having the battlefield
>> than your two cards in hand?
>> Correct. Like at this point, the game is
going to finish before his opponent is
going to be able to use most of the
cards.
>> So, it doesn't really matter if you give
those two cards right now. I mean, most
likely it doesn't matter. It gives more
options, but not probably like long-term
um and in in this case, like there's a
win condition already on the board.
Yeah, it's representing lethal at this
point um to close this one out as I mean
it really comes down to that singularity
though putting the two units like
unprotected. It's a risk that sometimes
you have to take early on in the game
cuz you're like if this pays off I'm in
control. I'm in full control of the
game. But singularity makes it very
difficult for Irene to actually maintain
a board state. And now there's so much
going to be spent at playing any units
that then making them strong enough to
compete. And I'm seeing a handful of of
all equipment.
>> Is there a there's a rare guard. The
rare guard is I think so last the the
right side.
>> Yeah, there's two units at the back of
the house.
>> So you can use there's six power six
might sorry on arena's greatest and what
you can do is play rare god for two play
equipment then do relentless assault and
sorry relentless pursuit. equip the
equipment for free, move your unit, and
essentially uh have in this case five
assault, which is still not enough. The
problem is that you kind of have to you
kind of also have to guard one of the
battlefields because your opponent has
two tokens in the in the base that can
conquer anything. This comes back to one
of the points that I made earlier uh
like three hours ago. Those are talking
about the fact that it doesn't matter
how much might you have. It's about the
units that they can just walk in and
take control of a battlefield and get
you a point. It can be a scuttle crab in
the next expansion with zero.
>> Oh, it will be. I guarantee
>> and you can win with that, you know. So,
here um Lucian is under huge amount of
pressure
>> because those those tokens are infinite
strength at some point. You know,
>> you can see Irene going through just if
you do this, I do that. And that there's
only so many options in hand.
Singularity is an option to deal with
most things. Bellow's breath is going to
be another one to remove both of the
removal spells or at least the the
damage abilities. He has to. So now it's
okay. What can I play this turn in order
to represent presence on
>> Oh, we're actually accelerating it.
>> Okay. Does have the rear guard
accelerated. gets onto the battlefield
and just is going to stack one first
mate.
>> Okay, so I was thinking that maybe we're
going to utilize one of the equipment
pieces.
>> So I guess this is saying
>> he's playing around cold the week. I
guess
>> I guess this is saying can I on my next
turn make enough?
>> Okay, that's better to be it now.
Bellow's breath.
>> Bellow's breath on top finds it. That is
going to be the game as Colin is going
to take the series two games to one.
Victor, first time we're seeing win.
>> Quick games, by the way.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We still got 20 minutes left
on the round.
>> Yeah. Maybe we'll get another match. I
don't know. We'll see. But uh this is a
pretty convincing win. I would say the
game two was I felt like fully almost
fully under control from Colin and then
the combo just finished off the game,
you know.
>> Yeah. But it it is it is pretty
significant. Like I would say this is
the moment for Victor to strike as well.
I feel like Victor and Rexai have the
best possibility of actually being for
the first time in like an really big
tournament and making some splash on the
results because there there's a lot of
Victor haters out there. I I'll tell you
that you know there's a lot of people
who are saying this is not a good deck.
It's not a good in the meta game. Stop
stop talking about this deck and so on,
you know. But I feel like in a in the
hands of a good player, I feel like this
deck can really do well.
>> Well, Colin is a good player and he
proves that in round four of taking the
victory there. Yeah, I think that was um
you know that singularity in game three
is make or break, right? Sometimes you
do just have those board states where
you're like, I have the one answer that
shuts you down for long enough.
>> In this case, he had two singularities.
>> Exactly. He had two two at that point,
which seems thematically not quite in
line with singularity. It's like the
That is true. But also, but I I was
hoping that maybe Colin is going to do
the Danny DeVito impressions. I started
blasting, you know,
>> that I now I want to hear the Danny
DeVito impression. Uh that that's
something
>> can also kind of apply to Bellow's
breath.
>> Okay. Yeah. No, true. Exactly. because
uh we saw the the strength of some of
these direct damage spells coming
through where you know in the past we've
had Kaiser with direct damage spells and
it's not something that a lot of decks
play around in Riftbound because I think
some of the way of healing after combat
kind of prevents direct damage. I've
always felt that like cards like smokec
screen which reduce might for the turn
have a wider impact than direct damage
cuz damage heals up. But it's
interesting to see like the Imperial
Decree damage combination on top of each
other. It's difficult to play around.
>> What you're saying is it would be so
different if reducing might would be
able to kill a unit.
>> Yes. Exactly.
>> Because then it would be much much
stronger than any damage. But in this
case, and that's what I really like
about this kind of interaction, it
>> there are limits to how a card can be
utilized, but there are combinations
where the cards are becoming much more
efficient. Just like you said, like you
can do the reducing the might, dealing
the damage at the same time. You can
reduce something to zero might, it still
lives, but the moment it gets slapped
with a leaf or something and it just get
knocked off of the board, you know. So,
um I feel like this kind of of of
systems that we have in place for rift
bound make the um the choices that we do
very interesting. And I it's something
that we spoke about as well behind
camera is I feel like
>> riftbound is more like a hybrid between
card game and a board game at the same
time. And I feel like those kind of
interactions like the damage and the
might being different and affecting the
boats different are falling exactly in
the way that a board is a board game
would work you know and that is very
interesting like with the movement and
affecting the the might of the units for
the end turn healing at the end of the
turn. the damage not permanent. Those
are very conscious decision in game
design that make this game work.
>> Yeah. And there's a lot of interesting
space still to design into. We've got
unleash coming up soon. But what we have
coming up for you right now is an
interview with Barcode.
>> Sorry, I thought we had an interview. I
I'm being differently. I was uh I was I
was down the rabbit hole because I heard
that we might be dropping in on an
interview. Uh anyway, let's let's go
back. We We're talking about round four.
It's okay. We're live. It's uh Yeah,
>> it's a live show.
You We better be glued to the screen. I
might do something really stupid at some
point.
>> You can't miss a moment of of when we're
going to going to going to have a faux
paw like that. So, um yes, we were
talking about design space. I mentioned
unleash. We were talking about damage.
And I was even thinking about it in the
leadup. I was like, if we have time, I
want to mention the card that everybody
thinks is going to be broken. And I
agree, but Elder Dragon is going to be
one of those ones where again points of
damage like aren't just one thing, it's
going to kill. Like the Elder Dragon is
>> when an enemy unit takes any amount of
damage, it will die.
>> Also from combat damage from any unit.
So one of the combos that you can play
in unleashed is going to be Poppy, for
example, Aurora that plays Vangard
Armory. And then the elder dragon just
sits in the base and is chilling, you
know, and the small tokens are just
taking care of everything on the board.
>> This sounds great. Uh, one of the
players in my local game store is a
Poppy main. I'm pretty sure they're like
masters ranking. They're going to be
that's the deck they're going to play.
So, uh, I I might have to lend them my
my Auroras to do that. Or I play Poppy
and I I will be the one uh with the the
Elder Dragon. I just have to crack
enough packs to go find an Elder Dragon.
So, uh, I'll maybe I'll just let you
handle the rest of the show. Clearly,
I'm clearly I'm not cut out for it. So,
we'll, uh,
>> well, we have to wait for Unleash to be
released in what, 10th of May, I think.
>> Yeah, it's soon. It's soon. Uh, check
the the Riftbound website to to find out
exactly when. Um, I've been told that
the interview is ready and it is with
Blevens.
>> Hey everyone, it's me, Blevins. I didn't
win, but we have a winners interview
here with Colin, who took down my dearly
beloved Lucian with Victor. How do you
feel after that match?
>> Uh, excellent. The deck's been doing
well for me so far. So, uh, undefeated
so far, and hopefully that trend stays.
>> Yeah, I obviously congrats on being
undefeated. How do you feel about the
Lucian matchup in general?
>> Uh, I think it's very good for Victor,
fortunately enough.
>> The word un unlsable comes to mind when
I think about that matchup. I think
there are things that Lucian could do to
make it a little bit better. Uh, but
historically, Lucian have not boarded a
lot of the cards that you need for the
Victor matchup just because, you know,
it's very hard going into a tournament
as big as this one, even though I
believe Victor's like the fourth most
played deck or fifth most played deck.
It's only about 6% of the field. So,
dedicating sideboard slots specifically
to Victor is difficult. So, uh, we see
Ruin Runner is their most common card,
but Unyielding Spirit would be the best
card in this specific matchup, but it's
really only good into Victor, which is
why, uh, I know that they typically
don't play it,
>> right? Yeah, it's uh, it it's Ferris
Morrunner and and Ruin Runner, and we
saw you deal with both of those cards
quite well. I mean, were you prepared?
Obviously, you were prepared, but were
you thinking about those cards coming
into this tournament?
>> Um, a little bit. Rununner is not
something that's quite as common, but
Ferris 4Runner is kind of the the card
of the card. Yeah. Right. Uh every deck
is coming in with a game plan to either
play Ferris 4Runner or beat Ferris
4Runner, I believe. Uh just because it's
the most uh powerful card coming into
this current meta. So, it's a little bit
strange playing Victor into that card,
but I find that so long as I have my
decree plus bellows, they're holding
with the uh the forerunner, then you
just do what uh you saw there in both of
those games where I just come in, I run
over the um or run over it, play the
Imperial decree to kill it, it spawns
the tokens in the back, and then the
afterwards. It's nice, clean, and easy,
which uh makes my heart break as the
Lucian player, but obviously in your
seat, that's a that's a pretty good
feeling to be able to take it out
>> for sure.
>> Now, you if I remember correctly, you
were not on Victor before this meta,
right? You were on the detonate Draven
deck.
>> I was on normal Miracle Draven.
>> A normal normal miracle Draven, right?
So, obviously the bands came, shaped up,
changed things up a lot. What What put
you on Victor for this event? Uh,
honestly, I was looking for a deck that
I think had kind of game into
everything. I very much so like playing
the style of deck that is a little bit
under reppresented, but also has uh some
sort of good plan into pretty much all
of the top meta decks and I believe
Victor is at that point. Um, I
definitely don't think it's the best
deck by any means, but it has potential
game into all the top decks, which is
what I love to see. So, um, I wanted to
try something new. I try to be as um
wide of a player as possible and not
commit myself to any strategy, which is
funny because I was a set guy in set
one. Everyone still comes up to me
today. I can't tell you the number of
people that just came up and were like,
"Oh, you're the set guy from set one."
I'm like, "Yeah,
>> I'm hoping to maybe I can become the
Victor guy or the Draven guy, whatever
it may be."
>> Yeah. Whatever gets you the, you know,
the top prize. It doesn't really matter
what that is.
>> Exactly. I just want to be the guy. I
want to be the Riftbound guy.
>> Yeah. Yeah, the Riftbound guy is one to
uh to uh strive to be for sure. Now,
obviously, this is the biggest event
that we've had for a regional qualifier
yet. It's here in Le. Did you do any
specific prep or anything different for
this event compared to the other events?
>> Uh, honestly, it was very interesting
coming into this because of the new band
list. It's shaped up
>> for basically an entirely new format. Me
and my team, we're calling it set 2.5,
right? Where um it's just a completely
different format that we had to test
for. Obviously, we still see a lot of
the main stays. Draven is still
playable. Really is still playable, but
how every matchup plays changes
drastically now with the removal of
cards like Fight or Flight.
>> Absolutely.
>> Um, we definitely did a bunch of testing
as soon as the ban list dropped. We're
like, "Oh, well, I guess we have to I
have to completely try this new format
and uh I I just kind of gravitated
towards Victor
>> pretty pretty early on. For whatever
reason, it just did well for me."
>> Well, there you go. Had to had to throw
all of the testing out, but guess what?
It's working so far for Colin, of
course, our winner here. Congrats on the
40. Good luck in the rest of the event.
But that is going to be it for this one.
We'll send it back to the desk.
>> Thank you so much.
>> And then I started blasting
>> and then you started blasting. Thank you
so much by Vincent Colin. Uh we'll see
if Colin can become the Riftbank guy.
There's a lot of Riftbound people in
this room that want to be of the
Riftbound person. So, uh it's a a tough
field to get past. Uh we're still in
round four. We are getting through
towards our second feature match. Let's
jump right into the middle of the
action. Let's see where we are. See who
we've got. Uh looks like we are jumping
into three with Prisman playing Annie
>> going up against P. Oh, I'm going to
have to read that.
>> Panda Panda Anaconda. No, wait.
Panaconda.
Pandaconda. Panda. actually a mutated
Anaconda.
>> We'll see if Pandaconda do or
Pandanaconda don't from this match cuz
it is the last game of a best of three.
>> Pay attention to the battlefields. One
says, "Ah, game's shorter." The other
one says, "Nah, game's longer."
>> So, essentially, we're playing to eight.
>> Yeah, it is equilibrium. We're going to
have uh Sean Ben Shan Bean come into the
scene as well.
>> Your movie references are on point. I
need to watch more movies. I uh I'm not
quite on the level. You you'd do well
with Blevens. Blevens and you would go
down a rabbit hole of of references.
Yeah. Um he's already made a Matilda
reference this weekend and I was not
expecting it. As Annie will begin things
out with a traveling merchant and it's a
guardian angel played on the side of
Pandanaconda. Now that I've learned how
to say it, I will say it about as much
as I can.
>> Did our opponent miss the trigger from
Arena's Greatness?
>> Ooh, that's painful. If he did miss it,
that is a little bit problematic because
now he's actually going to be playing
the longer game.
>> Yeah, of course, for for those
>> No, never mind.
>> Okay, it has been added. I was going to
say for those of you at home, um the the
rules were changed on Aspirin's climb.
If you remember within Sorry, on Arena's
greatest. If you remember within your
first turn, doesn't have to be at the
beginning phase, then you are able to
add that point at competitive rail. Um
correct. Obviously, if you're at your
nexus night and you're still learning,
maybe be nice. Maybe uh maybe give the
point lower. I I'll give you an advice.
When you're playing at Nexus Night,
don't be an ass. Just Just be nice and
play with with the people that are
there. Everyone wants to have fun. It's
a hobby first and foremost. Building
your local community is incredibly
important. Uh in in my local store, we
rewind very often.
>> That's fair.
>> You know, it's like if no informations
were done or something like Yeah, sure.
Rewind that. We are not playing for like
>> golden metal foil here.
>> Half of your stores seem to be at
Bolognia. I feel like
>> that is true. I feel like a lot of
competitive from the the Polish
community were uh were were traveling
down. I think it was like 200, right?
But this game I think we need to zoom in
a little bit on Prismat has played a
stack deck. That is what we are having
resolved. The Aurelia now on board with
the guardian angel attached is one of in
my mind like the scariest combinations
cuz she is very difficult to take down
and then a G on top of it. Um, this is
one of the only moments where
Pandanaconda's shields are going to be
down like tapped out with no runes out
for a defy or a defiant dance. Like
there's a lot of of combat tricks and
spells that Aurelia can bring to this
game.
>> Mhm. And uh the problem is for Panda I
am not able to panda panda panda p
>> just say one for panda. I'm just going
to ignore the snake part. Ex. So,
exactly.
>> Um, he's being open because now, as you
said, he has no energy and now any kind
of buffs like blood rush, claves will be
able to go over the um uh uh go over the
the Aurelia, but we see Prismatism is
playing way slower game. He's not trying
to destroy this Urelia to um because the
because of the G. Even if he goes over
with like a blood blood rush or cleave,
the Urelia is still going to be in base
and then he is now utilizing energy that
is not going to be advancing his board
state in case of Ferrosana.
>> Yeah,
>> this is something that we spoke about so
much. Yeah. In already previous matches,
the the Ferris Fana, if it's not met
with a rebuke, it is putting a big
problem, a big stop sign for Radia
players because you have to utilize your
buffs in your turn to go over it, right?
Because you're not you have to at least
play one card to essentially have more
power, more might than the Ferris
Forana. And if you do that, then two
mechs going back to base are not going
to be able to do a counter strike. And
now you have to find more answers for
the un ongoing oncoming ga damage.
>> And this is where Annie makes it even
more difficult because Annie can just
tap out like use all runes on her turn
and say, "Oh yeah, I'll just keep two
up. I'll keep up enough for for many
many options." And okay, some of the the
cards have been banned. Like Fighter
Flight's gone. That's not a problem. But
Rebuke is still there for those that
play. There are also other cards. Flash
is still there. Rebuke actually, we were
looking at the stats earlier, the most
played card of the tournament on deck
list. It does make sense. If you're
running purple, you at least are going
to have a copy of it in your deck.
>> It's specifically needed just against
Ferris for honors. So, if you're playing
a purple deck, there's no way that you
don't have like two copies of Rebuke
into your in your deck or at least
inside board. But here, the entire game
is slowing down and
this board state is going to be a little
bit more open, I would say. So, I'm
going to talk a little bit something
different. I wanted to talk about the
fact that prismatism uh
>> do they on on purpose just choose two of
the names the hardest names on the
planet to weed out for a Polish person.
>> Panda and Prismat. We can keep it as
>> Yeah, let's do that. Panda and Prisma.
Prismat. So Prismat is choosing a deck
that I feel like is very
underrepresented and it was under the
radar as well in the entire meta game.
And if I'm not mistaken, this is going
to be because of the arena's greatest
because of the purple color. I feel like
this is going to be a aggro deck with
sneaky deck hands and the right the
winds. It's probably going to be that
kind of deck, right? Because Yeah, I for
sure. For sure. I didn't see the deck
list, but I think it's it's going to be
this this kind of build. And this kind
of build can go underneath the tempo of
so many other decks that are playing a
slower game after the bands, right? So,
you're going to be able to catch people
off guard. This it's kind of similar
with Darius and Rexite. They can also go
underneath the opponents and try to be
super aggressive. But in case of purple,
you're going to be able to get the
points during your opponent's turn with
right the wind. Essentially, if you were
listening to my cast before, I was
explaining how this is the way of
actually aggroing the game in Riftbound
because you are um shortening the the
this this the game by getting points in
your opponent's turn, which you're
typically not able to do, right? So
that's most likely going to be the way
that a prismat will try to finish off
the game as soon as possible and will
have to find a way of controlling the
board state till she will be able to get
a double conquer with the gank. That is
going to be the game plan. I feel like
at least that is something that Panda
will have to find a way of not losing to
right the winds essentially.
>> Right. So like defies and hands are
going to have to be kept for that
specific reason if possible because
that's not always a thing that you're
going to be able to do.
>> Yeah, that is uh a very fair point and
something we'll keep an eye on. There
are two in hand right now for Pan
Anaconda as uh two Kaisers in base from
Prisma. We're into a showdown
on Aspirin's climb. It is going to be
Aurelia taking that down. Prismat not
utilizing anything at this point in
time. Yeah. His small units are
essentially saying, "I'm getting one
point and I'm dying."
>> Yeah.
>> The big units will do the other point
for me.
>> Yes.
>> So they're like sacrificial lamps
for for the Annie players.
>> This is And by the way, if you never
played Aurelia, it's a really complex
deck. I was thinking like, eh, it's not
that hard to play. It's just what? It's
just one unit. you just play you you
just you know you get card draw you
spells you spells and you just easily
just overcome every battle. But
specifically after the bands when I
tried it, I was like, "Wow, this deck is
actually pretty tight when it comes to
amount of resources and cards you have,
unless you get the best opener, which is
probably like guardian angel into
Stellacon
>> Herd." Oo, and this is a a piece of tech
that we saw um you know, a couple months
back people starting to build Rengar in
>> Mhm.
>> doesn't actually uh end up
>> But the thing is
>> doing more than putting a body.
You can use the Renga on your opponent's
turn by putting it as a surprise
defender as well on the battlefield that
you control.
>> That's the main thing as well. But
playing a unit on your opponent's turn
into your base essentially makes it
ready
>> accelerate but but yeah the pseudo
acceleration
>> and this is the synergy that we have
here because Annie can leave now one
open on her turn on top two and suddenly
there's a free unit.
>> Suddenly it turns into Rengar. Yeah,
exactly.
Suddenly a cat, you know, this is a
>> something we're going to have to get
used to as well through Unleashed with
the ambush mechanic coming through in a
kind of a similar way. There's some some
some differences in that one, but
>> okay, this is the first time I'm seeing
this.
>> Two Kaisers conquer, two Kaisers draw.
Thank you very much.
>> Since set one, I have not seen a double
Kaiser conquer.
>> It's because nobody normally lets two
Kaisers sit on the board. Normally,
you're like, one Kaiser, I got to get
rid of that.
>> But yeah, that is a very fair point.
Rarely do you see uh two Kaisers uh
>> remember we're playing to nine points by
the way is already at true I made the
joke about going to eight but uh it's
eight points need to be scored but the
total will be nine from Arena's greatest
and aspirants climb um since both get
that first point of the game to
>> energy open this is like really looking
grim for foria for now at least because
there's potentially how much might
coming in 11 from those me
>> because of the assault as well. Oh,
there's Oh,
>> Prisman just has like the best cards of
origins and remaining from Spirit Forge
on the board. It's like, hey, so Kaiser
is great. Uh, Ferris Forerunner is
great. And then I got a handful of cards
as well, and I'm going to untap some
some runes at the end. So, why don't I
just put them all on the board and see
what happens?
>> I'm really liking this Annie. It just
looks like a very aggressive deck and uh
utilizes the powerful cards in the
environment currently. Right. We have
the Ferris Forrunners, we have the Kais,
we probably also have Darius's, although
might not be the case because we have to
find space for other cards like Right
Winds
>> uh and uh Rengar.
>> That's exactly it. You got to find some
space somewhere. And what what are you
cutting? Meanwhile, on the other side of
the table,
>> this is where Pandan is going to have to
really go in the tank and figure out,
okay, how do I sequence my turn to get
the most out of it? because I'm I'm in
trouble. I'm up against it, but it is
not over. Like, how many cards can I
draw? How many actions can I take to uh
to ready Urelia? How many pump spells
can I play? Which of these things is
going to allow me to conquer over that
battlefield? Cuz that is a big
battlefield. 17 if our counting is
correct.
>> Let's point out to the new feature.
>> I used it. I was like, I'm going to
double check it. But yeah, down at the
bottom you can see our live might
tracker for the board game. two for the
for the board state I should say. Two
Kaisers, Ferris Forrunner and a mech. We
will keep keep track of that as uh as
any spells and abilities are used.
Prismat doing the due diligence just to
say, okay, how do we how do I make sure
I really hold this?
>> Mhm. Calculating an attack into this
Aelia is like very tough. It's like four
open. What do you count?
>> Yeah, 17 feels safe uh at least for
holding on the next turn, but it's not
not against Aelia. you we've seen him go
higher than that. Um
>> but the thing is this Urelia if she
burst out like this to conquer the other
battlefield she will be very low on
cards. Not only that she also going to
be all tapped out and that that is
making an opening possible for Prisma.
Of course let's remember there's that GA
on that Ielia that are the boots of
swiftness there and what was the third
thing?
>> Um that is a great question. slightly
covered over
>> Doran's ring.
>> Yeah, I I didn't actually see it when it
got got placed
to wear two pairs to to wear two boots.
Yeah. Um the other thing is like it's
not in in the hand right now, but then
you're looking at like can I charm
something over? Do I have a way of
interacting with my opponent's board
state? Break it up a little bit. Make
their following turn a little bit uh
trickier to play out. But this is this
is where you got to really get in that
tank. really think through the the
downside is when you're going to have um
combat spells in hand, you you're kind
of hoping you got discipline and defiant
dance cuz at least you're either then
getting a minus or for discipline a card
draw to get another option
>> in this case kind of just stuck to
what's in hand.
>> Yeah, it was even more important. Oh,
there are like three counter spells. Oh
my
>> Yeah,
>> and Annie is like not even using spells
right now. But the thing is even if you
use like the divine dance and like in
gods for example there are cards out of
your hand discipline is fantastic
because gives you plus three
but it can fuel you still and also
what's even more important
>> the fine dance
>> would damp you and I feel like this is
still a spot where six energy is not
really that comfortable. Yeah,
>> that's fair.
>> And but the biggest problem is if we
don't find a solution to the resources
in our hand as Elia, we're going to just
let the Annie just hold infinitely or
like if we're going in and try to um
conquer the battlefield, then we're
going to get pushed away back and then
we don't have any pump spells and we
can't really do anything anymore. So, um
there is this like very delicate state
where Panda has to plan ahead
>> for the next two turns, but also the
timer is running out because Prismat is
looking at seven points next turn.
>> And the other half of that is, you know,
Annie as a deck runs flash. So, Prismat
can also say like, okay,
>> only for two units, remember. But I
guess my point is Prismatic can say,
"How much do you have to spend to
threaten on this battlefield before I
can just flash out and say, "Yeah, sure.
Use use all your stuff this turn. Next
turn, I'll just bring the 4Runner back
in a Kaiser and I'm representing more
damage than you have spells available."
Like there's a lot of complexity here.
And this is where, you know, accounting
for the worst case scenario out of hand
when you don't have information comes
in.
>> Yeah. And now we see the commitment from
Panda.
>> There is the attack 10 to 17. Right now
you can look at the Oh, there's even a
small text saying showdown. How cute.
>> So we are into the showdown on aspirin's
climb. You're right.
>> 101 17. And in this case, Prismat can
just like chill. He's just going to wait
for Oh, he pass. Okay, so pass pass. We
are killing the Ferris Forana and one
Kaisa. Okay, we're trading that for a
guardian angel. Yeah. Okay, so stay
there. That's a really important
difference. Yeah, now we can try
antapping.
>> See, this is why I don't play Aurelia.
I'm just going to be honest, cuz like
there's a line there that an actual
Aurelia player can see, whereas it's
like, "Yeah, I have G. It's fine. I'll
just trade. I'll trade against your big
thing and go back in."
>> And now we have another attack. Does the
flash
>> saves the Okay.
>> Okay.
>> No more energy. Two units are being
killed. But look at the look at the
board state.
>> That's huge. There's like three max, a
porro, and a Rengar waiting in the
bushes.
>> But we are going to nine, remember? So
you actually can just bring Aelia back.
You could
>> maybe leave it there.
>> But don't Wouldn't it be
>> There are two counter spells. So
>> how much power? How much might do we
have? We have 10.
>> You would have to find desert dance. So
it will bring down
>> essentially it's a plus five, right? Oh,
so we will go to 15 with the Urelia to
opponents 3 6 9 11 uh 16. Okay, never
mind. That is not enough. So, you kind
of have to go back and just say, "Yeah,
I'll let you go to eight." And that's
okay.
>> If you want to go back now, you have you
have to pay for the conquer, which is
one energy, and then you have to use the
defiant dance,
>> which is what I think Panda is is is
perhaps thinking about here because you
can see still in the tank. I'm assuming
that means the conquer has completed and
we're we're we basically have the
decision on the chain of whether you
want No, there's the pass. So, we'll
stay the base. That's a really important
thing is where you're holding where
you're holding the uh the priority or
where you're holding the option to play
that of whether you want to untap on
that
>> as Panda will pass it away.
>> Now, Prismat has much better economy in
in this situation. and has all the runes
in the world that you could want as an
Annie, especially knowing that you're
untapping two. So, Prismat can put
himself up to win the game next turn,
but as far as I'm aware from this
situation, because we're on Aspirin's
climb, because we have to go to nine,
cannot win the game until the next turn.
>> Mhm. Well, there are two ways of playing
this out. I recalling the bluff of the
amount of buffs that the opponent has.
And I think there was a tell already
because in the previous turn, Urelia
just said pass on the initial attack,
which would kind of signal that there
were not that many buffs in the hand
already. So in this case, I would not be
surprised if Prisma just calls the bluff
and attacks. And here we go. We attack
with how much?
>> Uh it's a mech uh
>> mech, porro, and regga. So that's going
to be 10. That's going to be 10. 10 to
eight and that's going to be forcing the
irrelia now to respond.
>> Now we don't know the hand from Prismat.
There can be I I would imagine there's
either going to be another Renga in hand
or a cleave or a blood rush.
>> Definance on the Rengar once the assault
has I mean it can go under thanks to
define dance anyway but the the assault
is already on so it will drop down too.
So it is fine regardless of what happens
>> there. So that will tip the the balance
in Pandaconda's Pandanaconda's uh favor
for this showdown. Again, you can track
the might at the bottom. A card I
haven't seen in a long time of cleave
has fallen out of favor in the meta, but
it will get defied. Prismat feels
perhaps winding up there is the Rengar.
You cannot defy that cat. You cannot
deny the Rengar in this situation. And
that is likely
>> 113
>> to be enough
cuz it's we know it's a not so fast and
a lonely parro in hand and only two
runes not so fast and not quite enough
likely.
>> I love the sequence by the way. Just
wanted to point that out. Prismat starts
with the blood uh sorry with the cleave
to bait out potential counter which will
damp his opponent. He knows that he's
most likely winning this fight anyway
because Renga cannot be affected by any
counter spell. So he's drawing out the
energy and the runes from the opponent.
So he cannot then even if even if he
wins and uh Urelia kills most of the
units, there will be no way of like
playing a a two drop and like going into
a battlefield with too much power
because you will have to spend the equip
and you would have to um also spend the
power for the untap of the Urelia.
>> And now Pandan has to clear both
battlefields on four runes. We know that
there is a unit in hand and there are
two equips for boots
>> and also
>> but that's going to
>> what are we getting? What are we
getting?
>> Stack de comes out from from the Annie
just to to turn the knife a little bit
more.
>> Yeah. And we This is nice. Also, we
don't use the tact deck immediately.
We're going to be using it during the
showdown to change what we
>> It's a defy.
>> Yeah. The tactic is going to be used mid
showdown to just essentially find the
perfect answer. Yeah, that's it. The
fist bump comes out as Pandanaconda will
concede the game to Prismat.
Prismaticism will take down our backup
feature match, our second feature match,
if you will. Uh, and advance from round
four with another win. Uh, running
Annie, a deck that we still see around
the fringes, still there, still has the
potency that Annie always has, but uh,
not one that's right up in the top of
the conversation right now for a lot of
players.
>> For sure under the radar. Um, and wanted
to make a joke about downwell or
somewhere there. But
>> anyway, the point is it's a good aggra
and it's I feel like it might actually
decently perform specifically also when
such a caliber of player like Prismat is
playing it. So would we expecting uh,
you know, some Annie Day too already?
>> Yeah, I I already would at this point.
Um, and you know, if you did make that
joke, it wouldn't go down well.
>> But is going forward well from that
series. Um, you know, the Aurelia we've
seen a lot. Um, I think you and I both
talked about how difficult it is. It's
funny you said about like Aurelia more
complicated uh as a deck perhaps than
you would give it credit for. I would
say it's a really easy deck to play
badly. Uh, which is not what we're
seeing here at the uh the thankfully.
I'm I'm the best example of that. I'm
just like I'll try and score one point
per turn. It is very complex to like
balance that economy, the number of
cards in hand, like the number of game
actions because you you can easily miss
a point of might or two or if you
sequence things wrong, you don't get the
untap. Um that game that game three that
we saw came down to somewhat economy and
card draw. Sometimes with Aurelia, you
do get a hand of of Defies, not so fast,
and ong guards, which means well, you're
not refilling, you're not getting extra
cards. Dreaming tree is where that
punishes because on guard used to
basically have brackets of like if you
do this to the dreaming tree, draw a
card anyway. Discipline used to be
brackets draw two basically.
>> Exactly. Like in the previous meta game,
you never had the problem of like
thinking, oh, I'm going to be running
out of resources essentially because you
had a refill almost every single time.
But now if you could, you would just be
playing six like herders because
otherwise you're going to have an issue
of not having enough cards, right? But
if the deck hits the Celicon Herder and
is able to just ramp up the movement and
just have like an obscene hand of eight
or nine cards, then the deck is becoming
just absurd in in the potential of what
it can do. But you need to draw Steelon
Herder. And now the question is, if you
don't draw the Stellon Herder, how do
you play the game efficiently if you're
good enough to actually get enough of
value from the game, from the deck
itself to win those games?
>> That's a really good question. Celicorn
Herder, one of the absolutely most
impactful cards from Spirit Forged, and
we're kind of getting to the the end of
the window of Spirit Forged. We're about
to unleash some more cards on the
Riftbound uh card pool. So, let's find
out a little bit more of them about find
out a little bit more about the cards
that are coming in unleashed with
Blevens and Amy.
Hello everyone and welcome back. We're
going to be talking about the new
Riftbound set, Unleashed. We've got a
lot to talk about. I'm Blevens joined
with Amy. And Amy, we have got a ton of
new mechanics and new just awesome
things to talk about here with
Unleashed. Starting off with the XP
mechanic. This is a brand new one. We're
having an additional resource here to
generate and and actually be able to
spend and even build up to increase your
level here. Amy, what are you thinking
about XP?
>> I think XP is not only a fantastic
mechanic moving forward, but also
something that allows you to circumvent
the style of gameplay that you're
forcing your opponent through. You're
forcing them through rings that they
haven't had to jump through before.
you're forcing them to play the game not
to lose because the advantage you gain
from gaining XP and the generation of
that XP can be so vital and can be
crushing if your opponent leaves it
unchecked.
>> Yeah. And if there's one thing I like,
it is a miniame and XP can be its own
miniame. Whether you are getting XP to
spend with cards like Kha'Zix and
legends like Kha'Zix or or if you're
trying to get up to a higher level with
Master Yi and other other cards like
that that is really awesome.
>> Another mechanic in the XP vein and it's
actually a one of the premier ways to
get XP in Unleashed is hunt. So when
you're conquering or holding with a hunt
unit, you're going to be getting XP
equal to its hunt value.